the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
the grand chess tour kicked off with the
super bet chess classic in bucharest the
best players in the world are putting on
a show in the capital of romania the
first round started off with sizzling
games across the boards but most
simmered into fighting draws however a
draw was not enough for american wesley
so who took down returning champ
chakriar mamadiarov in an exciting win
the rust has been knocked off and the
top players in the world are ready to
shine
day two of world class chess from
romania coming up next
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back everybody to day two of the
super bed chess classic the inaugural
stop of the 2022 grand chess tour behind
me is the majestic statue of carol the
first one of the most influential kings
in romania's history the players have
duked it out in day one and are ready to
continue the action in day two let's go
to the studio and start today's round
with yasser peter and alejandro
welcome to our continued coverage of the
superb chess classic from the sunny
romania
uh day two in front of us very exciting
times
i'm just going to admit to you i've had
a little bit of a bagel
and i'm still finishing it
nice and i'm
ashamed to admit it but there we are
it's uh
five to seven in the morning i'm peter
svidler and with me is uh yassas here
welcome everybody day two of romanian
chess classic you did that perfectly
well i mean
peter you're the best hello everyone and
welcome to our coverage of day two
indeed as peter said uh it's early here
in st louis but we're happy to be with
you and thank you for sharing your day
with us as always it's a pleasure to be
with peter and alejandro in studio
yesterday was an important confidence
builder for juan wesley so our returning
grand chess tour champion as he gets off
to a flying start peter
take us through our standings after one
day of play that is a manageable job
since there's there was only one
decisive game yesterday and that is
reflected in the standings wesley is
leading the field on 100 score chaplier
has no points so far the defending
champion from 2021 and the rest of the
field is on 50
clear and our format peter uh the format
is quite simple as well it's a templar
templar around robin with the standard
feeder time control of 90 minutes for
the first 40 moves with the 30 minutes
edition of the move 40 and the 30 second
increments starting from move one uh no
draw offers allowed at all at any point
whatsoever do not offer draws
one point for a win half a point for a
draw standard scoring system zero points
awarded for losses nine rounds of play
what about our schedule uh the schedule
is with one round gone we've got a very
simple symmetrical schedule in front of
us uh four more rounds to go until the
res day on tuesday may the 10th uh
expansion day very exciting and then
four more rounds with playoffs if
necessary on
after round nine
and alejandra you're in studio to drill
down on our players nice to see you my
friend nice to see both of you what a
pleasure to be here bright and early or
actually pretty dark and early here in
st louis as it is thunderstorming but
let's hope we see that on the board we
have a very diverse group of players for
here it for you in bucharest let's take
a look at the ages of these players we
actually have players in their late 30s
as well as teenagers in this event of
course lavona ronian there with 39 is
the oldest player in this field which it
might be surprising we have had older
players in the grand chess tour but
that's what we have here we have a
couple of players in the 30s and only
one teenager booked on daniel dayak the
player the local player at 20 also we're
very very young but let's take a look
first our at our oldest participant
lavona ronyan relatively a late bloomer
he did get his grandmaster title a
little bit older than some of the
competitors in this field but he has
been a dominant force in chess for such
a long time he's actually won the world
cup twice he's won the olympiad and it
just feels like the only thing he missed
was getting to that world championship
match he actually participated in the
candidates an incredible six times was
unable to qualify from any of them was
unable to make madrid next month and
will be skipping out in at least one
more cycle meanwhile the teenager the
youngest participant in this tournament
ali reza firuja everybody has his eyes
on him he's broken the 2800 barrier he's
qualified for the candidates everybody's
excited to see what this youngster has
to bring to the chess world many are
saying this is the next challenge the
next serious challenge to magnus
carlson's throne let's see if those
prophecies hold true he has certainly
proved to be an incredible player very
diverse in his style and very difficult
to pin down plenty of chess that we will
see from him but to go through the key
matchups of today let's go with our
friends in bucharest
thank you alejandro and welcome back
everybody to day two of the 2022 super
beth chess classic from location here in
bucharest romania i will be your host
grand master kirilla joined by my
brilliant co-host woman grandmaster
anastasia carlovich welcome back
anastasia hello christian
it's a really great day today here in
bucharest it's sunny weather and
actually it's a great day to play
outside some chess in the parks perhaps
so everything is set for the second
round the plane hall is ready for the
players and i'm personally looking
forward so much to see the game uh
between chakri armamidjarov and richard
roberts
we all know how creative and aggressive
players they are and i'm expecting
really great fights remembering also
their games in tata steel previously
played and in sync world cup so what
about you christian what are you
expecting from this this day well
anastasia the players that you just
mentioned are two brilliant players and
yesterday we could see that with richie
rapport with the black pieces he
actually got the initiative in his game
against leveronian well unfortunately
for mamedyarov he fell under the sharp
sword of wesley so but one game that i
have my eyes on and one player in
particular i have to say must be ali
reza ferruja the 18 year old bomb
because that guy is just incredible he's
been playing brilliant chess but for the
past five months he's been training hard
for the candidates tournament he's
starting off before the candidates with
this big test this event is a big test
for him and i'm definitely looking
forward to see what he's going to bring
to the table in terms of preparation
preparation is key especially in a
tournament such as the candidates
because you have 14 games against the
best chess players in the world and you
know that the preparation for those type
of events is much tighter with the black
pieces especially you have to be
defensive you don't want to lose at all
and maybe you will score a couple of
wins with the white pieces that's
usually the strategy well yesterday with
the black pieces we saw that ali reza
defended quite well against fabiano
caruana and fabiano caruana is a
difficult player to play against with
the black pieces well today he has
another huge test in his clash against
jan nepomnyashi that's a big one yanipon
actually is the challenger the last
challenger against uh magnus carlsen
which a match which he lost of course
five months ago but still he has a lot
of residual preparation from that match
i'm go i'm looking forward to see how
ali reza is going to deal with that guys
back to you thank you christian and
thank you anastasia for your insights
from romania
peter lay the table for all the pairings
in this round absolutely would you
please uh we've been somewhat preempted
though in that by the previous segment
but yeah there you are uh shakira my
media fight against rich airport should
be an interesting game with wishart
obviously looking to bounce back from
his loss yesterday uh the armenian wild
card bogdan dayak is white against le
monranion uh the feroza nibomnishi game
is very very interesting as well i
absolutely agree with christian there
there's also an all-american pairing of
the near angus versus the uh
versus fabi and wesley is once again
playing with the white pieces having
drawn number one in the uh drawing of
lots uh he's once again playing the
white pieces against today against uh
mbl that just feels like such a
heavyweight match up to me uh and the
money
what are they playing for peter they're
playing for very very nice uh
money grandchild story in general is is
paying their players very well and the
price fund is increasing year on year
and uh
this year as you can see uh there is a
very cool 100 grand up top
and if you win the tournament outright
you get 13 gct points and if you have to
play a tiebreak you get 12 which
explains that little 12-13 up top in the
gct points column
uh and it goes all the way down to uh to
10.5 for uh the 10th place so yeah very
very nice price fun 315 total everyday
very very nice video and there you see
the all-american match-up linear
dominguez with the white pieces
against fabi
a rematch if you will
alejandro of the america cup was it the
semi-final it was the semifinals they
want to call it that we remember that
was a double elimination tournament
linear dominguez faced against favi in
that one in the classical portion the
champions bracket bobby got the better
of lanier starting with the white pieces
he
bounced in with a novelty lanier spent a
lot of time trying to hold on to the
position cracked under pressure
and fabi actually was the one that had
to be defensive with the black pieces
right into a fair amount of trouble
against lanier but managed to survive
on the back foot when he was black in
that game for sure and
well as we get
ready for the start of round two i was
impressed by what you were saying about
lavonne and being a six-time candidate i
remember in one of his candidate
campaigns he actually played a match
with magnus carlson and not magnus
carlson out of the candidates but he was
never able to become the challenger so
one of the few matches that magnus
ever lost in his life was to lavon our
oldest player it always felt like a bit
of a i mean travesty is probably a
strong word but uh a kind of an
unfulfilled storyline there that the one
never got the world championship match
because uh
i remember
the the current era of the kind of the
tournaments the a player double round
robins that started with london in 2013.
and i remember when in london he was
clearly considered to be sort of the the
heir apparent yeah yeah
yeah he was definitely one of the people
and the way he started right the way he
started that yeah yes his first half was
incredible wow and uh yeah it feels like
uh something is not just quite coming
together for him in those tournaments
perhaps the pressure of actually
fulfilling the the lifelong ambition of
playing a world championship much is
getting to him but once again armstrong
psychology is
is something we should probably try to
avoid exactly well at 39 years old he is
definitely still a incredible force as
we have
our first move this is a
former world champion boxer from romania
how would i pronounce his name uh we
settled on uh mihailo
i don't know i don't know why i ended up
doing it that way i we apologize for
mispronunciations
that do occur in the show an
extraordinary uh professional career 28.
zero yeah that is a record to be uh
yeah
and i understand
from uh alejandro that he was a cancer
survivor as well so 28-0 thank you uh
michael
for uh
honoring us with
the first move that we see kevin duggan
holding the camera trying to get it we
don't know we don't know it's mikhail
our viewers had forgotten about that
already
and there you have uh
the bird's eye view of the playing hall
there with players waiting for the
clocks to be started yeah now of course
we're living in this modern era of chess
players but as you were talking
alejandro about the 39 to 18
in terms of the ages of the players
peter
what what's the perfect peak age for
chess
grandmasters today that's an interesting
question right because uh i think uh
depending on when you asked this
question like what here it is outside
when you ask this question the answer
would be very very different because
exactly uh i think it was like i i
remember that
like the prevailing i would even say uh
opinion in the old soviet school of
thought was that like people don't come
into their prime until the mid-30s right
uh and and these days if you're not
retired by 35
what kind of career what do you have a
career yeah
did you have
and
it's so obviously as with everything
else there's uh there is a very clear
kind of a shift towards
youth and
i would say mid-20s are good i think
by the time i was playing chess i i
already thought that that was the the
accepted opinion that of course you can
still play excellent chess in your
mid-30s and in your 40s but mid-20s are
the time where
you absorb knowledge very quickly you uh
you progress very fast but you're also
still
your synapses are firing at the proper
speed right
and alejandro jumped right in peak
performance peak
ages of chess players today you know for
me it's it's a question that doesn't
have a simple answer because i think as
a chess player you evolve you just
change the way you handle a lot of
different things not just the way you
handle tournaments the way you handle
certain positions the way you handle
your opening preparation i feel that the
burst of power and energy and talent
that you have at 18 gets you to a
certain point but won't sustain you but
at the same time a lot of the experience
that you can bring early 30s could more
than make up for it and i've seen
players peak at early 30s where
i don't think that's so unusual but that
being said all the rest is 2800 right we
don't expect him to be 18 right now at
18. exactly by the way as the players
and the round is underway we see and the
game of ali
raza there a bishop's opening a bishop
bishop c4 on move two uh which is very
rare guessed
but i think it's becoming
it's always been kind of bubbling just
under the surface for people who did not
want to uh
compete in the in the
uh
knowledge comparison contest maybe you
want to just kind of
get into
for me the idea of the bishop's opening
was always that you wanted to play d3
early so that you could get in a quick
f4
yeah that's that's kind of a romantic
romantic idea which would be great if if
it if it actually worked was there ever
a chance for it yeah but like don't
allow it yeah exactly for example f2f4s
in this exact moment seems to be refuted
and everybody's kind of fallen back on
this now a5 for me
sorry to say but
that's
rare i i think i think it's one of the
two two main moves in this position
these days
you either play bishop before check
straight away or you play five and uh
they uh very much flow into each other i
think there is a number of uh
transpositions but in general playing a5
in these types of positions is very very
uh normal of course the tactical
justification of the pawn on e5 is
hanging but a5a4 is a much more
significant threat there exactly a
central pawn there our bishop is
unfortunately trapped so so black is
trying to gain uh gain space on the
queen side uh and uh also support the
idea of bishop before checking before
check also looks a bit strange perhaps
to a naked eye because it seems like
we're just losing a tempo provoking a
move
c2 c3 which doesn't look half bad at all
but the point here is that before
retreating to d6 or playing bishop d6
immediately you would like to prevent
white from having access to the movement
c3 exactly as yasser is pointing out on
your screens
and provoking c3 helps with that uh
immensely white of course is not obliged
to play c3 you can play bishop d2 but
that allows simplifications that allows
black to trade off some pieces and uh
these types of positions are supposed to
be completely fine for black
i've recently tried playing the bishop
opening and with the white pieces and
was completely lost by move 15 so i
i've had some very interesting recent
experiences with this opening which is
why i'm so confidently uh you know
exposure exposure
on the various various intricacies of it
nice bishop g5 uh pinning and uh i'm
going to toss it over to you alejandra
your thoughts on this opening please
well the bishop's opening is mainly done
nowadays to avoid petrov and of course
we know that nepo uses the petrov once
in a while with both colors
this variation in particular i
do wonder when we're going to start
calling it the chinese variation of the
bishop's opening because every game on
the database here is is from chinese
players against chinese players
wang yue lu xiang lai bai jin shi
all of them joo and jun every strong
chess player from china has at some
point found themselves in this position
it's interesting theoretically i see
that both players are still blitzing
their moves to move e4 here is the most
common so i i still expect to see more
ideas coming out from them before we can
really settle down in the position and
talk about it uh we can probably go
through the openings very quickly on the
other boards uh i think four out of five
yeah i think four out of sorry
uh
for some reason in the game between
wesley and mvl they've completely uh
knight of three d5 is apparently such a
surprise that wesley is now thinking for
five minutes uh wesley again
am i doing this right this is dak
aronian am i not clicking correctly
i'm gonna send it to you guys while i
figure out why this is not working
but yeah uh
going going i thought it was like
richard rapport
uh also
oh i see what you mean the wesley soul
game is like
one move and there was this
and then a longish pause yeah the
longest thing
and finally we did see uh d4
from uh wesley so absolutely but as we
go through okay this is
we've spoken a little bit
if you will of the bishop's opening
there you go
and this is intriguing at least uh
lanier on the white side
of uh especially yeah that's that's
interesting to me uh
simply because uh like
the
if you if you say the words uh
sveshnikov and fabi to me my immediate
reaction is his match against magnus
absolutely
in which he played it on the white side
exclusively yeah and there was a lot of
very very exciting very interesting
games between uh between them including
the uh you know the very very
controversial uh you know you you the
the the birthplace of the famous you're
entitled to you
they're entitled to their stupid
opinions quote
but today he's playing it with black i'm
sure most strong players have played uh
have played the svashnikov once or twice
so it's not a it's not a horrible
surprise but
but this particular way of getting into
this feshnikov uh with e7 e6 does invite
uh one
major line of play i think we saw it in
the in the ladies version of the
america's cup
with arena crush was on the yeah but
very importantly it
this allows the variation that favi
himself used against magnus carlsen in
the 2018 world championship match right
you cannot go to the knight d5 yeah yeah
this is this is the point of this move
order and alejandra is exactly right
yeah uh by by doing it by this move
order black allows as gasser correctly
pointed out the knight takes e6 and e5
lines but does not at all allow the 795
lines which i think have become the
central uh the central point of
discussion if white wants a sharp game
against the sesnik of why these days
plays uh the 795 lines
which is also an interesting transition
because when i just started looking at
this versioning of all the all those
years back 795 was supposed to be the
most boring exactly the most bland and
the most like
chickening out line against the sweden
if possible but these days it's by far
the sharpest
so yeah things don't things don't stay
the same one of the crazy parts about
this particular position of the
swezenikov that we have between
lanier and fabi one time again as you
were saying it was the sharpest and
everything but it's almost become played
out alejandro i mean when i look at the
games of magnus
for example he seems to be perfectly at
ease on the black side yeah there's so
much variations there's so much theory
in this fashion cuff in general even
back when it was everybody was playing
smashing cuff in the early 2000s theory
exploded uh so many variations were just
forced draws or variations that went all
the way to a dead drawn end game and
somehow the special fell in popularity
and it revived a little bit uh recently
it was always considered to be a good
opening but for some time it didn't have
a lot of fashion and nowadays people are
still trying all kinds of things against
this fashion code still such a solid
defense
i'm curious what linear is going to
choose because there's two completely
different approaches to this position
the move c4 goes to very close positions
as it basically forces black to go the
move b4 closed out that side of the
board or the move c3 which keeps uh the
tension on the queen side open for a
while and he's actually chosen to move
c3 i'm curious on what five is going to
bring to the table i have seen him play
his fashion cup before he played it
against ikaro nakamura in the 2019 u.s
chess championship in that one hikara
won the variation c4 with an early queen
f3 and got a winning relatively not
winning a very strong word but clear
advantage against favi in that one but
it was unable to convert
thank you and anastasia said at the
opening segment of our show that uh the
two creative players that she was
keeping her eye on was between shaq and
richie yeah and already by move three
she's vindicated exactly as early as
move three we have this move at knight
c6
i actually had the french
defense in my repertoire
my whole career i want to say it like
that and i actually dabbled in knight c6
myself because it was such a rare one
and
quite frankly i got it from tigran
petrossian and today when somebody
wheels out knight c6 it's really kind of
a shocking move yeah if you will peter
tell us about it i don't know very much
i know at some point it came back i i
personally i think i played a game in
this line against ruslan panamarev who
uh at one point played it semi-seriously
on the black side
and i reacted well in a way which i
thought was sort of the most principled
uh there is a possibility here for white
to basically offering a pawn sacrifice
by move seven uh shakti already declines
but if you go knight f3
i believe the major point of the movie
knight c6 here is if you provoke knight
f3 you can go knight f6
e5 knight e4 and the knight on e4 feels
of course much more comfortable when it
cannot be attacked by f2 f3 and and here
after bishop d3
blood goes bishop b4 and you can castle
and just give up the pawn on c3 which is
what i did and
failed to equalize utterly i didn't
there was there was a tournament where
no draws allowed was not actually
written in written in the rules so i i
got to a semi-playable position by move
15 and offer the draw and then we went
to analyze for like an hour and a half
which was longer than the game
but
that i think is not an optimal way of
meeting knight c6 and i think shakira's
response is the current understanding i
think if
f6 bishop b5 is supposed to give white
a very pleasant edge there have been
some recent games where black tried
proving that this is playable
but i think
let's put it like this engine will
probably disagree violently with the
assessment that this is playable for
black but that doesn't mean you can't
play it because uh
you know we're no we're not playing
against engines right exactly and
alejandro uh the players richie let's
put it that way seems to be in the dusty
part of his chess library wheeling out
knight c6 again
not something that uh
that shaq has been looking at this
morning
let's say
probably not yet but that's the thing
about richie you just never can tell
what he's going to bring to the table
that day and he's not afraid to
experiment he's the type of player that
is okay with the worst position but if
he knows the ideas and if he has some
semblance of a plan he'll go to the
board and just play it out he's a very
creative player he's able to find
different ideas in many different
openings we see the move f6 there bishop
b5 is certainly the main line here it's
not the only way of playing but uh
last time i checked this and it's been a
couple of years one of my students
played knight c6 pretty regularly so he
was showing me some of the variations
here
shout out to grandmaster jj ali morandi
he played knight c6 for years somehow
successfully
but
theoretically yeah it doesn't really
work out
right yeah but it does lead to very
strange very unusual positions with
plenty of pieces on the board and kind
of strange maneuvering fights where uh i
think
rickard in general just kind of welcomes
this type of this type of contests and
clearly there's also the surprise value
i think exactly
very much part of the equation there is
just playing something that
shock probably did not expect either
today or in general
right exactly and and
just
let me just say from my point of view
when i did play knight c6 and they did
play e5 again uh i borrowed a page from
tigran petrosian which would again you
know completely throw my opponents off i
played b7 b6 which looks really strange
but the idea was actually to play bishop
b7 queen d7 and just simply castle along
and for a lot of white players who
wanted to play a win award against me
and
you know uh
it was really they they found it very
very confounding
they oftentimes they did something wrong
i'd end up getting a knight on f5 which
was always strategically wonderful of
course and there is also a close
relative of this line which i think
rafael vaganyan was was playing which is
in the vinover after 93 bishop before i
think uh rafiq used to play bishop
before e5 queen d7 exactly
exactly exactly that was also a
game i had to against yan tim on and
then
and then knight c6 without c5 so it was
very interesting to get so i think we
can call this school of thought maybe
the armenian french the armenian french
if we're going to call it the chinese
bishop's opening armenian french i'll go
along with that do we have queen d7 on
the board for me the armenian french is
bishop a5 in the winner that is a good
point yeah but that is a good point
the armenians played so much so much
of the french defense i think they you
know they can very easily have more than
one they're gonna steal the french
defense from the french exactly so just
uh for everybody the armenian french was
a283 and now the the winner were proper
everybody plays bishop takes c3
but it was like the school of armenian
players was playing bishop a5
takes and dropping the bishop back to c7
and then after australian says retweet
oh no
there are there aren't enough
there isn't enough space on the screen
but i think it actually is called their
meaning variation right because it says
a r on my screen and then dot dot dot
which probably is pictures
there was enough space to write in
the name
uh
okay well this is kind of fun as we are
getting into
a very uh
quintessential yeah was such a shocking
move to me that i had i looked it up but
apparently uh richie has played this
before twice
but it's been a long time when was in
2014 and the other one was 2017 against
eric hanson and evgeny nyer he obtained
draws in both games but
as you can expect the engine absolutely
hates this move with queen d7 already
giving a plus 1.3 advantage to white
wow
and uh a little exaggeration
exaggeration yeah we we welcome all the
all the blunder blunder viewers to us
stream wonderful viewers this is not
this is not a blunder this is just uh
reheard as usual taking significant
risks in the in the opening but he knows
what he's doing he knows he
he's in trouble but he kind of welcomes
the
incoming storm if you don't mind me
asking alejandro after the move queen d7
how did eric hansen and uh nair uh
continue their games with uh richie
everybody played the move knight f3 so
far in this position a6 is at this point
i think almost forced right
i've been wondering sorry for
interrupting but it's just so exciting
it's so so interesting to me if i take
on c6 here we'll take with the queen yes
according to the engine yes okay and
then after ef6
yes because i'm wondering if i can go ef
gf95 anyway
a 95 anyway yeah in this position it's
just a draw
this would just be a draw you take
two h4 queen h5
the king somehow has to go to e7 because
if it goes to d8 queen takes e5
just picks up the
house yeah pretty much so you actually
have to go to e7 so that on queen takes
e5 you have the move tonight f6 this
knight is now defended um bishop g5
check and then it runs somewhere yeah
well actually after the move king e7
if you play check which just continues
the game king d7
check bishop e7
d e
the engine is saying what's a little bit
better down a piece just chilling uh
this has never happened before but it's
apparently one of the ways to play
actually the engine is liking this more
and more and more
but it's also saying that there's no
real need to do any of this just castle
or go positionally knight e2 and white
is simply with a better position it's
very hard to break down the central
problems on the on the center however i
do know that a lot of players with the
black pieces they're okay they say pair
of bishops long term prospects i'm gonna
go bishop d7 hide my king on the queen
side and then on a good day i'll roll my
pawns on the on the king's side it's a
little ambitious uh perhaps a little
crazy but that's just the chest that
rich report brings to uh to every
tournament very very provocative i like
the whole variation that you suggested
there with knight e5
uh it felt to me at least like white was
enjoying an image
i saw that idea and i thought we should
bring it up on the screen because again
this is very exciting very tempting
knight f3
a7 a6 because that was the whole purpose
of queen d7 you wanted to recapture the
queen not taking the double pawns and
now when you take you don't
really want to take with the knight and
invite knight e5 that's a respectable
kind of horrible right so you play you
recapture with a pawn you protect all
the squares
and as
alejandro was saying you go bishop d7
and castles as quickly as possible white
understanding that trips you up
goes 95 you have to take
and right here though uh this is
wow i mean uh first first impressions
are like
why is killing it i mean like it just
looks really good i was wondering yeah
because it does look very attractive and
it does look sort of very promising but
wow and then it goes again
to seven and uh
i mean it's a funny two step right yeah
yeah
you have to stop queen takes e5 that's
why you're inviting the bishop to come
to g5 to stop and now
when you look at black's pieces you
couldn't imagine a worse placement it's
unimpressive
black's pieces and then you go check
here and you just chill so you've got
one pawn
but a completely messed up development
for your opponent and you have a thread
right right quincy seven is a thread i
just have six
sixes
all of those things yeah these look
pretty good
yeah but i mean the likelihood of this
actually appearing on the board
right
i mean it's zero but shock is white yeah
yeah like it's it's it's
a loss so it's slightly above zero but
not by a larger
we'll certainly keep an eye on that over
to you alejandro and what did lanier
and
fabi choose certainly lanier could not
have expected this vashtikov because he
is stuck in thought right now after the
move c3 we saw the move rook v8 being
played mainline i think is still castle
but they kind of transpose into each
other pretty often knight c2 and now the
move castles and this is heavy theory
that tons of games have been played from
this position the most bishop e2 and a4
have been essay but certainly the main
line in this position is the move h4
which restricts the bishop on f6 very
often black wants to go the move bishop
g5 and take control over this diagonal
also the bishop would not get hit by the
knight and the move h4 is in general
useful to follow up with a g3 uh very
soon of course the bishop cannot take
this pawn because of this move queen h5
thank you for the pin on the h file that
just blunders the bishop away so h4 is
certainly the main move in this position
but linear is thinking uh for quite a
while now considering it's the opening
considering his options not really sure
if he wants to go into the main lines of
h4 so this fashion curve it's going a
little slower than some of the other
heavy theoretical duels now one of the
things i'm not thrilled about today's
day is the presence of uh two queens
gambit accepted
i've been excited about some new
developments of theory on d4 i love the
semislav ideas that shanklin has brought
forward uh one of our commentators
peters village came out with the second
version of the gruefeld defense chassis
ball course
go buy it right now and i thought this
was all really cool but somehow the
queen's gambit accepted has made a
resurgence in chess there's been a
couple of exciting variations uh that
have been brought up but this lines with
the exchanges
no no this is not this is not the fun
line
it's really not the finals you can see
there's a symmetrical pawn structure
this is the particularly the game
between dak and aronian in which black
let's just see how we got here
uh we got through this move order with
an early c4 d takes
and
without going through much through the
subtleties here white has basically
attempted every move in the position
i've seen a4 b3 knight c3 bishop e2
bishop d3 bishop b3 queen e2
and d takes c5 all e42 and e4 yes
all played seriously for an attempt and
advantage uh but the move b3 is one of
the most solid one it's one of the ones
that gives black the least amount of
play uh c take knight c6 is played
bishop b2 c takes d4 knight takes d4
bishop uh comes to d7 and then to e4 no
games that i have in the database with
this particular position but the
structure is well known to pretty much
every grandmaster four and four here two
and two on the queen side white has a
little bit of extra development already
castled you see very nice pair of
bishops in the center but we lack
targets as wide there's no real
weaknesses that we can focus on these
spawns do a very good job of stifling
the bishop on c4 so does this pawn on a6
and black is saying look my next couple
of moves are to bring this bishop out
castle and i'm gonna have solved all of
my problems you have a couple of moves
to actually uh tickle me somehow and
pose problems i don't know exactly how
the romanian player is planning to do so
of course he's not no danger himself
either as this is a very symmetrical
position but i think levon is close uh
to fixing his problems also
interestingly levon is
actually has more time than he started
with
and that bishop c64 move doesn't seem to
me like the most obvious move in the
position but it was made pretty much
instantaneously meaning that levon
clearly has looked at this and we are
being informed bish before he is
actually the first fresh move in the
position and this is a novelty which
also explains why uh bogdan was playing
so quickly because i assume after
something normal and by normal i
probably mean this b7
in there
white has a little bit of a
of a push and as alejandro says white
never risks anything at all in these
structures but bishop b4 is a
is an attempt i guess to improve on
what is the
uh the more natural developing moves and
uh levon i'm sure is
uh
has looked at this carefully and in the
other uh b3 queen's gambit uh accepted
which is being played in the game
between wesley saw and mvl i have it on
my screen yeah uh
nvl chose not to play knight c6 so so we
have the same structure but the knights
are not coming off the board i think
this is the way linear plays it with
black right i think i've seen linear
play play exactly in this fashion with
uh
an early b5 followed by rook a7 and the
rook coming out
yeah lanier is a player that has really
adapted the queen's gambit accepted to
to his repertoire recently he plays it a
couple of ways he also plays it with an
early knight c6 uh without taking on d4
i've seen him i've seen him do it both
ways um yeah
b5
in the spot that he played it looks like
a bit of a startling move at first maybe
because white clearly i mean bishop
bishop ii is
sort of specifically aimed at putting on
f3 and you play b5 allowing white to
sort of gain a tempo with bishop three
seemingly yeah but the idea there is as
yasser has already indicated with arrows
earlier yeah like the rope goes to a7
and then to either c7 or d7 and then you
can play bishop b7 and start trading
those bishops on the long diagonal so
this is mvl right we're not we don't
have the wrong board yeah it's really is
this really crazy
this is not the mvl of uh
grundfeld fame i think it was your uh
chessable video that put him off of the
group
it was it was that horrible yeah
it's possible honestly almost nothing
nothing can scare them out of it finally
i will say that i very much based my uh
i mean these days i i look to to mvl for
guidance in many of the lines of the of
my beloved opening uh and uh
it's it's only honestly somewhat
saddening to me to see him you know
switch to the you know the grown-up
openings
to give up on the dreams of his youth
well well this was the whole point about
the queen's gambit it accepted and i had
it in my repertoire uh most of my career
as well this idea look i'm just taking
and equalizing i'm going to take on c4
i'm going to play c5 i'm going to trade
i'm going to get just as alejandro
described it the 4 versus 4 2 versus 2
and we're not really going to we're
going to be throwing
light
objects at each other not the heavy
stuff but i always understood the b2b3
which i also adopted as a line that
akiva rubenstone brought and the whole
idea was as we're seeing in this exact
position
is
you wanted to undermine the move b5 by
playing a2 a4 you would get uh the pawn
on a4 you would
likely provoke a trade and this knight
would end up thanks to the removal of
the b5 pawn on the c4 square and then
white could try to
make some attempts i think all of that
is still true it's just that uh i think
uh
the the current understanding is that
that pool is manageable exactly that
black
yes we'll have to defend a somewhat you
know ever so slightly worse position but
uh
if you put the work in if you figure out
exactly you know which things to avoid
where to put your pieces and so on which
trades are good which trades are bad
uh you you will be able to still manage
to get an equality at the end of the day
actually before a4 has been played by
yeah by wesley uh without bishop f3
right now well i mean you could always
take in uh the the
you could always include pardon me the
move bishop f3 and provoke this rook to
come to a7 and rook takes a4 i'm not
sure if you if you actually want to i
think the bishop is uh is fine only two
kind of hinting at some additional
pressure on the a6 pawn
and also it's
difficult to trade it off when it's only
two whereas on f3 it feels like it will
at some point just get traded
and
alejandro their lifetime results
uh well it's a very solid affair here
one win for wesley four wins for mvl and
18 draws actually that's a very good
score for max yeah i was i was wondering
why you chose the word solid yeah that's
that's
that's a plus three
plus that's a very good plus three i i
have
i'm not really recalling where
we're lastly dropped and honestly
like anybody having such a
massively one-sided score against wesley
is i think very noteworthy because
wesley doesn't lose very many no exactly
well we'll keep an eye on these two
queens gambit accepted games we talked
about that
yesterday too it's like fashion at one
time queen's gambit accepted nobody
played it they play grunfells they play
kings indians they play queens indians
nobody [ __ ] but then everybody starts
playing it suddenly and then it becomes
popular in one round we have two queens
gamble to accept it and two g3s which
is soft
that i think to me is even more an
indication of how fashion works in in
opening theory because yeah qga
definitely is uh enjoying a resurgence
but uh the fact that b3 does seem to be
very much the weapon of choice pretty
much everybody who who faces
these days is is quite striking to me
because i i dabbled in the qga myself on
the black side of it and uh
b3
wasn't really even on the radar and
right like bishop b3 yeah and three
queens i was aware of its existence but
i thought okay i mean if if people
choose to play this against me my choice
has already been vindicated like right
now being tested as as my friend boris
gelfin used to say in in similar spots
you're not going to lose very much in
this uh you know
in this spot you know
so
it's it's
somewhat remarkable that this has become
absolutely the accepted norm of how you
how you react to the qga because there's
definitely some very sharp stuff you can
do against it like it it does not need
to be as you described it you know
people lobbing soft objects at each
other there are some very very sharp
lines where
life is on the edge for black exactly uh
speaking just a bit of being on the edge
sorry i was going to take you to the
game of lanier fabi because this move a2
a3
that looks soft i mean what it's uh it's
a kind of a
i think it declined an invitation to
discuss main lines here with this move
a2 a3
all right and let's uh jump over to
bucharest as christian
is going to talk about this game
christian what do you have for us
thank you yasir funny that you mentioned
that game indeed because that is a big
american clash and i've been eyeing that
game since at the beginning also i was
in the playing hall as the players were
getting ready to start the games and i
have to say i saw two very completely
different attitudes
on one hand dominguez was with his head
in his hands before the game started
focused extremely extremely focused
fabiano on the other hand much more
relaxed it felt like it and fabiano came
with this idea of playing c5 we know
fabiano plays uh e5 mostly petrov
samurai lopez but nowadays he started
engaging with c5 as well and trying to
get a game out of the opening and put
some pressure with the black pieces
maybe get the victory let's see how the
game transpired in the opening knight
xd4 and we've seen fabiano essay this
idea of knight to c6 quite often and
quite recently actually in a game
between uh himself and jan nepomiashin
knight to c3 and then queen to c7 now
today he adopted a very different
approach knight to f6 first knight to c3
and only now knight c6 now this move
order allows uh a transition into the
shweshnikov and this is exactly what
happened in the game knight to b5 d6
bishop f4 e5 attacking the pawn on d6 of
course you have to defend it with e5
bishop g5 a6 knight a3 b5 knight to d5
and now we have a typical vashnikov
bishop to e7 bishop takes f6 bishop
takes f6 c3 rook to b8 knight to c2 and
this is the critical uh position the
tabia position of this variation and i
was looking at the top games in the
variation
six of them are dominguez with the white
pieces on the other hand his results
were not as uh confident at least to my
taste he drew five of them and lost one
with white pieces so it definitely
doesn't feel like it's his type of
position or at least he doesn't feel as
comfortable and perhaps fabiano uh took
some lead out of that idea now
a big moment came at this point bishop
to g5 seems to have been the move that
has been played for the last few months
few years as the main line instead of
that fabiano immediately played the move
castle
after bishop to g5 generally white
starts with a4 and once again dominguez
played a lot of games in this
move a4 to be honest i've analyzed this
position a couple of years ago and i
couldn't find a clear advantage for
white so
perhaps dominguez being confident in
this nevertheless i from the games that
i've been seeing of his he was unable to
get an advantage nevertheless fabiano
decides he's the first one that wants to
change the pace of the game with this
move castle early move castle now the
difference is with the bishop g5 you
very often have the idea of playing h4
h4 attacking that bishop and forcing
some sort of interesting play on the
king side now on the other hand at this
point right now dominguez spent
18 minutes
on this move a3 the last move that he
just made and this is a very timid
approach that he's taking generally
we've seen in the main line that i just
showed the idea with a4 now he decides
to go a3 this is going to probably be
followed up with a more strategical plan
on the queen side he's going to try to
go knight c2 to b4 invite this trade on
b4 take with the a pawn if you're ever
going to take on before of course you're
not going to do that but we have a very
very interesting battle going on between
these two friends and rivals at the same
time because right now fabiano is taking
his first thing of this game as well
they're both in fresh waters and we're
going to have a very intriguing match of
brewing in this one guys back to you
thank you christian interesting uh
strategic approach by lanier in his uh
game with abby with this a2 a3 another
very strategic uh battle that's shaping
up is between ali reza
and ian
in this bishop's
opening
peter your thoughts on
the last move of ian
when we left it we left it about here
yeah and very much like knight f1 uh by
bayalireza i think uh
this knight very much belongs on e3 and
has to be there as soon as possible so
yeah not casting gustling would actually
set back set wide back a number of tempe
because the knight on d2 really needs to
be on a different square and by castling
you're basically committing to go in
rookie one to still be able to play
knight of one so it's very
understandable that white is continuing
to play with their king in the center
because
the king only one is currently quite
safe and then and as i mentioned the
knight needs to be on e3 right and h6
and bishop four is i think a very
normal way to respond because the bishop
on b8 was kind of in a way you want to
connect your rooks you want to perhaps
unpin your queen from
from the pin on the edge for the ga
diagonal so you are opening up as a
potential it looks a bit artificial but
queen g8 b8 as a follow-up might be
something that jan is interested in
just to free up some of his pieces
also the pin as you're saying and
also i wonder if there are some
positions in which uh knight e3 can be
met by actually taking on e3 changing
the structure in that way but currently
i don't quite see why that would be good
for black it it's it's a structure like
the only thing good about it is that the
structure changes
like if you're
in favor of change in general
the structure definitely did change but
i think it's a very important bishop
that blood gives up here and i don't
particularly like this position for
black um
honestly i quite like white's white's
chances after 93 i think if i if i had
to pick a side here i would be i would
be choosing uh choosing the the alireza
side of this of this position well now
we're ready to castle we want to play
bishop g3 if you play mba they play
bishop g3 here right i will castle next
move and try to push for some kind of
two f3 break now it's funny because i'm
borrowing a pr a page
from a really low pass variation i think
an open rui in fact where they get this
bishop
and they play the supporting move g5 yes
it's very much on the cards here exactly
so i wanted to say that
i would probably meet your bishop g3
with g5 and maybe h5 yeah and
really try to force white to take on the
f4 and that would be the dream yeah that
was that would be that's the absolute
dream yeah
um
well it looks
looks
yeah and this is still nothing nothing
necessarily new there has been eight
games that reached this position perhaps
not in 93 specifically but the optimist
before we're still very much in
uh in in theory yeah wow okay very cool
90 interesting bishop f4 we'll probably
have to ask alejandro what uh i i mean
it always seems to me like the producers
uh have deeper
uh just databases no databases than
us i mean we got like the the the the
2021 database so they got var which
seems to be like the may
2022 database
notice how he slipped in may very
important like up to date uh what do you
have for us alejandro what what what say
our
database about this position a few grand
master games still in this position five
to be exact the move knight e3 is
certainly the most common one the
engines are considering this to still be
more or less equal all of the plans that
you guys mentioned have either been
followed or have been suggested by the
computer so still top-notch work there
i'm going to go through a couple of the
other games as this one i feel has been
severely analyzed by you guys i wanted
to take a look a look at this game
between amanda yara from rapport because
we had a couple of moves after castles
here by white i expected the move bishop
d7 to come on the board but the engine
wasn't suggesting it and i was starting
to wonder why and the reason is that
actually here ponte's pawn takes 95 just
straight up wins
without the ability to put the king on
e7
and then g7 yeah and then d7 exactly
because here you get basically made it
remember if you go to d8 in this
position
then after queen takes e5 i trap your
rook and that is just a winning position
for white so you want to play king e7 so
that after queen takes e5 i have knight
f6 but here unfortunately after bishop
g5 check you simply don't have a good
way of blocking this check knight f6
loses to detox e5 and king d6 gets mated
after d takes e5 so no chance here for
black bishop d7 is just a bad move and
instead richard uh starts with the move
knight e7 takes takes and knight h4 has
sent rapport finally into the think tank
what to do about this move knight h4 the
move queen h5 is coming with check and
that is an annoying one however how
annoying is it it is possible to play
the move bishop d7 queen h5 check and
kind of chill with the king in the
center not exactly what you want to do
but it is not terrible i have seen
engines that like this uh this in this
particular position the engines hate it
but i have seen positions in which they
say it's okay in this one they think h5
just the better move prevent the check
there is no secondary check on g6 so
queen d3 doesn't actually threaten
anything and you're just preparing the
moves bishop d7 and castle basically
white has a couple of moves to use as an
initiative to try to create pressure on
black's position before the king
skadoodles all the way to the queen side
and then black is simply going to be
better you have the majority on the
center you have the open g file you have
the bishops so white has put himself
in sort of sort of taking time pressure
uh
to be able to create something in the
next couple of moves after knight h4 h5
i expect something like queen f3 start
to harass the pawns something quick
because the moment that black fully
mobilizes he's just gonna have all of
the trumps in the in the position
including the two bishops
well i'll meet your skadoodle with my
skedaddle
and another interesting um possibility
here in the game between the romanian
player and levonaronian
we have here the move knight g5 played
very very quickly yeah we were
discussing it we were discussing it off
there with uh with yasser because we
thought the bishop will not return to c6
and then white could have a very
significant initiative but what is on
the
saw the the coming of knight g5 and he
just calmly goes back to 6 and says my
worry was that my bishop will get
harassed by knight e5 i've sidestepped
it by uh putting it on e4 preemptively
you played knight g5 knight doesn't
belong there unless you have some
winning attack with the sacrifice on e6
which doesn't seem very likely right now
because white really lacks the attackers
to continue
and black is very ready to play
something like i don't know bishop b7
and castles and honestly i'm a little
bit uh
worried here
because uh
i have seen uh bogdan take pragmatic
choices and positions like this and he
obviously does have a choice of going
knight f3 here
which might end the game uh which might
end the game kind of
a repetition quickly yeah because i
think luan just quite happily goes
before again and we have uh we have a
threefold
yeah uh he also has the possibility of
going crazy let's do the crazy the crazy
would be to go f4 i was trying to play
around with my uh engine to see how much
it hated the idea of playing h6 because
i think that if you play bishop e7 then
f5 just comes too quickly you don't have
enough protection over the f7 square
so you i thought you had to kick out the
move uh the knight with a
the move h6 and here i thought well why
not just take on f7 they're not my
pieces anyway exactly king takes f7 f5
the engine
doesn't hate it doesn't think that white
is better but the more it thinks about
it the more i realize that perhaps white
is not worse in this position which is
already a huge accomplishment you
sacrifice pieces yeah yeah yeah but um
it doesn't think that it's enough for an
advantage
those arrows on your screen are kind of
scary because if the best move in this
mission is h6 h5 yeah
they're not people are going to find
that they're the only good moves if you
go king g8 after of takes e6 the engine
after something started to already like
white
so
it didn't think that this was a good way
of playing it did prefer the moves uh e8
or h5 king e8 or h5 unclear what exactly
the evaluation of the position is i
don't have a super engine with me so
it's still liking black but the more i
played around with it the more it
thought okay black white actually has a
lot of compensation here i i do want to
to offer a counter point and the
counterpoint here will be uh bogan
actually is i think one of the people
who is extremely capable of playing f4
here in general i think he is a uh he is
a very very sharp very interesting
tactical player but he he's playing
against somebody who has a an hour and
31 minutes on the clock and i think
that's the scary part right you assume
your opponent has looked at this
and
and you don't you just can't go for the
sharp sacrifice and night variation and
he's played queenie too after a little
bit of thinking
i must say uh
f4 is definitely worth an a try
maybe when you prepared it because this
move bishop c6 to e4 came as a little
bit of surprise and when your opponent
is playing it that fast queen e2 in
order just to play rook d1 nina tempo
against the queen sure looks attractive
and also i think it doesn't work but i
have to mention that if black ghostb7
here there is bishop take c6 i suspect
it's not enough but there is the option
of doing this and then 96 knight g7 but
after queen d7 specifically queen g7 i
think to take away
to take away the knight of five square
after 97 king of seven
uh i think black is fine but this is
still a playable position for white
knight h5 and let's go exactly that's
three bonds after all but this bishop on
it's a very nice bishop yeah it it it
sure is h38 or yeah we'll definitely
keep an eye on this i just wanted to
bring us back to the shack versus um
richie game because i agree with you
wholeheartedly uh alejandro in the sense
that if white plays soft black will play
bishop d7 and
skadoodle did you say
skadoodle over so i'm not interested in
the skadoodling
i was thinking that
white has to play very very
active forcing moves and after h7 h5
why isn't queen f3 just wonderful for
white okay you attacked my pawn i
defended it bishop yeah and uh
we
yeah i was also looking at this line i
attacked my stuff
[Music]
okay so i just
so the reason why i wanted those two
moves played in you can't castle
kingston don't worry about it
you were not aiming the castle there at
all okay well good i mean
and again i i think i should be fast now
how do i
there is 92 f4 at it takes h5 plans but
it does give up the pawn on c2 which is
not only just a pawn it also gives black
queen e4 ideas which will very uh
uh
efficiently interrupt our plans on on
the king side i think that would be very
sad yes actually and i i want to to add
my voice in agreement to what you were
saying uh that
efgf in general is a kind of a horrible
concession
as white as white yeah you you give up
much of your much of your spatial
advantage we went like 4e5
and we've made another tempo move so
it's not even the tempe it's it's
you you free black's position up very
much you give black pieces squares you
give black hope of pushing for a 65
later in the game if they somehow secure
king safety uh you you give up your
spatial advantage as i mentioned right
it has to be justified by being
extremely energetic and by achieving
something while uh black finishes
development before yeah i will i was
also looking at exactly the line that
you were describing queen of frequent g3
is the most obvious line here right but
it doesn't seem to do to get very far
like you do have that draw between the
three queen g3 but that obviously is not
what you want yeah so i i did look at it
with the engine and here apparently
there is a problematic move for black
right in this position try to move b3
b2 b3 clever yeah
it's hard to even come up with the
concept right because your bishop on c1
already has an open diagonal but the
more you look at it the more you realize
wait a second how do you deal with
bishop a3 knight knight to g6 it's kind
of a simple threat that is very very
nasty but it's a nasty thread right
you just don't have moves it's just
incredible how unpleasant that is wow uh
as we struggle let's uh send it over to
bucharest and see what
christian and anastasia for us uh hello
bucharest
thank you thank you yasser yes well
anastasia you were mentioning that you
have some insights
about a very important game the clash
between wesley so and mvl because these
players have been playing against each
other quite a lot this year specifically
in the grand prix and you are there on
site if i'm not mistaken tell us a bit
about that yeah you're right i was in a
grand prix event recently like it
finished like three weeks ago something
like that and the wesley saw and then
well they were playing in the same group
from the very beginning and the one who
would win the group would qualify later
for the next stages and i'm sure the
fact that they'll lost this mini match
against the wesley saw makes this game
kind of special for him i'm sure that
maxim is looking forward to have some
kind of a revenge and the first game
finished in a draw the second game he
lost and it's interesting to speak about
the first game because uh grundfeld
happened at that time and when while i
was doing the interview with both of the
players uh wesley mentioned that already
for seven years he's suffering to choose
the right uh you know consequences of
moves against maximus grunfeld and i
think today it was an interesting kind
of dance of moves between two players
what can you say it's a very difficult
uh task for any white player to defend
to a defeat i must say
mvl's grunfeld because he's been playing
the green field his whole life he knows
absolutely everything the ins and outs
of every single variation so i
understand uh the attitude that wesley
saw bring to that tournament but tell us
a bit about this game because he started
off with the move knight to f3 and after
this move d5
well wesley spent five minutes on his
next move that's the question that's a
good question i was in the plane hall at
the time and i saw him thinking you know
making all these kind of faces and
yeah i i don't know what he was trying
to do did he try to find a way to avoid
still grunfeld or let's say it's already
finished i don't know it's hard to to
say can you tell me the details like if
maxine wanted to have greenfield what he
had to play well probably after knight
to f3 knight to f6 is the best way to
maintain your possibility to transition
into a grunfeld because of course after
d4 you can start off with g6 you don't
have to go the move d5 the problem with
the move d5 well also after knight to f6
white has a lot of options at his
disposal and i would assume this is what
the discussion resembles right
potentially c4 and now we see an
anti-grunfeld which supposedly is quite
dangerous there's a lot of very
dangerous lines in the antique room
field so immediately uh mvl signaled
that he's not ready for that he doesn't
want to see that on the board he wants
to play more of a team game and after d4
knight to f6
c4 now at this point it's already quite
difficult to transition into the groom
file you don't have the knight on c3 as
white so if you go with the move g6 i
can just simply take on d5 you take back
and now i go e4 there's no knight on c3
to capture we're not going to have a
grunfeld white is going to be much
better in this position so now the
question is after c4 you can also go c6
but once again i can go knight to c3 and
g6 is not the best variation usually you
want to see g6 as black when white
already has the move g3
in the position so a very interesting
dance and i know the guys in the studio
especially alejandro was looking
incredulous at this position after d4c4d
takes c4 because we almost never see nvl
play this type of idea big news actually
that is that is a very good question and
i do uh like that mvl is very interested
in finding new ideas in the opening
that's a big big plus that i'm seeing
from him in this event what do you guys
think about this game
well uh thank you for that christian we
also were wondering what had happened
with our mvl and grunfeld and for me
peter it's it's such a great pleasure to
be sitting next to you because i wanted
to ask you exactly about that and i also
wanted to tell the audience and to
invite them
into our discussions as well
and that they can ask you ourselves
anybody on our panel and there's a way
for them to do this yeah you you can uh
ask us questions and uh do you to do
that uh uh use twitter use hashtag
granchestore or tag the account at
granchestore and we will be
addressing the best and the brightest of
the questions
well i'm not at all about to say that
i'm going to ask you the best and
brightest of the questions but i do have
to ask
that as you are such a grunfeld expert
and i was so surprised
in
recently it just seemed that in the
non-standard
grunfelds
that
maybe it's levon
or
something it's been it's been around for
a while everybody starts playing h2h4
what's going on well it's uh
i think it's uh of the early age fours
of the world i think this was
potentially maybe the most dangerous
it's definitely the one that put me off
playing this particular move order with
black
uh i think
this this is one of the h4s where black
legitimately struggles to equalize i
think
i mean
there is at least three different ways
of playing h4 versus the pure grenfeld
and they're all kind of scary but there
i would feel that yes black should
equalize with precise play whereas this
particular position
um i have a kind of a decent idea of
what's best and i think
in particular if you're well prepared
and your opponent is perhaps kind of
winging it to a degree you'll be fine
but it's scary this position is
legitimately scary for black it's uh
it's very very tricky to equalize uh and
i think it also makes sense because uh
if you want to play an early h4 uh i
think it makes very a lot of sense to do
it when knight has already vacated the
f6 square making h5 easier to achieve
and also i think it's it's it's very
simply in white's favor that all of the
central pawns are still on their uh
starting squares because it very much
limits the amount of counter play that
that can launch the fact that the pawn
is on g2 makes
c5 break not a break if not it's just a
move and c3 is sufficient yeah c3 is
well protected
so
so the knight f3 if we're if we're
trying to really get into the head of
wesley so for a second you could say and
who also by the way is a grunfeld player
himself i mean he certainly has it in
his repertoire so he's trying to no i
think i i watch
not exactly i want to slightly correct
you because i'm over the years mvl has
been the player of the knight of six c4
c5
persuasion angie grimfield yeah and i've
personally had a
large theoretical discussion with him on
the white side of this in the line of
knight c3 g5 mm-hmm she takes d595 e4 in
the belize grand prix oh no grand prix
world cup i had some good positions but
ended up actually losing one of those
games and
that ended my end in my world cup yeah
night before bishop c4 and it's so it's
a very interesting position which uh mvl
had very kind of fixed ideas about and
you could kind of pinpoint prepare
against what he was doing there i see uh
he was never really uh in in the recent
years never really a knight of six g6
player against knight of three okay but
i'm pretty sure this is what would have
happened if he played it today i think
most players by this point with with the
white pieces are very much aiming for
that five h4 line that you pointed out
and uh from wesley's point of view that
was the five minute thing that he had a
move too because here he is trying to
casually catch mvl in some prep
mvl plays d5 in the queen's game but
accepted it completely different well
unveil has been playing
non-grunfeld's i think starting from the
run-up and the the yakuterenburg
candidates he started showing
non-grimfield as part very much integral
part of his black repertoire so you can
no longer really you know act entirely
shocked when he refuses to to stick to
his guns but
uh still people i guess assume that he
probably plays his uh his usual stuff
alejandro back over to you and ali riza
enough of this qga talking
but here we had a game that we thought
was going to turn quite interesting very
long strategical battle the knight
coming to e3 perhaps pressuring d5 we
saw ideas of g5 by black to cement this
side of the board but alaris is going
for none of this he's going for first of
all the move h3 which baffled me a
little bit why are you weakening your
control over g3 why are you awakening no
we need four but now we know after the
move rookie 8 which seems more or less
normal he played the move g3 kicked out
the bishop bishop b8 and immediately the
move g4 came on the board and this
completely changed the character of the
position i do not know if g5 is even a
threat in this position i assume
not because knight h7 unless say missing
something yeah i don't think g5 is this
rare i think you're just sort of
securing the position of the bishop on
g3 and just gaining space on the king's
side and the assumption is uh the king
either stays only one or gets castle
queenside so he is perfectly fine you
know quote unquote ruining his king-size
structure
it's going to be a very exciting game
this is going to be a lot of fun but i i
think that black's play here especially
considering the weakness of the f4
square it's not so difficult you go
knight f8 knight g6 you put something on
f4 especially if it's a bishop it's
going to be quite annoying and yeah
white has a little bit of ideas here and
there but
my main question is going to be what is
the advantage of having the pawn on g4
over having it on g2 and that one i
leave to you guys uh no idea
give us an easy one from now on because
i'm
looking at that f4 square and i'm saying
that's the tender
knight f8 96 knight f4 plays itself
knight f8 looks extremely attractive
right now we have a
tweet uh for our panel very excited
read it out
from push pushgarage asks uh the thought
experiment how would you build your
dream classical chess player by using
the best available skills from past and
present super gms eg opening knowledge
of player x uh tactical awareness of
player y time travel skills of player
zed
opening knowledge
my kind of full sort of default answer
would be would be gary uh but i think
these days uh i mean but gary sort of
was the
he he laid the path and now perhaps many
people have
traversed the path right further but i
think he was the first person to to
really approach
you know so to try to you know weaponize
opening preparation to the extent that
he did
uh
i mean time travel skills you have to
take sasha right you like
if this is the world apart yeah i mean
if those are the three skills that are
being given to us you you take you take
time travel skills of sasha just sort of
for pure watchability i think
not necessarily maybe the best player in
time travels ever but i think it's
entertaining he is eminently watchable
as he does it uh and
tactical awareness i think was the third
one or well no you just building
your dream player yeah so you're going
to take you know cappa blanca's endgame
skeletons or spacelove saying game
skills you're going to take bot
vinnick's approach to opening
preparation you're going to take sasha's
approach to time trouble build it for us
who
who
which pieces and from where what players
are you gonna i would need to for you to
sort of name name the pieces you're
right okay so jump right in here
if you've got a lego piece okay that you
could have met like for me i would take
bobby fischer's professionalism his
approach to chess that he
he made
study of the openings at least from the
american player's point of view
forced i mean he put
time work and effort his professionalism
was extraordinary i always thought
kasparov's openings also was something
incredible the
uh
positional his death skill at handling
uh positions
uh and gary by the way will be joining
us he'll be he'll be on there so we
could inspired you alejandro as far as
you know extraordinary in what phase of
the game well that's a different
question yes sir because who inspired me
is different than who i would pick
that's true i was a lego robot but my
lego robot is carlson carlson carlson
wow he's just so dominant in every
aspect of the game i know that perhaps
you could argue sometimes he gets out
calculated once in a while he gets out
prepared but i just thought that his
ability to play any opening is really i
will i will still insist that even even
even your carlson lego robot has to have
the the the sasha
i'll give you trouble i will give him
that i'll give him
one time
right yeah magnus magnus max
magnus but for me my inspiration uh for
active play for plans for attacks that
was always gary but for openings it was
kramnik uh for me and it was entirely uh
what big vlad was doing all the time and
so many d4 lines i was greatly inspired
by halifan's treatment of kramnik's
openings he did this five uh book series
on how kramnik played with starting with
one knight f3 and transposing into d4
openings and for me that was a huge
inspiration uh learning how to play
those structures how to learning how to
play those openings and how to come up
with new ideas i always felt that
kramnik had the best understanding of
how to transition the game fully from
beginning to end
wow yeah that's that's a good shot as
well yeah and
vladimir's influence over over opening
theory of the last i don't know 20 years
cannot really be
overstated he has been the the absolute
trendsetter there um so yeah i agree
with that part
cool as we prepare for our break
peter you're gonna have
more exciting news from uh the cuba
chicken the item for today is
as you can see on your screen a very
very nice limited edition t-shirt
commemorating the world chess hall of
fame's current exhibit which is mind art
experience 10 years of chess and culture
in st louis
and it features as you can see a very
nice drawing of the world's largest
chess piece which stands in front of the
world chess hall of fame which is just
across across the street from us
available as as are many other things as
as you can see on your screen cubitique
saint louis.com
do all your shopping needs there we'll
see you on the other side of this break
as we continue our coverage of round two
of the grand chester
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the
bucharest granchester stage here we are
in the building of the romanian
parliament we are very excited to see
the opening ceremony and the drawing of
lots to learn who will be playing in the
first round let's go for it
[Music]
it's a great ceremony it's really a
beautiful place and it's quite rare that
you're you know in a parliament for an
open ceremony wow that was my experience
i mean beautiful environment especially
for chess i've never
i don't recall being into the parliament
of my own country actually so you know
being a being here is really spectacular
[Music]
i'm very pleased to be here in in in
bucharest so where it's you know it's
the the chess
um
modern adventure of the game of just
eastern europe has started
[Music]
yeah really looking forward to to the
tournament once you get the parents you
know
your opponent for the first round
immediately you start thinking what
you're going to play but uh yeah it was
really great the opening ceremony
it's been an amazing opening ceremony we
saw the drawing of lots we saw the
simultaneous exhibition and now let's
come back to the exciting games
founded in 1839 the university of
missouri is steeped in tradition the
recently founded mizzou chess program is
a partnership between the university of
missouri and the st louis chess club
collegiate jess has been experiencing a
meteoric rise at the national level
through its tradition of excellence
mizzou has always strived for the best
mizzou chess is working towards raising
the bar by bringing our institutions
ethos of respect responsibility
discovery and excellence to the chess
board
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
can you hear it
it's the sound of hope
and health
and strength
it's the sound of compassion
of open doors
where people and machines are in tune
and miracles occur
[Music]
it's the sound of personalized
healthcare
and active communities
it sounds like life
and it's what you hear
when you really listen
we all know st louis is a championship
sports town from the 11 time world
champion cardinals to the stanley cup
champion blues
but i bet you didn't know about all the
championship places there are to get out
and play here like the world chess hall
of fame westport social and topgolf and
now even our own mls team so whatever
sports your team is into you can always
bring out your a game in st louis
oops sorry st lou is always exploring
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and here we are with the continued
coverage of round two of the super bet
chess classic in bucharest romania here
is the view of the playing hall with
players
deep in thought and some players
obviously out for a walk because it's
nothing as it's not their move
as is the way it should be
were you much of a walker during your
playing days not really i had pretty
good sits flash i liked sitting at the
board and enjoying except if there was
some really great game going on on the
other side of me then i wanted to walk
around and see what's going on uh take
us through our pairings if you want to
peter let's take a look at what's
happening in round two
uh so we have uh the game between
chocolate and jared and uh richard
rapport which is heating up very very
nicely we'll get to that in a moment
yeah bogdan dayak is playing white
against leonardo and also quite a sharp
position on the board right now yeah a
very very exciting position in the game
between anderson ferruja and yanni
pondiche
lenier dominguez is playing a somewhat
quiet session off against faviano
and there is also yet another qga
queen's gambit accepted in the game
between our tournament leader wesley soh
and the frenchman with three names
maxine the charlotte
and or5 yes and indeed
uh jump right into it uh alejandro uh
daniel uh bogdan uh go
i've got that game on your board the
game between deck and aronian we did see
the idea of f4 hopefully with the idea
of following it up with f5 but we have a
little bit of a pause here for the
romanian player considering if he wants
to actually commit to the move f5 i
think after this we will see very
quickly ironian respond with the move h6
trying to force white's hand and the
question is does white believe in the
sacrifice the engines actually give a
surprising nod of approval to this
strange idea to go knight f3 take my
pawn on f5 it's not defended and black
could take it two ways take it with the
e pawn perhaps it's not the most natural
because after 95 you cut the queen from
the pollen f5 that means the rook can
take a next turn you're also threatening
the pawn on f7 and on a good day maybe
you can take on c6 so perhaps not the
best way of playing this variation you
could of course take it with the queen
but it does present a considerable
amount of risk after the move knight e5
remember the rook is hitting this queen
on f5 it only has one square if it goes
to e4 then after rook f4 it has to go
all the way back to h7 and the engine
finds a way to actually win immediately
it doesn't matter for us we would just
not put the queen on h7 you just don't
do that um
so after the move h6 knight f3 queen
takes that 595 you could go to g5 and
the engines are thinking you could just
play for the compensation play rook f4
play rook a f1 the queen's very awkward
h4 at some point might be a threat
especially when i remove this bishop by
taking on c6 the engine is of course a
zero zero nobody cares about that it
seems to be a very entertaining position
in which i would think it's a lot easier
to play with white i wanted to
inquire about something because i
thought f5 was just going to be met by
castles but you're saying h6 is
semi-force why why are we not just
castling here if you're casually
yeah there's a very cool idea here b4 i
love that winds
like it's a cold shower type of bike if
you take with the queen i'm allowed to
take on e6 of course the previous uh the
point to illustrate this on the board is
that if i play f5 castles and i take on
e6 of course watch out for the queen
moves queen takes g5 just picks up the
knight and this is the reason that you
have to move b4 it's a huge distraction
if you take with the bishop remember the
queen can't stay on the fifth rack this
is the whole point of the move b4 if you
take with the bishop then i think on f6
you take on
f6f66 and i go queen h5 add this is just
mate takes takes king h8 check king g8
and now a bunch of things work but i
think f takes e6 is the that's the
simplest to calculate this is gonna be
made if i take on f7 no real good way of
defending against the engine just saying
resign let's go to the next game so
because of the existence of the move
before
it would make h6 an automatic after the
move f5 i don't see another way of
keeping the tension here in this
position especially because b4 will
always be an idea uh so i do expect the
move h6 here would be a lot of fun to
see dax sacrifice a pawn on this one
meanwhile in the game that we thought
we really think is heating up here
between uh shaka yamamyarov and richard
report they have followed this line of
queen f3 bishop g7 and shaq did play
sorry shaq did play the move b3 which we
thought was incredibly annoying for the
black side bishop a3 coming bishop takes
e7 knight g6 will win in exchange at
some point it's also not so easy to
evacuate with the king to the queen side
while this knight on e7 is hanging and
richard went forward he actually played
the top engine move in this position
which looks risky but it makes a lot of
sense plays the move e5 grabs space on
the center taking advantage of the fact
that the move b3 didn't develop a piece
for the white side immediately and with
the move bishop g4 coming with a tempo
he is accelerating his development
bishop a3 of course has to come on the
board and bishop g4 is currently the
position now the most logical move in my
opinion is to put the queen on g3 which
it has been done because it threatens to
move h3 in many situations the bishops
are both hanging on the g file not to
mention bishop takes e7 knight g6 is
currently a threat
for this reason the engine's top move is
certainly the move rook g8 it moves out
of the double attack says go ahead and
take on e7 i don't care the king could
slowly run to the queen side if
necessary and you are lacking pieces in
the center to immediately kill me of
course this is engine type of chess the
engines are thinking white's a little
bit better but not that much and there's
not a lot of choices right because i am
taking on e7 and i am threatening h3 i
expect the move rook j to come on the
board uh you could make an argument for
bishop f8 but i don't think you're
really going backwards in this position
i think rook g8 will be on the board
pretty soon
i just
if you put rook g8 on the board
alejandro
and
why wouldn't you you could take on e7
but why wouldn't you play rook e1 and
just build up for a big central splat
well the problem is that you're not
planning anywhere because the bishop on
a3 only has one purpose which is to
pressure this knight on e7 this is
what's preventing the king from going to
the queen side so what black needs to do
in this position is get rid of this
pressure go knight f5 uh sorry for
example rookie one rookie yes put this
rook on e1 it actually prefers the other
rook but it's not very important right
knight f5 trade this guys off no choice
for white takes takes and the moment
that you start uh opening up the center
in many cases it's going to favor black
for example if i take on e5 of course i
don't take back and allow you to take
only 5. this is the moment i take
advantage of the tempo that i was giving
skadoodle all the way to the queen side
and remember of all the trumps that we
were talking about open g file pair of
bishops now this bishop looks ridiculous
it's on the wrong diagonal this knight
is hanging tactically in many positions
the engine actually thinks that black is
already winning perhaps an exaggeration
but certainly not a fun position to play
for for white so i think that after
queen g3 because of the strategical
threat in some ways of uh rook g8 knight
f5 coming taking
this bishop out of the game in some ways
that the bishop has to take on e7 in
this position keep the king by force in
the center to have these counter chances
okay and continue if you will with that
bishop e7 king e7 black's king is in the
center how do i
exploit
uh that bringing rook to the center you
probably want to bring a rook to the
center i think rook ae1 looks a little
more logical to me okay i'm not really
sure which one and now black has some
choices the engine wants to play bishop
h8 you could consider going e4 trying to
close down the position i think bishop
h8 does make a lot of sense because you
never know when bishop e2 or even just
bishop e6 will be helpful for the black
side
the engines say 0.4 very slight
advantage for the white side not really
completely sure for example after bishop
h8 you could you could take on e5 if you
could take 25 you could even sacrifice
the exchange it looks quite normal but
the engines aren't too afraid of it so
bishop takes e5 is playable but more
clever is it was bishop e6 again
slightly alien chess you have your king
in the center knight f5 might be a
threat but it tactically holds for the
black side rook is attacking the queen
on g3 the bishops are very powerful
always remember that this knight on c3
is hanging many variations knight takes
d5 fails tactically tactically to queen
takes d5 so you actually have to take on
e6 now you don't take with the queen
because queen takes c7 check you
actually take with the king and this
would be just absolutely wild this is
what you expect from a shock versus
rockwood game they might be kind of
forcing each other to go into these type
of positions because remember white is
just worse strategically he needs to
start going after this king he's forced
to do so and there are many variations
in which you will have to sacrifice an
exchange just to expose the king and
black's not going to have a lot of
choice or say in the matter but in that
final position it seems it just seems
wrong to me that black's king survives
in the middle uh it's on an open highway
in the middle of the board and you don't
have to kill it it's concrete it works
or it doesn't right and at this point
the angel's done don't find a way to
kill the king and says wow that's not so
easy yeah remarkable if all of this
happens but uh
so far they've been playing very very
well i mean shaq took
honestly
less time than i expected him to find b3
but i thought b3 was a difficult move
too right to spot and he spotted it very
easily which means that he is i think so
far i think he's been playing really
well he is he's on point being sharp and
uh definitely an improvement over his uh
his play yesterday and uh
i mean it's exactly what you want to
have on the board after first round loss
no question about it it's just a great
game uh turning our attention to ali
reza versus yan for a moment we did see
this move knight f8
and peter i'm looking at that f4 square
and i'm thinking to myself as white
i'm fearful that black goes knight g6
knight f4 and you know something
terrible happens to white what's your
perspective here is it okay
i don't know
for me the interesting part is jan
hasn't played knight g6 yet which i
suspect means that he uh is trying to
evaluate whether white can actually be
uh greedy here and take on f6 and take
on d5
which looks incredibly
suicidal looks incredibly risky but i'm
thinking with the bishop not the knight
i think this is important like
i think with a bishop on g5 okay it
still looks extremely extremely
dangerous but
maybe you can make an argument for it
because now after knight f4 which looks
like it might win the game if the knight
is allowed to get the g3 right i have
bishop take c4 this is why i took uh
this way to bishop to break the
connection between the rook on e8 and
the pawn on e4 and uh this still looks
incredibly dangerous for white because
if if black finds a way to break through
here somehow
the game will just be over yeah right
but i don't see it and white on the
other hand is really sort of one tempo
away from completely stabilizing
preparing to castle queenside and being
two central pawns up so just second so i
you you're telling me that uh jan is
fearful not fearful exactly but you do
need to know what's happening here
because it's a central pawn and he has
other options i think he can he has
played 96 by the way by by this point
but i mean it just feels to me like even
if you went a pawn and again
i'm sitting there looking at this king
over on uh richie's game and i'm saying
this king is at the center like okay i
make a stupid move i just posted it
let's go outside on queenie too yeah and
uh something uh three little castles
yeah
long castles just just along you know
you can get out of there
oh queen takes off some rook to e1
queen takes f2 and so when should i stop
you guys please jump right in i'll yeah
any time so bishop takes f6 and we'll
just do it on your board uh yes sir gfc
gf of course is possible yeah no no no
no queen takes is correct okay uh bishop
takes d5 knight f4 yasser sport is fine
uh knight f4 bishop takes e4 you guys
had all of that
and now there are several winning moves
winning
winning straight up winning one four
probably is one of them yeah bishop z4
bishop d5 is another whoa that is
beautiful that is beautiful i know that
is really really beautiful
and it just collapses
yeah
i mean as i said surprised that's not a
surprise at this point right now no i
wouldn't it wouldn't shock me in the
slightest but you do have to calculate
all these things because if you don't
have a killing blow like why does
legitimately i think one move away from
completely stabilizing them
and you do have a bishop on b8 and a
rook on a8 which i am participating in
the game which means that
it's not unthinkable that white actually
stabilizes but yeah machines are
machines are good at chess
all of which probably indicates that
alireza should play bishop g3 here
neither four
perhaps bishop c2 and uh kind of admit
that this has been a misadventure
well then it's just a bad position for
white i
don't like bishops too at all and for
those who are just joining us we are in
round two of our inaugural grandchild
store then from bucharest romania as
wesley soh is the only winner uh peter
from round one and he's up uh he's got a
big time matchup with mvl we'll we'll
check into that game we've been looking
at this game between ali reza and ian
and this position after knight f4
don't curse me uh but i do think
that something could be said for just
stepping aside absolutely from uh night
f
knight f4 to d3 check with king d2
yeah
then again after 93 there's a number of
pawns hanging so like sure
you might actually struggle protecting
both the f2 square not necessarily the
pawn but they have to square with the
fork to the rook on h1 right and also
the the the pawn on b2 exactly but all
in all i think we are absolutely in
agreement that this is not fun for white
but
something happened with g3
or h3
h3 was a surprise the whole sequence of
h3 followed by g3 g4 and i wondered why
jan played rookie eight but
in in hindsight this was a very very
strong move because it prepares this
night of fate move exactly
it looked it looked somewhat
insignificant i was looking after h3 i
thought maybe you can do something more
forcing but yan just spent a tempo
playing him with rook f88 which
did not seem to me like the most
necessary move in the position but it
turned out to be
exactly the right move he needed against
perhaps he actually guessed what what
alireza was was planning with the move
h3 exactly because my eyes yeah i didn't
consider this at all i did not think h3
could have been connected with the idea
of g3 g4 but
rookie 8 makes me think maybe jan
actually kind of deduced what the plan
was and prepare it for
prepared for it properly sometimes
you're sitting across the board it's not
like you're watching opponent's eyes or
something like that but something you
just pick up something and uh
h3 g3 g4 i think is an overreach by
by white but who knows uh
jump right in uh alejandro what's your
take there's no i mean i have the engine
take the engine says that h3 g3 g4 is
asking for it that this is way too much
it doesn't think that white is too much
worse okay but it does think that white
is worse that you have to retreat with
the bishop to g3 that you have to go
knight f4 and then bishop's e2 it
actually doesn't like at all if they
don't have to move bishop d7 because
you've given up the d5 pressure what
black can even start thinking of taking
on b5 and just munching upon
uh after the move knight g6 bishop g3 at
knight f4 it does consider king d2 as
one of the better options but the
engines you know they don't play like we
do they see an ugly position how do i
hold it they just take on f4
oh yeah i would be incapable of that
movie but exactly right humans don't
play like this they don't give up their
bishop for a knight on f4 and hope for
the best you're black you know that
you're going to be suffering the rest of
the game why did you go h3g4 this is
completely incongruent so with the
previous moves so i don't think this is
going to happen but what will happen in
in that case because kingly 2 is
difficult to make bishop takes a 4 is
difficult to make everything else is
landing alireza in a really bad position
so
we see
on round 2 already the youngster with
problems to solve and i want to see how
he handles this one
exactly also i was curious about about
the game of lavon
there h7 h6 was played and uh yeah no
sacrifice yeah bogdan chose not to play
a five on move 16 which was i think a
very important kind of a turning point
in the game he included rook 81 yeah kg1
is a very solid move but it does allow
as we see in the game it does allow
black time to consolidate to a large
degree by playing h6 and castling
driving the knight away from the
threatening square on
g5 and now after 95
i'm guessing uh i'm guessing
before yeah come right back to e4
took on f6 in the meantime we're kind of
returning to that but if he's if he is
intending to take on d5 which i suspect
he might be i don't say why else you
would ever talk otherwise otherwise yeah
it's clearly the wrong knight to be
taking like if you want to trade your
dark square bishop four at night it has
to be the knight on the four not the
knight on f6 so it seems like his
intention actually is to grab it to grab
a pawn which
uh yeah as we've established with the
help of our trusted computer
and our friend alejandra
is just losing uh if jan finds the the
way to convert and yan is extremely
strong in these tactical tactical
positions can we take on b7 yes you can
actually it is the best move
what yeah it's it's the best move to
take on on and after knight d3 checking
yeah let me let me go through that line
bishop g7 is the best move you could
also take on e6 but it does give black a
decisive advantage here check king d2
and perhaps alireza got to this position
and if queen takes f2 queen e2 is just
winning for white this rook on a8 is
trapped you have to trade the queens
this does not work at all so he might
have been tempted by the sequence the
problem for him will be if uh nepo
simply trusts his uh
initiative on this side the mover rook
a7 gives plenty of compensation you just
give up the rook for the knight but the
engines are saying this is the strong
move bishop f4 give up the exchange this
way it is an exchange and two pawns but
after takes and takes on aid there are
other moves to consider knight takes b2
with the idea of knight c4 is possible
you could also take
it's also possible but the engines are
saying rook 8 is the correct move simply
take the bishop back keep up all of your
threats and that this despite the huge
material advantage is just an awful
position for the white side you can
understand that b2 is hanging f2 is
hanging yes you're up material but it
doesn't look like it these rooks are
well not participating in the game the
king is the one of the most forward
pieces that white has is not exactly how
you want to be playing chess and
black has absolute dominance over the
position the pawns aren't going anywhere
the moment that one of them drops the
position collapses so it's going to be a
game in which white is basically
attending to his weaknesses hoping not
to fall apart in the next few moves but
that's pretty much all you get you don't
get to actually play with your extra
material
and queen takes f6 of course very
quickly played on the board the problem
with alyresa's position is that his
pigeon holds himself into it if you
don't take on d5 right now what are you
doing what are you doing nepo is going
to play knight f4 thank you for every
single dark square in your position oh
by the way d3 is also weak right so and
you've defended d5 so you have to take
on d5 you conceptually you have to take
on d5 in this position you cannot take
with the knight that straight up loses
yeah that's clear right and bishop takes
d5 knight f4 will lead him into an awful
position so this looks bad for aliresa
to begin round
number two and it also is not very
difficult to find these moves for uh for
black because if he decides not to play
the move knight f4 if for example he
decides that's too much material to
sacrifice i don't think nepo is that
type of player but let's say that
there's a more conservative player that
decides i don't want to sacrifice so
much material i'm going to keep my
compensation i just want to give one
pawn away and takes takes goes uh queen
g5 in this position
attacks this knight on d5 and says that
if you retreat i'm going to go to simply
knight f4 keep all of my positional
edges you could attack my queen i'll
move it away knight d3 check is still
coming on the board how do we evaluate
this position and the engine is saying
black is doing great here as well uh
very strong advantage so it doesn't
really matter which direction he chooses
sacrificing half of his board for
extreme compensation or just sacrificing
one pawn for positional compensation
both are advantage black
well for me the judgment that you have
to find
is this moment that you play knight
after bishop takes b7 you have to have
an incredibly
fine intuition for the attack the
initiative check king
and you don't play queen takes f2 like
something's wrong with you you don't
play knight takes f2 but you just simply
go bishop f4 yeah this mission is tanks
takes you give up an exchange in two
pawns yeah if you show me this position
without without the speech alejandro
gave earlier i would say
yeah with white i'd be scared but i
would be
very very unconvinced i'm doing so
poorly right because the k92 like it
obviously is in trouble but it's covered
by a pawn structure which will be not
that easy to attack the knight on b5 is
a very very important defensive resource
meaning that the the b file is is closed
for the time being because if rook b8
came and the knight on b5 wasn't there
this position i know i know is that
you're saying yes yeah but with an item
b5 blocking off the the very important b
file and white after all is a ton of
material right exchange
but you can see how powerful what black
species are exactly for example queen e2
i'm not even using an engine just play
bishop c4 yeah yeah sure but what's the
thread though like i go
yeah 95 is annoying and and the thing is
uh i currently there is no discovered
check but if i move a king anywhere
there will be a discover yeah i would
like to play king c2 here to unpin the
knight only three but this straight up
loses tonight before check of course
and
right yeah
no i understand what you're saying it is
very very scary but
once again we wear so much material up
that i would start by thinking before i
start calculating i would start by
thinking maybe i can return
quite a bit of it to trade stumps some
stuff away and then my position maybe
will become defensible but yeah uh
it obviously is uh
the more i look at this the more i
struggle like i can play b3 you will
quite happy to probably just take on b3
and return it to c4 next move right and
i haven't really achieved very much no
except you've lost your bond you know so
might be it might be a useful pawn uh it
is
strangely awkward right you start to
think well if queen e2 doesn't work
maybe i should play f1 and maybe i
should play queen g one maybe i can just
play king c quick king c2 here and just
offer a dawn of material straight up
like please take my pawn and the
exchange just to get rid of that octopus
on d3 exactly
i'm still a pawn up but right right
right despite all that i'm still born up
with white hat yeah but maybe the
problem is why after king c2 black has
other bishop takes e3 probably wins on
the spot on the options yeah
queen enough to check and then we should
be three check is unfortunately ending
the game on the spot that hurts that's
the thing right there's so many lines in
which whoops that's the end of the game
what whoops that's the end of this yeah
yeah absolutely the more i look at this
the more i understand that yeah
as usual machines are not wrong but it's
sort of like it it really takes that
feel unless these players are prepped
to the max and they've actually looked
at these types of things you come to the
game and you reach a position where
you're exchanging two pawns down and you
start to say
do i have enough
then you look at the position after
bishop f4 and you say yes you do that's
extraordinary but also i think i think
the sort of the the correct player is on
the black side of this game for this i
think because i think jan is very very
uh you know unafraid to part with
material very very unafraid to just sort
of go with the flow and play
play as the position dictates the only
reason i would think this might not
happen this exchange in two pawns
sacrifice is simply that the other
option is also good and you're not
facing such a huge material deficit
right a pawn deficit is such a
manageable amount of material
yeah bishop d5 played in by the way but
yeah as as we've explained you don't
play bishop to xf6 if you don't intend
to take on d5 exactly you have to have
at least some some extra material here
too well the whole concept of h3g3 g4
has led
white to this position where
well he's said a b c and d
which is i want to win the pawn on d5
he's done it and knight f4
as you were saying alejandro very very
sharp but if you want to
not burn all bridges bishop takes and
queen g5
is a
softer way yeah
it's
it seems like you're giving yourself
less of a chance of being immediately
winning
but it's also clear black has perfect
compensation at the very least like 93
not of four knight lens on d3 the king
will be stuck in the center for a pawn
you're you're you're you're very very
happy um could you take us to the game
of lanier and fabi what developments do
you have for us in that one alejandro
it's been a little bit of a slow affair
a slower slashing cuff as you see lanier
play the move a3 instead of any
expansion on the king side and they've
reached this very typical structure in
which black has a lot of pieces pointed
towards this d5 square the white is very
clearly controlling the game sometimes
revolves around that you want to take
twice on d5 and force your opponent to
take with the pawn and white wants the
opposite you he wants to force black to
take twice and be able to recapture with
a piece whether it's a queen or a rook
on d5 so you see there's a little bit of
dance between black and white uh based
on the d5 square and around it it comes
also the e4 pawn that's why the break f5
is such a common idea the engine is
suggesting a move like knight c8 i've
never seen these ideas but
the idea is that after a5 the
superfluous knights will be disconnected
once one leaves i can return to e7 and
then continue this dance around the d5
square they just say equal it's
obviously not going to be an
earth-shattering strategy against this
fashion cuff but it is good enough to at
least pose practical problems here fabi
is thinking uh lanier spent a ton of
time to get to this position because
this is already this is still theory and
four moves later he spent uh he's down
to 42 minutes on the clock he spent 43
plus whatever increment he had gained
which is a fair amount of time to get to
this position uh black's probably okay i
expect to move f5 way over knight c8 but
there must be other ways of handling
this position well white doesn't have an
immediate threat uh a4 might come at
some point but if you haven't played it
yet then it's no there's no reason to
think that it's going to immediately
destroy your position black has other
ways of playing even a quiet move like
king h8 can be considered in this in
this scenario so it's not the most
exciting game it's definitely not going
to have our attention the way the
alireza game i have the feeling we'll
have our attention but we will keep an
eye on it and people are keeping an eye
on the games our friends in romania
let's check in with them
thank you alejandro yes that game that
you were mentioning you guys have been
focusing on is of course the game of the
day the one between ali reza and nepo
and that one is a fierce battle between
the two players but another fierce
battle that we are having our eyes on is
the one between mamedyarov and richie
rapport and this was the game that you
mentioned at the beginning of the
broadcast as being the one that you're
going to be focusing on tell us a bit
about this gate yeah i mean i think all
the expectations worked out today very
pretty well i mean we had a really nice
sharp opening um nobody can understand
what's going on basically even the
computers are a little bit confused and
also if you look at the if we think
about the perfect game scenario i think
we also have now the king at the center
of the board and a lot of interesting
moves are happening variations are
flowing um i don't know looking at this
position and i see the king on e7 i'm
wondering what just happened in the
opening phase and without the engine i
consider this position as pretty much
borderline losing for black nevertheless
the engine says something completely
different tell us about that exactly i
mean the evaluation is not so bad and um
i mean
with the last move e4 rich is trying to
close the center i think he's doing the
logical thing he's just trying to avoid
opening the center and it's not possible
to do it at the right moment because if
you play f3 you are simply losing the
knight right so it's just not easy to up
oops dope on the center immediately
so um white has to find a way how to go
after this king and it's not that easy
he needs to spend a couple of is
probably moving the knights either to d1
or moving his queen to e3 and then
trying to play f3 so let's say you go
with the queen here now this keeps
contact with the knight on c3 and then
protects against uh any sort of queen
take c3 gets ready to play the move f3
what would you do as black in this
mission and how do you assess this
position visually without the engine
yeah i mean when i look at this position
i think those nights they got some
squares but it still takes time to come
there and you can see the two bishops
the pair of the bishops but i'm not sure
if it's so good at the moment i think
it's the game continues
and we're going to see a lot of
interesting
adventures actually this move knight to
a4 was just played let's see how long he
thought for eight minutes spent by
mamedyarov well this one is not this one
were
on the wrong game this one is just an
incredible game is developing quite
quickly at a very fast pace i have to
say i'm looking at the position and i
understand both players they really
enjoy what they're doing right now
because both players are such creative
geniuses and they definitely enjoy these
type of positions guys what do you think
uh thank you christian and us anastasia
uh for me i'm looking black's king in
the center i'm with christian all the
way not looking at a computer engine i'm
just saying
black's in deep
deep trouble yeah it looks it looks
extremely risky but right
knight a4 is a bit of a surprise by the
way it is it is but i think you can
relate to to the idea that shakira puts
into this movie it's it's c4 i think
it's more just that he wants to play f3
yeah he was impossible while the knight
on c3 was hanging and also knight a4 has
an additional uh additional uh advantage
of perhaps
uh
it being useful to shahriar to be able
to meet king d7 with knight c5 check
because the king needs to go somewhere
to avoid f3
and the desired direction i think is
still has to be d7 and c8 right get out
of the dodge yeah if you can play king
j7 rook a8 and king c8 suddenly black's
position looks fantastic right i'm just
going to make a very bad move and
uh suddenly everything
something like this is at least very
drainable a dream and maybe already
better for black exactly but the quote
the problem as you've been discussing f2
f3
one way of puncturing uh that balloon if
you will knight a4
let's say i make a move okay e8 f3 comes
and oops that's a huge tempo
the game sort of still continues but i'm
struggling to to hold it together
because like here fe4 c4 is also very
attractive here but even the simpler the
simpler stuff just take only four go
knight c5 just start picking up material
it looks terrible it looks like it's
just falling apart
yeah both of those things look extremely
strong yeah i don't know why i keep on
arguing against the others it's okay
it's okay no no no no but i mean uh the
point is is this king in the center and
we're just looking at this king and
we're going to say well
bullseye you know like c4 f3 yeah these
moves play themselves i must say that i
was with anastasia all the way with the
move knight d1 i i thought okay
you know like i want to include
everybody that's your chess culture
shining right i want it on e3 because
it's such a beautiful square and i
wanted to bring the knight on h4 into
the play as well but the more you what
you were saying
the black king getting ready to run for
the queen side the move knight c5 starts
very very attractive king g7
king d7 knight c5 check the problem here
is that now suddenly this rook
is no longer defended we have
disconnected the rogue yeah still f3
maybe we can take
and uh if you have to take with the
knight maybe black gets a very important
tempo to play b6
right so
weirdly i have a feeling that the game
isn't really decided just yet even
though it looks unbelievably dangerous
like here i can also probably play b6
and hope that i'm still alive so right
somehow the the fact that the rook on g8
is not protected really is is
frightening so for us
you know again visually richie's
position
is rocky but then again how's the chess
engine about no no no no no no i'm not
ruining it you're not really
what the
zeros and the variation is simply not
going to happen so i'm not going to give
it oh wow uh there's zero percent i have
i have uh
good good vision good vision good vision
though there's no way yeah that's not
happening not happening the light is f5
that's not happening okay f5 f5 f3 of
course f3 yes of course you give a check
h1
f4
you can actually get there move by move
though because otherwise you just lose
material so you have to like use squares
this part this part we get i i get that
much but why is black's position not
collapsing after rkf8 queen d2
is a mystery to me i guess the they go
bishop f6 or something yeah
yeah
and somehow this is
actually zero
yeah yeah actually having looked at the
first line i think you might get there
simply by process of elimination because
everything else is so horrible so i
think the biggest task there for for
rehard would be to consider the move of
6f5 because it looks like what you're
doing is just creating yeah you're
trapping your own bishop creating more
weaknesses for your opponent to play for
and
yeah i think that would be the biggest
hurdle here for uh for any player on the
black side of this position just to kind
of i mean you consider a five because
you've attacked the pawn on d4 and
you've given yourself some squares
but then you realize like both f3 and h3
on the surface level appear to be
winning on the spot i don't know why h3
isn't winning to be honest like f3 we've
discussed why is h3 uh not just
yeah it looks like hg rock g4 knight
takes a five
i guess you have to go the same f4 right
yeah yeah
h3 f4 4 and then what queen of four rook
fade and the cafe and then d7
where are we going it's can i take on h3
is it a rook fe or something is that too
much oh yeah maybe uh
yeah but it's it's it's bizarre but i
think as is often the case these guys
are so good at chess that
weirdly the biggest hurdle is simply not
stopping yourself from continuing to
calculate
because i think if you force yourself
not to give up in your mind's eye after
5h3 if you see if you tell yourself
there might be something here you you
stumble upon a four because you your
bishop has no moves you have to do
something about it exactly so you give
it some squares your force queen takes a
four you start considering you might
land on the idea of pin takes h3 bishop
takes h3 here which alejandro just did i
think completely unplugged so
we have seen it being
possible before our very eyes uh and i
mean it's a mess i still
like i would feel with black that maybe
i'm completely lost but
but maybe not not certainly because
some things have improved i have now uh
yeah the bishops are more more your
rooks are still connected and you still
have a dream of evacuating your kids so
and the here are the score uh the scores
in the in their previous encounters are
actually doing really well
and they they played this absolutely mad
game in the last year sing field cop
right where both of them were avoiding
draws but like they played an increment
for like the last ten moves the first oh
that game and they both were they they
were both dodging very safe
continuations and uh
yeah yeah they're a great game i
remember now yeah that was a fantastic
game
for those of you who haven't seen it
just search for uh the game shock one
with the white pieces against richard in
the single cup 2021. it was just
unbelievable and with very little time
on this clock richard kept upping the
ant i'm finding these incredibly
double-edged uh
continuations well this is a game we'll
definitely keep an eye on as well our
tournament leader wesley so let's just
check in on him this was the queen's
gambit accepted
not much has been happening there's not
much
going on yeah very very tame position
and i would say and yeah on the topic of
players in this tournament being decent
at chess uh fabi thought for a bit and
actually played knight e7 c8
which really which really isn't a move
that i have seen very much in any in any
of these fashion echoes so knight e7 c8
but the move that was mentioned by
alejandro and once you see it yes you do
understand the reasoning behind it but
still uh
it's a concept which i'm sort of
familiar with but there is a very famous
position in the uh in one of the
betweenings books in an english opening
where black is supposed to play knight
ca just to avoid trading one of the
knights on d5 but i haven't seen it done
in the threshold even though the the
theme as uh as alejandra mentioned this
is basically the concept of the
superfluous knight where white has a
very very good square for their light
pieces on d5 but sort of too many pieces
vying for it right so it's very much to
white's advantage to be able to trade
one of them to put the other one on d5
yet again so five says no
let's keep both of your knights on the
board and then i will drive one of them
away so it doesn't have a easy way to
coming off coming back to d5 and then i
will rechallenge resume challenging the
other one i get it the the concept is
not unheard of but i don't think i've
ever seen it done in this fashion eco
goes
in this and quite this way
cool
i mean
thinking outside of the box 97 c8
and
prepping a5
again
we mentioned the world championship
match 2018
fabi on the white side exclusively in
the sveshnikovs
he's playing like he's at home
like
i mean if you studied the special cup
enough from the white side i guess you'd
learn how to play from the black side
huh
we did a little bit of work yeah okay
yeah it took a couple hours you know i
don't know that's fashion cup but yeah
work paid off okay i think favi is an
interesting player because he's not
afraid of playing different ideas and
different structures and sometimes you
can actually tell that he doesn't play
those structures and comes up with weird
ideas that makes sense over the board
and the move knight c8 for example i've
played this magical whole my life i've
never seen it
but he has no problems it's especially
attractive to him because he gets to
keep pieces and it's just the way that
he loves playing chess where you keep up
the fight and you create problems to
your opponent where a lot of players i
think they love trading pieces and going
into more simplified positions favi
shies away from those
yeah and uh in the meantime uh in our
second sort of central game of the round
uh as we suspected might happen uh jan
went for
a very strong continuation but the one
that gives up less material right
because it is it is strong uh
he felt that yeah this is definitely
good enough and i'm i'm quite happy to
only be
one pawn down instead of like the whole
chess set and this of course is the
bishop takes d5 game of uh ali raza he
didn't uh play
uh the
double edge super sharp knight f4 bishop
takes b7
he you pulled in his horns a little but
he says look bishop takes b5 knight
takes uh d5 queen g5 is still good for
me yeah we didn't really uh it has to be
addressed i guess uh because it's i
think a question that our viewers might
be asking why not knight c7 here because
it does appear to be winning a lot of
material the issue with that is that we
take on c7 we play 43
and i think the king only one uh dies
normally doesn't survive type you know
the the attacks of of this strength
white is just way too disconnected and
way too undeveloped
to be able to to afford uh i guess even
the whole rook here might not be enough
for white and an exchange definitely
will not be enough here
uh to compensate for the amount of the
amount of initiative black has developed
in the center exactly this knight's
still again coming to f4 it looks like a
it looks like knight e3 is forced but
then again we do get the the this
position and
you know alejandro assures us that the
chess engine loves uh black's position
great compensation
and uh whatnot but you kind of
mentioned that in that position where
you were in exchanging two pawns up you
kind of have a feeling like i should be
able to fight
wouldn't you also have that same type of
feeling or would you feel
i'm only a pawn up and yeah i i i feel
kind of despondent here with white
because yeah it just doesn't feel like
you have enough it feels like you need
to be more material up for the amount of
trouble you're about to be in here
a single a single meager phone uh even
though i mean it's a very very beautiful
pawn structure that white has their own
size people have never been pronounced
in the studio a single
meager yeah i mean i'm tasered by such
uh language incredible yeah yeah right
what we have given for pawns in this
industry and uh
we interrupt our usual broadcast to to
bring you more of the these guys are
good at chess
moments yeah f6 five in midair of
rapport yeah wow these guys these guys
are good at challenging they have seen
this game before yeah they may have seen
this game before that's an incredible
move right
let's go for it and again for those of
you uh who are joining us a little late
we are expecting that uh gary kasparov
will join us from romania as he was
there at the opening ceremony so jews
keep that
in mind that should be coming up and
this move f6 f5
man that's that's that's tough
deep breath it is
very impressive it is very very
impressive what they're doing here and
also you you get the feeling i don't
know i don't want to read too much into
it because i haven't really been playing
each other that much but you get the
feeling that you know you sometimes get
those pairings of players where you just
get this idea that maybe they enjoy
playing each other because they're sort
of on the same wavelength
and they produce fun stuff exactly and i
think both of them actually kind of
value right
having fun games
potentially sort of more than you know
maybe even winning them exactly
uh i don't know like did you have
players like this yeah i i i
for for me i just really enjoyed
watching larry christensen yeah i mean
he just he just swung an incredibly big
bag
that's a bit different but
christensen and john nan when they come
together you know there's going to be
just a marvelous class yeah well i was
talking specifically about you oh me
yeah who did i really like to have
larry christiansen is one of the guys
that you just knew that when we sat down
at the board also when we commentate
together we we take a very dry desert
position with nothing happening and
we're sacrificing rooks
uh larry is a great fan sorry i mean for
me the immediate name uh that comes to
mind is vasily vanciuk and also due to a
degree even though we haven't really
played for
quite a long time alexander is average
yes
we used to have we used to have battles
and it also it went in streaks like he
there would be a period where i would
like lose every single game to him with
both colors and then there would be
suddenly a period where i would do okay
and then he would start beating me again
and and also with vasily i think we
played a number of
very very exciting games where uh yeah
it just felt like we brought sort of the
the best out of each other i don't know
maybe we'll disagree or possibly the
worst yeah alejandro did you have such
an opponent where you just said like
okay i'm gonna kill you this game and
then you got killed or vice versa
i actually don't have such roller
coaster records i tend to have like
either a very good record against an
opponent or a really bad record against
an opponent uh like against players of
this tournament i haven't played that
many but i'm a plus scorer against
wesley
um but from the top i have a huge minus
score against hikaru hikaru's always
been a nemesis for me uh we played since
we were very young he's uh only a
year and some older than me so we played
youth tournaments junior tournaments we
played u.s championships together and
i've never beaten him and he's gotten
the best of me like two or three times
but it's always a fun game because i'm
always lower rated than him and he
always tries to beat me you know black
why it doesn't matter he always goes
through my to him for my throat so it's
always fun to play against him and try
to
you know
defend a little bit white black green
doesn't matter i'm always finding myself
defending against hikaru nice nice now
try to make heads or sense of this yeah
no no no there's no there's no there's
no way
there's no way i went through the line
that we proposed right we proposed h3
not bad f4 only move we got this so far
so good right double question mark
double question mark like none of this
works
let me go through it if you go queen
takes f4 the engine thinks that rook af8
is the only way of playing the dust and
loose and this forces the move queen h2
why not queen e3 because apparently
bishop h6 is bad for white beyond my
understanding you have to go to h2 and
the only great move is bishop d7 not to
e6 because of knight g6 chuck and this
is a winning advantage for black why
[Music]
and after f5
the more
dangerous i think for both sides i think
that h3 is just dangerous for white uh
because f4 it doesn't need to go queen
h2 uh i don't think you really want to
play like that is the move f3 and after
bishop takes d4 check absolutely force
king each one is absolutely forced f4 is
absolutely forced queen takes f4 is
forced this rook af8 is forced in this
move and now the question is where does
the queen go uh because the queen does
have a couple of uh
of squares the most logical is of course
to put it on d2 where it hits the bishop
on d4 and you're hitting the bishop on
g4 only move for black is bishop f6 you
counter attack this knight on h4 we got
this far and we forgot at the fact that
bomb takes e4 actually threatens pawn
takes d5
also hitting the king hitting the queen
so you have to take on e4 and the
surprising part here is that even though
the king cannot cross to the d-file
because of the queen and it cannot cross
to the f-file because well it's gonna
run into pins and stuff like that the
fact that this knight is so far away
from the board means that it's not easy
to actually create threats against upon
e4 remember that the knight on h4 is
currently hanging for example i was uh
checking a move like rook f4 trying to
see if it was enough but it's just not
quite enough after bishop takes h4 uh
rook f84 is in is not enough rook check
is met with bishop e6 and black is just
barely holding on but since you're off
material it's a winning advantage
so it's not easy to for me at least to
think that here black's king
is relatively safe because perhaps with
an engine and looking at it from this
perspective i could see it but
calculating that your king is safe
in that position here that's that's real
talent i mean how how do you even come
up with the idea that the d-file is cut
the f-pile is cut but your king's gonna
be okay on e7 that is just the way that
rapport plays chess that's why we all
love him and this is gonna be a wild one
it's hard for me to say exactly what's
gonna happen because okay i have an
engine that doesn't blunder
but
it's hard to say exactly what these
players are thinking in in this position
because i'm sure that many mistakes are
being considered
yeah absolutely and i i think as i
mentioned i think you get to those moves
just simply by you know frantically
searching for something that is playable
and
refusing everything else uh because yeah
considering a five for more than five
seconds uh
if you have other options yes very very
different and he did right he did have
other options they were just not as
attractive
and there we see shaq at the board
looking at
frantically
calculating
because again i i mean i'm looking at
this king on e7 i'm just thinking to
myself you know i have to win exactly i
think i think we all know exactly the
kinds of thoughts that are going through
his head he's basically telling us to
tell him to tell himself
i must continue calculating until i find
the forced win which is surely here it's
surely yeah because like my position
looks like it should be winning exactly
and it's not and you're sort of running
around in circles searching for that
forest win and normally in a position
like this maybe it will be there but now
you know we know that against best play
he isn't actually winning at all
and it's it's actually a dangerous
situation for uh for a player in his
shoes because you might kind of
overextend
because of your sort of inner
understanding your
inner belief yeah that a position like
this must be very good for white
absolutely so it's possible to let's say
at the very least it's very possible to
like burn half an hour here searching
for a win leave yourself like 10 minutes
for 20 moves and then you're potentially
in trouble half an hour he doesn't have
it's 37 um minutes for the remaining 23
moves so this is definitely a time to
burn clock if you think you have a win
but
it's dangerous right
but wouldn't you
wouldn't your spidey sense everything
you know about chess suggests to you
that you're winning here as white yeah
yeah yeah he's played of three quickly
and i quite like the fact that he's
played off three quickly because i think
you uh from a practical standpoint it's
very very good to just commit to
something which you believe is correct
and just just go for it because this is
clearly not going to be the last
important calculation he needs to make
in the game and he can't really commit
uh commit too much of his remaining time
not a lot of moves have been played that
was move 18 f2 f3 each player has
roughly 40 minutes and they're 30
seconds
so
if this comes down to a wire like that
it came from the sink fill cup
it wouldn't be unexpected
we're really kind of struggling today
it's an embarrassment of reaches for us
because it's it seems weird to drag
ourselves drag ourselves away from this
position but there's also a position
where i've been trying to solve it on my
own and kind of coming close but
somewhat failing so i want to ask
alejandro and his uh and his stockfish
because it feels to me
which game uh only 0.7 amazing to me i
thought this must lose by force i
thought before
i thought e4 e3 has to win here but
apparently it doesn't uh
pardon me ali raza did not play the move
knight a3 play c3c4 trying to i guess
include very importantly i think rook a3
is a hugely important resource that he
has in many of these lines fighting for
control over the f4 square as well
but c3 c4 that just looks like but i i
assumed that uh e3 would be uh would be
a
decisive blow but i'm guessing it holds
somehow why why would you need e4 e3 why
wouldn't you just play knight f4 right i
guess i think his idea is knight bc3
here knight b
c3 and allowing a 93 check is very
knight d3 check
yeah maybe maybe just going out of four
yeah but i thought maybe
okay you're thinking e4 e3
yeah right i thought this wins and my
point was if you go knight takes e3 yeah
i think bishop g3 might actually end the
game here oh that's nasty
the four also looks strong but bishop g3
i thought might actually just straight
up and the game on the spot castles is
possible but even bishop to rookie three
looks like you just don't survive this
normally with rook a8 to come and knight
h4 and things of that nature i feel like
i'm playing a piece down yeah like i'm
i'm still only upon down here with black
green remarkably it feels like you've
got all the material advantages
in the world uh so e4 e3 but the killer
but i think fe3 probably and then you
run to run for the hills you go fe and
if knight i wanted to play a knight of
four here my point was neither four but
i think knight bc3 holds here
potentially which is very heartbreaking
g2 and i run
and you run this is this is what i what
i settled on that here i go knight
knight takes in king c2 i think white
might be better which is very unfair you
can get some nice
bolt hole
uh to escape to uh
and that's a that's a very nice
variation where where
getting on your running shoes is
sometimes
the oldest defense in the world yeah
run
it's it still works
yeah jump right in alejandro what do you
think about these lines that peter is
espousing it doesn't really matter what
i think it matters what the engine
thinks okay the engine thinks e3 loses
straight up loses for black uh you can
you can take the pawn you have to take
with the pawn on k3 and now you could go
bishop f4 but after castles and king h1
the engines are saying white has an
extra pawn and the compensation wow
because you're going to get queen f3 in
the knights are threatening to go to
scene for h4 i see on myself and knight
f4 has the issue of h4 this is the only
good move but is sufficient uh because
you run out of squares for the queen
knight g2 check doesn't quite work you
have to move king d2 you run this way
and on knight takes h4 well you've
destroyed your position yeah for the h
prime for the h pawn right who cares
about the h pawn right right white
consolidates queen e2 or kf1 the knights
are superb the rook's going to come to
f5 white is simply winning in this
position so after the move e3 pawn takes
e3 uh white has
perfect defense rook takes e3 just does
not work um
knight takes e3 queen takes e3
queen e2 is more than sufficient here
for white you still run to the queen
side against bishop g3 checking d1 can
see one king b1 you'll just make your
way over there and of course the rook is
going to come to a3 cover the third rank
no problems there and that's why nepo
instead of sacrificing with the move e3
how's it going with the move bishop f4
engines
hate this move
i should have four they hate this move
i'm also trying to understand what the
point is
i was thinking knight f4 knight f4 it
was definitely the best move by the
engine okay giving black a slight edge
uh but i'm really wondering what he's
planning to play against queen e2
because e3 i always have f3 now
is this his plan ah f3 bishop g3 is not
clear
maybe this is his idea but
i'm a little confused on why
not knight f4 because why united 4 was
refused is uh rejected is uh is the big
question yeah knight f4 and the angels
did thing knight c3 as you were
mentioning was the best continuation for
white and you could consider knight
check um it still thinks black is better
in this position you have such a great
knight f5 is coming also to open up the
king it doesn't think that white is out
of resources or anything like that it
even sometimes likes better to play the
roof rook a6 first and bring this one to
e6 or f6 or wherever it needs to go to
depending on the position and again it
considers black to be slightly better
after the move bishop f4 the engines
just completely flip around say plus 1.5
great advantage for the white side with
the compensation for the pawn as well as
the pawn itself so
not very happy uh the engines with what
nepo has done and uncharacteristically
for him he's down on the clock
yeah alireza is
among his many positive qualities he is
a very good practical player he um
he can play quickly when he needs to and
today i mean playing quicker than jan in
this position on the white side of this
position is actually quite remarkable
because the light the stakes the stakes
are higher for lereza because if he
makes one misstep here he just gets
mated in the center so but i actually
started i started to think what what on
earth was bishop for and i think i get
it i think i get it he wants to go rook
d rook d5
yeah that's definitely one one reason
for bish before you connect the rooks
you bring the other one into the game
and yes rook g8 takes d5 and e4 e3 is
something that is very attractive sort
of aesthetically and also in some
positions will be very strong but yeah
we need to i'm i think we need to is
just basically being played here with
the intention of
just walking towards c2 against most
things that can do
[Music]
and uh by the way in the game between
wesley so and mvl we
have been
witnessing a repetition
thus far but staying with our game of
ali visa for a second i really like
if there was something that really drew
me to the move um
c3 c4 sorry i've got to find the game
here it is it was this idea of putting
the rook on a3
i really like that and bishop f4 to my
eyes has just kind of got this one
dimensional
well it's the most it's the most
important uh
i mean if e3 comes off and if the
position becomes open in the center the
king only one will
will die it will probably be why it's
downfall so exactly i i can understand
the idea of trying to force force the
movie 343 in but yeah
the engine just says that you can
actually ignore e3 here and just go king
d1 i think this is the point because f3
bishop g3 check is
both playable yeah and then rook again
rook d5 knight four very much comes into
the uh sorry just uh so
not not to play the move f2 f3 but after
e3 just to sidestep the e file play king
d1 drop your king on
any trades
no harm no foul
or no blood no foul yeah the the shito
square is extremely safe for white so
we're just aiming our king towards uh
towards safety on the queen side here
even this position doesn't look remotely
clear to me like i'm i'm looking at the
evaluation on alejandra screen and i'm
kind of
uh
somewhat flabbergasted here like rook
ac8 here why is this so horrible for
black like
if we have to play b3 uh king c2 will be
impossible for the next few moves
because of queen takes d5 i've created
this kind of a safety valve for
ourselves by stopping king c2 and i have
a tempo here to do something and i'm
still only a pawn down here
but there is rook
rook f1 or rookie one or rook i don't
know a to e so there's plenty of plans
but still we're just upon down there's a
king on d1 we have active pieces we have
rooks on open files
this is where you get very very confused
by computer evaluations
yeah and i just i i'm warming up to the
fact that this knight on d5 is actually
a
really really marvelous space it
it it does double ample uh double duty
uh defending the king blocking the
defile but also covering e3 squares
keeping you uh honest
on the f4 square boy uh
a really really tough game uh to yeah
and in the meantime in the meantime the
entire line which we
in unison suggested will never ever
appear on the board the entire line is
on the board yeah between richie and uh
shaq we did see the move f2 f3 we bishop
takes d4 check came all the tempo
f5 f4
queen takes f4
but we have the first result of round
two wesley so
uh forcing a repetition against maxima
sherlock graph this ended in a draw
the engines did like wesley's position a
bit better at the end but yeah i wonder
why queen g7 isn't great but
i mean it it was like plus point six or
seven oh okay yeah it was a serious
advantage but well as i decided to call
it a day and that's the first result in
the books
yeah
just to be clear uh this was the
repetition and you both were questioning
why didn't it i mean i thought ng3 was
sort of played with the intention of
playing playing quincy seven yeah sure
then he's on play it anyway i was a bit
confused but
uh
i guess after knight d5 you might make
some you might have to make some
uncomfortable decisions but queen a5
doesn't really really even queen a7 but
both of those moves look perfectly safe
at the very least
and may be annoying for black because a6
is is hanging many of this in many of
these variations
and yes the rook on g5 looks kind of
vaguely threatening but not unmanageable
too and it also looks like it could be
offside yeah it could it could yeah
because like you can you can imagine
some very artificial variations where
some some kind of hg2 tactics happen but
they are very artificial white basically
needs to blunder something quite badly
to allow some tactics here so queen c7
engine approved actually the engine
wants to play queen f4 i think queen c7
is a little better for white but it
wants to play queen f4 bring the knight
to d5 and only then play the move queen
f3
bring this rook to f5 and it just goes
queen e2 thank you for the tempo because
e4 is going to be threatened sometimes
and rk5 is also a threat
oh yeah that that is
this is not quite quite subtle and
non-obvious but
having said all that it's clear that in
every single line that we're discussing
white runs no precisely zero risks
well uh the whole idea of the rubenstein
variation the queen's gambit accepted
with the pawn on b3 playing this early
pawn on b3 literally this is the dream
position you have a knight on c4 which
is the whole idea of a4 and so on you
have a protected bishop on anchored
nicely on the d4 square and you've
created what you hope will be this
target with an half open a file this is
advantage white this is why you do this
i mean you never really know what a
chass player is feeling right i mean the
resulting game isn't just what's going
on on the board there's a lot of things
that go off the board as well but
judging it from a just
on the board position it this is not a
good repetition for wesley yeah it looks
like white has achieved his maximum that
he could expect from this opening but
wesley called it the
early day i wanted to ask you about the
other queen's gambit accepted that was
going on in lavon's game because it's
sort of like that position got hosed
we were looking at all kinds of
wonderful sacrifices with f5 and 96 and
gosh knows we were we were sacrificing
all the pieces that weren't ours
and
we saw none of that it was a slow
uh
positional maneuvering game and then
came this move g4 well i mean gaining
some space and also
this is now uh
in particular with the knight on c4
against specifically the dark square
bishop it's a very catalan diet that's
what i want you to ask
on d3
and in catalans i think you're quite
happy to give away your dark square
bishop to to have exactly this
positional uh uh so exactly this
material balance left on the board i
don't know why you're insisting on
knight a3 i would have played 96 there
it sure looks like
you know if you want to attack the pawn
on b5 why not do it from a good square
instead of a bad square uh something
like
that
yeah but we have rook fd1 in every
single line of those right right i mean
three maybe yeah it had to be this that
threw them backwards uh otherwise those
moves have been played
how do you handle that though right yeah
rook c3 is actually very annoying there
i i underestimated that yeah because
otherwise you don't play knight no he
played knight a3
you asked a very salient question well
why didn't you attack the b flying ball
from the d6 square not on the a3 square
knight i3 on the board rook b8 on the
board
and
entertaining some thoughts here with b7
rook fc8 i normally bl
wha
that move was played with eight seconds
left guys what i don't know how we
missed this but jack is down to 38
seconds four
well
i guess i guess he got up yeah he has
enough time now that he came uh no no
he's already 28. he's almost 28. he's
the last 12 moves to make by the way
wasn't this the the match-up last year
where levone tricked him in this
marvelous
uh ending
uh it was it was it was a draw draw
headed for a draw completely
but there was one trick yeah yeah yeah
yeah uh that lavone set up that was
master
masterful and
dark fell right into writing yeah right
remember
uh but we have christian carrillo with
maxine vashirograph
well in just a second
possibly consensusly uh tentatively
while we're waiting for updates perhaps
uh without going too in-depth i just
want to bring up the position in the uh
no no in the
that we have seen dominguez versus
karana i have a feeling that fabi might
be better
wow because i think knight a4 is very
strong here in exactly the yeah after
knight c8 the game continued
uh rook fd1 a5 knight c2 and here he
played knight b6 instead of 97 i think
specifically with the idea of meeting
knight e3 with knight a4
uh
and after knight a4 uh if it's played
and if i'm not miscalculating something
horribly linear will have kind of a
tough choice here because
maybe quincy ii is fine though quincy
two i uh because yeah i'm threatening
knight takes b2 but i'm also threatening
knight c5 and then bishop takes e3 and
bishop take c4
and i thought i thought that double
threat was very strong but queen c2
probably handles it
efficiently enough and now we finally do
have the interview christian is going to
i have with maximo shirograd
thank you peter yes we are here with mvo
after quite a tense draw i have to say
maxine first of all welcome back to
bucharest welcome back to the studio
here tell us a bit about your first
impressions of bucharest how did the
first two games go for you
so far so good
i was a little bit pressing against
linear
yesterday but
i couldn't
find the the correct plan i guess i mean
even at the end
i'm actually
slightly better if i play with g5 but i
didn't quite believe in it
and today
well i managed to
to surprise wesley with the queen's
gambit accepted well actually at first
move right after knight to f3 you played
d5 and wesley thought for five minutes
were you surprised about that what is
your general experience between you two
guys
um i mean westlake definitely expected
either gwenfeld or
english like positions of the knight of
sky generally go c5
so you adjusted maybe to figure out
which line i was prepa prepared for
because of course it can be completely
accepted it can be
coins can be declined it can be slav
so
and he decided to buy the bullet with
the four knight to f6 c4 and you took on
c4 and at this point did you feel like
he was surprised by your decision did he
seem concerned at all
i don't think he was concerned i mean uh
it's very solid it's not like i'm
putting any real firework
in this game this queen's gonna be
accepted and i played it a couple of
times already different since it's world
blitz championship
but maybe never in classical so
uh
you know i think was they were just
trying to figure out which line you
would play and it did seem like he was
gaining some traction in the middle game
it felt like he's gaining momentum and
putting some pressure where'd you feel
like you got out of danger
if at all yeah i don't know whether i
got out of danger here i thought
so my point here queen c7 doesn't work
bishop
bishop d8 and now if you go queen a7 you
would lose badly
okay 8 is next that's very nice and if
you go queen d6 it's also not so great i
thought because
maybe i'm wrong actually but i saw this
uh well actually it does seem like the
computer at this point once knight e8
yeah or could be seven yeah i thought i
had ideas uh but this could have been a
try so yeah it was a bit of a
miscapitation and queen f4 here i wanted
just to go
um
actually
not great but i thought this should be
good enough for me to work in the worst
case did you get to chat a bit with
wesley after that did you guys discuss
this moment no not really but i yeah i
thought this was the critical moment
because of g5 is very
of course a very principal decision
and another idea by the engine was
something along the lines of just trying
to keep the position as it is and
force uh well at least provoke the
knight to go to d5 and dangle queen to
f3 hide the queen did you consider this
at all yeah of course but i didn't think
it was too much trouble but maybe it is
not that clear
so maybe maybe i shouldn't play all g5
but
uh
yeah i must say i didn't consider to
bring the root back to d8 maybe
like this is a bit too much for me a bit
too deep
and without putting too much pressure i
i want to ask you about your compatriot
uh alireza your new compatriot ali reza
first of all what is uh your general uh
experience with alireza since he joined
the french team by we know that he had
an explosive result at
european championships he managed to
i think it was mutually beneficial that
managed to adapt so well to
to the team and to be friendly with with
everyone of course we
all did our best to make more fear
to make him feel uh as much
welcome as possible
and uh it showed in his result it showed
of course in
the atmosphere we had
in this european team championship and
hopefully we can have some more of that
in our next team competitions and how
about this one position without looking
at the engine too much what is your
first instinct
is of course i i looked at the engine
but i was pretty scared for for him
scared okay yeah because he is a partner
but history is a big threat so
of course i know that he's fine
supposedly yeah
but i was not sure what was happening
for instance here i thought and maybe it
doesn't work but i was thinking about
moves like e3
it doesn't seem to work
because of some crazy stuff like bishop
xf6 yeah
it takes f2 or like f6 i wasn't sure
yeah some sort of crazy situation
doesn't seem to work so
still a wild game typical of his youth
you might uh say of course
and uh thank you very much mvl for
joining us and looking forward to see
you in the next few rounds yeah thank
you christian guys back to you thank you
christian thank you mvl as we prepare
for a break for those of you who are a
little late in joining us don't worry
we've got gary kasparov
coming up
and uh good peter just before we go one
last quick questions about the shack
richie game how do you feel it's
developed
well we we know this is fine for black
somehow which is crazy yeah because we
got here with alejandro and uh
we know this this holds but without that
knowledge i would still like i still
don't know why neither five check isn't
borderline chilling or knight f3 just
like the five bishop rook five i can't
really figure out what the move is
because
like white is doing this for free we
haven't really sacrificed anything
uh knight c5 for rook c5 for queen
before check i have like tons of threads
the pawn on e4 seems borderline
borderline doom there's still a king on
e7 you're right i mean everything that
seems to be by this point by this point
if it's not a five-check king e6 i will
not be holding no but five takes takes
tactics bishop h films c3 bishop c3
yeah i was thinking his back rank uh
issues uh yeah that explains many things
yeah right that bishop c3
uh
holding by a hair uh but will be taking
a short break and we'll see you on the
other side as we continue our coverage
of our inaugural grandchild story don't
go
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and welcome back to our continued
coverage of round two of the super bed
chess classic in bucharest romania and
uh we're coming back to give you a bit
of a round up of the action on all the
boards starting with
uh yeah there we go
round the horn and here we are we have
the game uh between ali reza and yan
we didn't see the move that we really
expected which was queen e2
in order to just make this escape king d
won king c2 we thought that white would
have been
quite
satisfactory in this case instead the
double-edged move queen b3
invites the move e3 a move that we
really thought was going to be great for
jan i still don't know why it's not
being played here but we we could get
back to that later yell instead go plays
the move h6h5 which is somewhat uh
inconsequential because uh
i mean the apollo g4 is sort of
important but less important than
perhaps opening the central files and
giving mate i would suggest
and uh yeah
there is a goal that we should do
so yeah the very very double-edged
position in which arrested perhaps is
back to being
quite fine this is this fesnick of in
the uh dominguez caruana exactly when we
left it you were explaining that knight
a4 would be fabby's idea and use the
crosstalk
is good yeah and that fabi could be
better
no i i think we've landed on the idea
that quincy two solves all of the
problems and white is definitely not
worse i don't think five is worse but i
think uh linear should be quite
satisfied i think uh he's stabilized
he's just played bishop d3 protecting
the pawn on e4 he's ready to play b
people before next movie he wants to uh
i think black is fine but so is white i
would suspect all right uh continuing
our uh completely crazy game
what can we say about shaq and richie
this has to be the the craziest game of
the round or potentially like with seven
rounds seven rounds to go i think it's a
very easy early front runner for the
craziest game of the tournament exactly
and shakira is finally pausing for quite
a bit here because i think he is still
sort of i think he's sitting there in
disbelief that he is not winning exactly
why but whoa
uh
black's king in the middle of the board
you would just think like you thought
a move like knight f5 just has to be
killing until you see rook five bishop
cd3 and you go oh no that's not the
killing we just seen a move that we
really didn't consider i i was trying to
calculate that when you take c4 rookie
one i'm assuming yeah but i think it
completely gives up any hope of
advantage because simply like i can take
only one here go king g8 king c8 and run
for the hills yeah and i think if if
anyone here has to be careful not to be
worse it's probably white because uh
black has the two rooks against the
queen and the two bishops in a
completely open position right and uh
these types of positions can very easily
become horribly horribly dangerous for
white they feel like i wanted to point
out a couple of moves ago because it is
possible after the move root takes e4
queen takes e4 rookie one blue bish p5
bishop e5 oh dear
oh
dear
are we dead and there's a back rank mate
so don't reach don't be reaching for
black's queen and surprisingly
white is just better after knight c3
that immediately came into my mind i
don't know about you peter but i saw
knights e3 and i thought isn't white
just a little bit better
and finally we do have one last game
remaining and that is uh
we thought it could have been a catalan
but it's not it still is very much like
if you gave me this position and told me
to name the opening i would still say
catalan honestly uh it feels yeah i
think uh in particular because uh for
the last i think at least five moves
when we saw it on our screen uh
bogan is playing on increment basically
his clock currently says 34 seconds
which means he made the move rookie to
d1 with four seconds to spare four
seconds
obviously
yeah
leon obviously is enjoying himself here
because he has no risk whatsoever
anymore but i don't know if this
position if you take time out of
equation and just like give this
position to a computer i think the
computer probably holds it with white
yeah but yeah you're clearly pushing uh
as black as black yeah yeah the the
black rooks have just infiltrated and
moves like rook c3 uh definitely on the
agenda and again how many seconds did he
have seven
seven seconds and like you said for the
last five six moves he's been playing on
the certainly certainly since rook f2 uh
we we had we had the clock on our screen
on move 28 when he played rook f1 f2 he
had eight seconds i mean 38 but he
basically made it with eight seconds but
he is just down a pawn right
it's no huh it's even
yeah but if you take on d1 take on the
one rook b2 how do you d3 and take with
the pawn right
take take
i think that this is a
you want to play e5 or i was thinking e5
yeah e5 might be interesting actually
with the idea of e4 right if if we move
the knight to c6 for instance e4 might
actually be extremely strong winning the
bottom b3 and the game i think and
potentially the game yeah yeah that's uh
so it might actually force white to go
fe-5 and then we lose the h2 pawn but we
might not be losing we might not be
losing that position necessarily right
if we go king of three you take with the
rook i would say
and then well you can also take on d4
right or take on d4 and then on h2 yeah
well he's in trouble he's clearly
and again it's an echo
of their game from the previous year
where
levon did trick
his opponent in an ending and it was a
beautiful trick uh we'll keep our eye on
that one but again i'd like to turn back
to the game of
ali reza for a moment
if i can
and it's this move h5 in particular
i mean to my
thinking when you see this move bishop
f4 it's all about all about going
through yeah and we really want to
ignore it yeah why you why you don't
actually play e3 in this position is
unclear thank you thank you that was
just
i want to i want to ask alejandro about
this because i'm very confused it seems
like this has to be the idea and then
you turn back from it and why why did he
not what could he what could have
dissuaded him
alejandro from
e4 e3 well i guess taking on eve yeah
exactly yeah right yeah
but then what's your follow-up exactly
bishop takes we go king d1 again or a
bishop takes bishop takes e3 yeah bishop
takes on e3 you go king d1 it's the only
way to continue the game you have to run
away obviously going to the kingside
gets yourself made it you must get
yourself made it uh king d1 seems to be
good enough for white uh the idea is
that you're putting the queen on d3
coming as well rookie one is coming the
king's coming to c2 and everything kind
of gels together and yes you gave up the
e-pawn for the f-pawn but the activation
of the rook isn't so crucial you don't
have any penetration squares and the
fact that the king is running away on
the light square so quickly means that
black doesn't have enough compensation
actually the engines do not really like
the move e3 bishop takes e3 so much
actually considering rook takes e3
instead
but before we continue analysis here
let's go to romania as christian has a
very special guest
thank you alejandro well i'm here with a
man that needs absolutely no
introduction the 13th world champion
gary kasparov gary first of all welcome
back to bucharest welcome back to the
studio thank you what are your first
impressions of the tournament the
organization and we first saw you at the
opening ceremony tell us a bit about
that
ah it's so spectacular it's uh i think
that's chess now is back to where it
belongs uh what i played world
championship matches uh
uh it's the level of respect and uh
admiration that
the game has been lacking uh for a long
time i mean we know that's about saint
louis and the standards that have been
introduced by granchester in its place
of origin but you know having the
opening of the granchester of bucharest
in the chaotresco palace
the biggest building in europe and the
second one in the world of the pentagon
it's it's not just luxury it's it's not
just prestige it's just now it's it's um
it's it's for me it was a symbol of
return in chess
like history exactly to to
the mainstream and uh
and uh obviously the
recent tragic events in ukraine just
elevated you know just uh more interest
and uh there are many journalists
obviously i wanted to hear my opinion
about the the tragedy in this in ukraine
but again it's it's all added to to do
do to the tournament to the publicity of
the tournament and by the way i'm very
happy now i can just you know i i can
have the first glance at the games
because it's uh i'm i'm engaged in
never-ending interviews about russia and
ukraine the war and the response of the
free world and it goes on and on uh with
probably every major uh ukrainian tv a
radio station and a newspaper and now
that's a it's a kind of a relief now i
can look at the chess board and talk
about the games that played by the rules
we'll definitely take a look at the
games in just a second but i do want to
ask you also played a time with the kids
at the parliament i made three moves how
important is that for the kids to get
that feeling of playing with the
bachelor's players in history no look
it's it's
it's always about um
happiness and and
a comfort of
the players who are taking part of the
symbols it's not for us to enjoy it
for professionals but it's it's an
opportunity to i mean test yourself
against the best in the world but also
know to um
to get them just a moment of glory
because you make a picture you can shake
hands and uh i
i did first three three rounds you know
shook hands
uh i mean i know it's a bit now risky
these days but still it's as if if you
want an exhibition so forget about
coffee so that's you have to you have to
be engaged that's also i think it's it's
been appreciated and also i have to say
that it's not a cymbal played in in a
cafe or or or in a city square it was
the whole of of of esco palace it says
it's like size of a football field yeah
if not more uh and and being there it's
it's added to the prestige of the game
and
and i think all the players uh there
were kids there and some of the very
famous romanian athletes uh also among
them so they all you know felt that they
were part of history
a lot of this is due to the fact that
the superbad foundation has been getting
involved into the grand chess tour with
a big way tell us a bit about that and
what was the impact of this change look
um it's uh it's the the engagement was a
result of my trip to bucharest
in 2017 i was invited to do a
presentation uh for one of romanian
magazines and
uh one of the sponsors of the event was
sasha druggage the former server chess
player who
stopped playing chess according to
sasha's because he looked at gary caspar
decided he couldn't be as successful and
moved into business yeah and now he's uh
he's you know giving back to chess to
this beloved game and um
we talked about about a possible
cooperation so i invited me next year to
bucharest to do an event with super bad
super but it was just uh
rising as as a big force in in in
romanian business and actually european
business and uh um
and then a
year after that on 2019 it was the first
super bad event uh
rapid and blitz
but i could already sense was the
appetite to do more and it's not just
now the classic tournament in bucharest
super vet is involved and being a major
sponsor in all three eastern european
tournaments in uh as a group and in
warsaw so now we would say that you know
this the um graduate stories is balanced
because we have saint louis or chess
capital
on uh
in the united states and now we have a
company
that's fast fast growing company that is
willing to extend its its
participation in in all sorts of chess
projects from professional to
educational uh
i met here the minister of education of
romania and they're very impressed by
superbet's
uh willingness to
invest heavily in promoting chess in
romanian classrooms so
between saint louis and and superbit
i think uh
grunge's tour has has a safe future and
it's not surprising that feed after so
many years of hesitations and and and uh
waffling decided uh to uh make grudges
to a part of the qualification system so
it's now it's it's solid
and and it has standards
that
yet remain dreams for other chess events
including fido official competitions
absolutely and i know that we will have
you
in future days as well to talk a bit
more about that but we do have some
incredible games today one especially is
this clash between ali reza against jan
nepam nyoshi what is your first take
when you see this position on the board
now we had a quick look you know just
about the game
that
started you know with this very slow uh
um
opening
but i think it's a demonstration that
even if you play like you know the
bishop opening e45 bishop c4 it's about
the mood of the players whether they
want to play tough chess and it seems
that they do
i was surprised just to find out that
many of the um
uh many of the moves that that okay
let's just yeah all the way yeah yeah
yeah yeah oh yeah all the way
all the way to here is so this is this
first it's they they played they played
very fast so that's the that means you
know that wasn't it was opening theory
but then a little played h3 and g3 g4
looked
up odd to me and and i think that
napoleon she missed a couple of really
good really you know uh
good uh opportunities so definitely this
is the move that i didn't like is is
bishop four here so i would definitely
put night my night on the floor and also
i think it was the it was earlier
earlier it wasn't even yeah yeah but he
also here here here with bishop d5 yeah
here knight four also knight of four and
you cannot take only four as we
discussed because bishop d5 i never seen
this and this is the first move that you
mentioned when you saw this yeah but
again this is that's the other night you
know that's yeah maybe goes from i know
just matches corporal you know you could
you want a knight on this one yes
and and uh and again bishop of four i
think that's the um
uh uh um
aliroza did well i'm not sure queen h
you know queen h4
i know that's it's and it seems like
he's losing some speed right black that
is allowing white cast and also i'm not
maybe against this is maybe bishop take
this three was was the only only option
but it's difficult to give but
you just played bishop f4
yeah exactly but after this queen of d1
looks to me that
white is
i wouldn't say winning but it's just
definitely much better queen
play queen e2 then long castle
this i don't see any any real real
compensation so they
so uh gary but still it's it was a lot
of fight it's don't the game game is far
from being over absolutely the last time
we talked was in paris a year ago
alireza was 2750 a huge prospect but he
hasn't confirmed yet at the top level
now he just exploded 28.03
and but he hasn't played in five months
and he's ready to play in his first
candidates how would you assess alireza
as a player as well as his strategy
maybe not to play for five months before
the candidates
look um definitely i'm the last person
to criticize his decision because as a
between disciple so i always wanted you
know serious preparation and uh and
considering the fact that you know
that's the you know he's
he he might be the the
real contender for for the for
uh being an ex challenger uh for the
world championship match um he wanted to
spend more time preparing uh we'll see
you know we'll see how he how how
he does here in this tournament
uh microf5 was just played okay what do
we think of this movement let's tell
again it's just you know he wants to
push the queen and and then just you
know too but after queen h7 i'm not so
sure you know that's the that he has
anything better than to go back
and now given that he has after necklace
five 15 minutes against 19 minutes do
you think he's going to repeat if we see
this on the board
i don't know i'm curious look it's i
think it's don't forget but they will
play in in madrid
the what makes this tournament even more
intriguing you have four players
that will go to madrid so it's alireza
yan uh uh rapport
and fabiano so that's why every game
between them it's just somehow a
rehearsal so yesterday we saw um quite
uneventful game between fabian and and
and alireza so i think fabian had an
advantage but he didn't manage to
actually get something you know a real
out of the suburbs but one interesting
fact about yesterday they repeated the
position four times none of them wanted
to claim the draw maybe it's
psychologically cyclical exactly yeah so
yeah they they they are trying to
position themselves you know for for
madrid
yeah absolutely absolutely so so we're
seeing this is yeah did he play he
played though
wow
you no no no no knight to f5 and right
now nepo is still thinking he's
obviously but he has no i mean real real
options i mean says yes you cannot quin
g5 queen g4 so i guess this is a big
problem yeah and then queen of six and
then you go back yeah yeah
this gives white a clear advantage now
another crazy game uh is this one
between mamedyarov and richie report
now the position has calm down come down
come down this is calm down compared to
what we have yeah exactly what is this
is the call come down
yeah i'm curious you don't say this is
the
way to go i see this computer office
bishop takes places and bishop divorce
yeah bishop
yes
yeah and the idea is to go but that
since then whatever you want who do you
want okay but there's two rooks you know
that should be yeah but but again i just
think what's happening here so and then
there's this look and look at the three
h4 shape
and i wish that sticks only move
it as good maybe yeah it seems
everything it's like uh some sort of
variation
yeah but this is because you just before
and then you double
wow
wow nice now because bishop is seven
it's it's the straight kick will be five
twenty five bishop d6 yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah but we'll see so it's this is how
much time left so 19 minutes for uh
richie and twelve minutes for mamedyaro
it's not the only move it seems like
just going backwards
now you have to go see it
let's see if he sees bishop h3 big
moment right now for uh luigi i bet he
would you think he i think he'll play
bishop takes history so it's the uh okay
that's uh and this is another extremely
intriguing uh player ritual report what
is your assessment of him he plays
non-stop he says i don't have any
support i'm just going to continue
playing and do my best at the candidates
look he will that's that's
that's a problematic problematic
attitude because you don't want to go to
candidates and to do to do your best
right you go there to win right or you
know just otherwise you can have fun
but you know it's i i i'm sure that uh
other is attitude or fabi or even young
they have a very different idea or
or young christian duda so who by the
way refused to to to play in in uh um in
granches tour just yeah
exactly more time to prepare so
again as someone you know who just
learned from pavwinik i i appreciate
this this attitude so it's a risky one
but but you know it may work you'd like
to take time for a preparation yeah it's
this is uh especially these days you
know when they see you can do a lot of
exercise playing you know just on online
but well that's
we have you know we can definitely see
the different approaches magnus
i think it's it's it's very
it's it's quite unique strategy for each
player because it's very individual you
know yes something that worked for me
more for carpool all the way around so
that you have to understand you know
this what what's
what does work for you and uh
we'll see whether it's and and and and
and young christian though this is they
they made the right right calls knowing
yourself is uh definitely a huge
superpower now what about this game the
all-american clash
how do we how do we see this one
developing
i don't know it's just
looks to me that it's it's it's
it's evil yeah probably is to just start
you know doubling
on d file but but he just you know
a bit of pressure for white but not much
a little bit fresher but i
doubt that is anything serious
so
maybe you could
i don't know just like rook f1 would be
one then somehow player four at one
point you probably have to play four if
you want to achieve anything but
i'm i'm
very skeptical about any real chances
for this one i would say it's from the
draw gary
and we have we do have this last game uh
the one in which actually
my last move this move knight to e2 was
made with two seconds on the clock
but it's amazing you see this
we look at this position it's just you
know why
yeah the one had to take take here and
play with b2 there was a much better
chance yeah much better chance take on
d1 b2 and then after rook d3 there's e5
yeah that's very strange at level you
know missed this chance and levon at
this point had 53 minutes on the clock
c5 i guess he kept no more pieces but
you know but you see this is h4 now he's
just actually after e5 he could take
only five because the pawn is no longer
here and it's everything is now
protected yes so you see this is yeah
yeah that's amazing you stabilize
exactly
absolutely
or maybe the advantage has slipped away
from uh absolutely yes from
this one exactly very strange again
but
sometimes you look at the opponent's
clock instead of looking at the position
and i think this is exactly what he did
he played that move rook to c5 with two
only two minutes he spent on that gary
thank you very much for joining us and
we'll see you in the next few days i go
back to to
to the main main main stage talking
about about geopolitics which is again
it's uh it's not ruled by uh
by people who respect the rules
absolutely thank you very much gary
appreciate it
guys back to you thank you christian and
uh thank you gary uh a lot of
developments taking place alejandro what
caught your attention during that
discussion that uh
they had the alley reads again i think
both the mama diary game and this game
by ali reza are really catching our
attention uh nepal has just played the
move rook a6 i was about to mention that
there are two serious possibilities here
go e3 directly but
this man has refused to push the pawn on
e4 to e3 for the last i don't know how
many moves i don't know why he would do
it now and he says yes i can go one more
move without touching that pawn he
actually puts a rook on a6 i imagine
it's going to go to f6 start pressuring
make it feel uncomfortable notice the
white long castle which i'm sure he
would love to do uh
the engines come up with two completely
different ideas the solid knight e3 now
that this queen was pushed back to the
h7 square preparing long castle at some
point giving white a pretty clear
advantage remember that white is up a
pawn
in this position or just going with the
move h4 saying let's go i can also have
my own play h5 will be an idea at some
point it doesn't actually threaten the
knight remember that the h1 rook is
undefended but in many variations i can
try to make this work tactically and h5
will be scary for black because the
knight on g6 is currently the only
difference so
it's an elimination of defense and
attack because you're also taking away
the 96 h4 ideas that's also true from
black so you're you're combining gaining
some space and perhaps pushing h5 with
just depriving black of one of the more
important
uh
proactive ideas that they have
yeah uh it's still very complex and
alireza down to 13 minutes nepal with 15
two players that are not often seen in
time pressure but finally getting down
to the last you know minutes considering
they still have 11 moves to make in a
very complex position so i wouldn't
doubt that time pressure is going to be
a factor here as it is going to be it
seemed like it was going to be a factor
for
bok dundak but he survived the worst of
it and as gary was pointing out uh we
also pointed it out in our broadcast
this move of taking on c1 rook b2 seem
to put a ton of pressure on white and
currently it seems that perhaps white
has solved all of his major issues you
can see the black is actively placed but
this rooks they're not really playing
together they only have one target in
common which is this pawn on g4 and if
you attack it immediately with the move
rook h4 uh i was thinking rook g1 was
enough because h5 is defended yes i'm
correct rook g1 is enough to hold on to
the position there's no actual problems
here um you can get counter play against
something like bishop e5 trying to
harass these pawns with simply check and
rookie or rook f8 start targeting black
spawns as well i feel that black's
position is optically a lot nicer than
it actually is i don't think that he has
any real threats and if there was any
hope for an advantage i think it's gone
now the deck has gone in that extra half
an hour and let me see if we have any
updates on the richard game no he's
actually burning his clock here of
course this seems like a situation where
you should burn your clock as it moves
bishop d7 and bishop h3 the engine of
proofs of both are completely different
styles thank you for that alejandro and
again this game uh defies
our analysis
but when you look at this position you
say to yourself that
both bishop takes h3 and bishop d7 are
engine approved that's crazy but bishop
takes h3 uh
gary mentioned it on air uh and yeah one
one thing i wanted to point out is
please uh something that is probably
shouldn't be surprising and i don't know
if it is surprising to anyone but just
sort of how how sharp and how on point
gary gary still is even though he's only
really i think he said in the interview
that he hasn't really looked at the
games pretty much until they started
talking to christian right and yeah he
spoke he's still a very very on point
and very much worth listening to uh
you know regarding anything chess
related
uh basically
uh but i don't quite understand like i
know this works because i have also
while we were on a break listening to
gary i checked and the machine does
suggest this is fine but for me like the
biggest question is why can't i go queen
d1 here
for instance like i assume because of
the pin the idea is actually the player
g1 check here
but why is this equal
that is that is the sort of the big
hurdle for me like why why why am i not
better here with white
king
yeah i think the solution is rook f4
knight i think should probably go back
to g2 and not to
g6 um
disputable but okay
it doesn't matter you'll lose h3 anyway
yeah rook f3 i mean i can play h4 here
why am i losing this pawn
and also why am i not better here i am i
understand my knights are very passive
and knights are not what i want to have
against the rook but why
like how i understand that you don't
lose these positions
necessarily but to be absolutely certain
that you are not even worse
i think
requires a superhuman effort of uh can i
be forcing is the key yeah like knight
b2 knight c5 rookie three i understand
let's go knight b2 rookie three knight
e1
and then like
h3 yeah yeah that's my
drawing attempt okay yeah yeah that is
funny but i i think it is a very very
difficult uh first of all just coming up
with the idea bishop h3 because it
doesn't really look like you're
launching any kind of a mating attack
really in this position it's just
some perpetual checks yeah uh first of
all just coming up with this and
secondly correctly evaluating queen g1
and also some of the lines that gary was
showing on air after 92 rook f3 yes are
just
mind-blowing for those of you who may
not have seen it that particular one
line can you remember 92 rook of three
yes queen h4 czech
uh bishop of six and this is hilarious
yeah and
straight up loses to rook f1 check king
h2 and now one of the more beautiful
moves i've seen in a long long time
bishop e7 in order to meet queen d5
check with bishop six counter check
killing your rook and then as i'm
reaching for the rook you say by the way
check yeah we can continue actually
neither four oh we go rook takes a four
right for style points oh yes queen
takes g8 check check no we who we've
been here before check check bishop 7 is
so beautiful it's too bad it's not the
only winning move but yeah but still but
it's so nice style points important
important you're telling me bishop e7 it
there's another winning rule
looks crushing ruby five also looks very
strong
sad
easier simpler bishop
i mean i've i've been picking up my jaw
off the floor for this entire game this
is a great game it's just it's just so
good
this is what it's just great amazing
like how how do you even come up with
these questions like how i don't
understand big shout out to our
colleagues
bucharest anastasia
it's been amazing and if it's not enough
excitement guys we've been taking on h3
and analyzing all these lines but it's
you're not forced to do so but doesn't
actually have a threat
right i mean is it time that we could
play move like nights
certainly a move that you can play in
this position maybe we should analyze it
without the engine because i don't want
to think about it
no he said i'm going to take your bishop
he's already taken yeah yeah bishop
takes uh here there's only one move for
black this one this part is clear
bishop d4 is here and also i want to
point out that i think the one reason i
can
find for bishop xh3 is if you go bishop
d7 i think you're supposed to after
knight c5 to just allow white like you
go king c8 here 97 and i guess you take
on d7 right and white goes knight f3
and yes you suspect you will hold but
this knight on the three does such a
good job of securing the king's side
maybe you chop it off right before you
go you could but it does lose you the h5
pawn as well like 97 which plagues h4 is
is a move you can make but after queen
h4 king d7 queen h5 you are down two
down while you're completely safe there
in fact white probably needs to be
careful but when you're down both of
them and you can't really go rook a
fanbook of two yet because your king is
not secure right
you're you're not a hundred percent sure
yeah you're not sure at all right so i
think uh if if not for the fact that
white is in time there to completely
stabilize probably richard would have
played bishop d7 but but you can't keep
the bishop pair of uh alive
uh but
having said all that i am still
honestly just in absolute awe of him
coming up with this
over the board
so well also
when you go back earlier in the game in
this idea that this king on e7
was safe
was also like i was
just tasered i mean like how could the
king be safe i mean it just
felt so so wrong
now again we're looking at this rook g1
move rook g-1 threat i should say and
nigey ii seems sensible but
we have issues yeah you know rook f3 is
coming and you start calculating and you
realize it doesn't it doesn't actually
work
out calculating and realize you have 10
minutes left also
you also have that that issue
uh could i just ask
ridiculous questions i think i think
like if you if you want to force the g
one check you're probably better off
going quinty one because i think here
same position i go g1 check let's say i
don't know if he's scores and but in the
same position your opponency three will
actually be hanging right i will go look
after look at four rook of three
look ah i'll go look at four rook f3 and
then b5 will be a major major threat
because balance e3 is the target
i i would actually prefer
engine lights guys engine lights okay
don't go knight g2
knight c5
what and then king jitu knight three
king g3 jesus
uh
oh just king g3 straight away we don't
need to prepare it yeah
this is like some steady
where rook is trapped on the fifth rank
and of course this is a domination and
this is a draw there's a draw
zero zero zero zero draw yes b6
king g3 group takes h3
i guess yeah
oh oh i know
yeah but that's what i'm here for
wow
crazy alert crazy alert
c3 yeah so if i hadn't recommended it
also i have a feeling c3 might be
playable but that's a whole other story
but uh
sorry
where where
it was like don't play knight g2 play uh
here
this is what i had in mind not trying to
get into this ending this this has to be
a tropical group c3 knight a65 or
something it has to be true
um
why is this worse according to the
engine yeah
i think it ends up being a draw i was
trying to cut i was trying to collect
the h-pawn and the yeah
[Music]
you got to be careful right yeah agreed
all around what a
what a crazy it's a crazy game but
there's so many possibilities for what
you have queen d1 you have knight g2 you
have c3
all of them playable moves
and
they all end up in zeros that's cr it's
absolutely crazy
yeah it absolutely forces the
continuation
yeah and we'll get into that end game
which
yeah the engines think is just about as
good as any other zero zero uh black
should be perfectly fine
in this one i remember they had played
this incredibly
ridiculously complicated game at the
sinkfield cup
and
shaq has won the game
and there were some
like
double exclamation mark moves in the
position of some
wild tactical melee
and uh shaq was being interviewed and he
said well i saw this variation
which he had calculated exactly what we
had seen and we were just like
astounding i'm disgusting like 94 right
yeah yeah yeah right remember that we
were just like
how do you even come up
with this
like nobody's tapping you on the
shoulder and saying right here is an
unbelievable combination by the way the
knight g2 was played rather
quick oh this is not the line this is
one of the lines c3 sorry so knight g2
is played very quickly we're expecting
three yeah he'll go rook off
he'll go rook f3 with the weird thing
that the computer thinks any move that
doesn't blunder the rook on the f file
is zero zero
yeah this is the the dominance of a rook
over the two knights and on an empty on
an empty board it's so i can sort of
understand why that would be but
still still a remarkable remarkable
piece of sort of trust in your
understanding there by by richie because
at this end by two minor pieces yeah
purely by numbers purely by numbers
you're like down a pawn and a half here
with black but right he understands just
how strong the rook is on a completely
empty board and i think that's one of
the more difficult concepts to explain
to beginners is that a knight and a
bishop are so much better than a rook
and it's a difficult concept i felt to
explain to players above 2000 that a
rook in an end game is just
very often so much better than two
pieces very very often but it has to be
an end game it has to have certain uh
positions with pawns on both flanks
there has to be certain uh
things on the board for that to happen
but it is often that uh i've seen a lot
of players 2000 to like low i am high i
am that severely overestimate the
two-piece advantage over the work yeah
by the way in the game between diac and
levon
white has saved himself well i mean he
will push a bit actually because the
king on h7 is not very safe but i'm
pretty sure it's a draw but he will he
will actually push a little bit here
he'll
play king somewhere and then play g5
and it will be a bit annoying for levon
but really king right here
g5 i think in this particular position
there is a specific way to make a draw
straight away by playing rook b1 takes
h6 rook h1 check and you can't actually
cross the f file without trading rooks
and there's still a pawn on before so i
think this is just a dre i go rookie one
check here
and you can't go to the f file because
rook fan check picks up the rook
and i have those checks from behind
forever right and if you go like king
[ __ ] g4 the one try here is
king g4
uh rook f1 i mean by try i mean it loses
but you can play king king of five rook
f1 king e6
hoping for takes takes ghg6 and mate but
black actually has g7 g6 there kind of a
cold shower move and the b-pawn queens
that hurts your feelings does it hurts a
little bit yeah
but it's an important calculation to to
make and alejandro what's happening and
uh our marquee match we've got to keep
an eye on this one of course alireza
against nepal we've had a couple of
moves rook a6 the one with the last one
we saw we lacked the move h4 we liked
bringing the knight back to e3 already
said this king needs to start running we
have been considering this idea for
quite a while they just don't think this
was the right time to do it but i don't
care about the edges think rook f6 was
played and we know this idea to
destabilize the knight on f5 rookie one
on the board this rook is finally active
and this kg move knight f8 we saw this
earlier in the game but the knight is
now on a fade again now the idea is
simple the knight on f5 doesn't have a
good way to be defended you don't have
knight d6 because black is protecting
that square so the knight returns and
the engines actually loved the move
bishop h6 keeping the pressure on the e3
knight instead the bishop has returned
to b8 there's still a threat on f2 the
position is chaotic
alireza six minutes for the next eight
moves nepo 11 minutes so certainly time
pressure here for both players there's
tons of possibilities this rook is
taking on f2 it also might jump to the
f3 square and
try to capture h3 white is up a pawn but
that's a pretty pretty much the only
advantage he has in the position the
knight on b5 is very pretty but it's not
participating with the rest of the
pieces for the time being of course this
is a protected pass pawn at some point
but we're fired for an end from an end
game tons to play for i think it's a
three years old game i'm excited for
this one absolutely no question about it
and
we know uh ali reza's uh
uh clock is a factor how about ian
yen is 11 minutes 11 minutes yeah and in
the meantime i think the the
rapport game will end in a in a
repetition that we pointed out earlier
the 9192 repetition we are seeing it on
the board and uh richard actually quite
remarkably didn't even play b5 he played
b6 restricting the knight on a4 and
still repeating the same moves so yeah
this game will be over in uh yeah he is
clearly calling for an arbiter but yeah
by the way i mean seriously i mean
applause applause
there's definitely there's straws and
there's draws and this one is
amazing this is amazing yeah truly uh if
you're if you love the game of chess
you're gonna love replaying through this
game and just
scratching your head and saying
how did he survive yeah this is a
stunning stunning game of chess very
very nicely played even if there were
perhaps some some mistakes
honestly from what alejandro said uh
apart from maybe a slightly dodgy
opening no mistakes uh like
pretty much perfectly played game yeah
as much as as much as you can so as
close as you can get to a perfectly
played game considering how messy bishop
g4 all of these moves and e4 f5 f4 oh my
god i remember there was there was at
some point there was a website which
tracked
the uh
the percentages of sort of the the
uh
how close you get to a perfectly played
game and you could also check yeah
accuracy percentages and you could also
check what your
best games were
and i think magnus was at about like 97
98 or somewhere around there and
obviously you want to compare yourself
to the best so i checked mine mine was
like i think maybe in the low 90s or
maybe a high 80s or whatever respect and
uh
and there was one game of mine which was
like 99 and i thought i'm i'm a good
player occasionally and it was a 20-move
draw against venetian norway chess where
basically we got out of the opening and
repeated
nicely done well done yeah
and he's just
he's just hitting his percentage mark
yeah he's trying to bring it up and
that's
and i get the feeling that they got
close to that mark in this game with
like
five pieces hanging on every move wow uh
and yeah this is remarkable this is
truly remarkable yeah just just a crazy
crazy game
and uh alejandro uh nice tie i was just
asking uh
you're doing an eye test
on ourselves i got my lasik surgery this
is just another advertiser for
qboutiquestl.com you like this time
support the chess club qboutiquestl.com
you can find all of this merchandise and
much more make you look good during
chess commentary
yeah that's so important uh that's what
i i'm i'm figuring
um a game also that uh is leaving us
befuddled
is the uh
nepo
game what is going on
after we left it first of all the move
bishop h6 i mean every everything about
this game has been fascinating but weird
yeah including the last move queen h4
i know krish 4 is logical we attack the
pawn on f2 we provoke something that
perhaps white doesn't want to do it and
you don't clip the pawn
no you don't want to open files for for
your opponent like you take on h3 white
goes king c2 then rook h1 and starts
perhaps some kind of counterplay along
the h5 you don't take a pawn you just
said that yeah
i thought you were supposed to uh
grab while the gravity was good
could i play knight g4
rook f4 and then f5 and rook f4 and then
f5 i want to take on f2 i'm very i'm
very open to the idea of taking the f2
okay
i care i care about less and i wanted to
say you know on the subject of alejandro
stein eye tests oh please i think i test
you take black here
i think by this point i i think it's
impossible to take white but you take it
back here despite being upon down like
the rook lands on f3 i go knight g6
knight to fall back landed on d3 after
all that time it actually finally lands
on d3
maybe
and it's only one pawn
yet again it's so it's not a lot of
material yeah rook f1 played by lyresa
as we expected
when you told me that d3 was weak
earlier and the knight was going to jump
to f4 into d3 i believe that one you
don't if you tell me the rook on a8
what's gonna land on the d3 square i
don't know i believe that so easily but
it does seem like colorist is in a lot
of pressure here he's played the mover
kf1 which is much better than the move
knight g4 according to the engine but is
defending the f2 pawn yes and instantly
nepo play the move rook f3 which is
incredibly logical right sloping queen
g4 is important it stops queen g4 it
prepares the moves uh bishop f4 even 96
knight f4 also hitting the queen so i
expect this game to start c two you
start running right you can't see
there's only one forever well
but white has a trump uh uh pass pawn on
the d file and you go king c2
and this one has finished we did expect
this one to fizzle into a draw and
indeed it has uh two draws for both
players to begin the tournament
all righty uh yeah i was going to go
king c to rook d1 and track still has
been played yeah but we have an
interview uh christian
kirilla will be uh talking to
shakhtaryama tariff
thank you peter yes i'm uh with the
winner of last year's superbad
undefeated winner in that tournament
shaq
shaq first of all welcome back to
bucharest this is a place that he always
said you love to play in tell us a bit
about that in your experience in the
first couple of days here in bucharest
of course as i like is to win bucharest
to play here because i like bucharest
like city and
i mean good restaurants good
time in bucharest for this reason okay i
like to be here but my tournaments start
not very well
i think yesterday it was very strange
game but more strangers today
absolutely looks
winning position we were completely
puzzled about this game from the
beginning to the end and i was looking
at the position somewhere around when
the king was on e7 and i said that black
has to be lost at least visually no but
it's okay i mean king is seven years
looks very strange because okay normally
i never play e4 in classical chess for
this reason uh
richard i think he wants
some surprise
opening to play but
i think after a few moves
absolutely and also i played very
strange move i mean is i play very fast
but i don't understand
i played very fast castle but if i take
f60 e take f6 is not
gta f6 knight e5 i don't know 95 wow
yeah i don't understand if i take
it it's not losing no it can be several
this one it just looks worse i mean why
i play immediately castle but after ice
is 95 is like made you know so now i
guess the idea is
winning yeah i mean somewhere is winning
position but uh i played very fast
castle is normal move but after the
castle i said why not just take knight
e5 i mean i want to play after bishop d7
take 95 ideas absolutely winning because
king in the in after castle but he's
also look very nice so the idea being
once you go bishop e7 you just simply
take on it i mean uh okay i played very
fast castle end of the okay this looks
losing position nice because
94 maybe knight f6 i think is for
engines made i don't know maybe not but
it's for humans upset uh it looks how to
play move i mean no moves now i play
very fast behavior strange i mean of
course it's very strange but yeah
i miss okay after knight hwy h5 okay i
was very happy with my position
because
everything looks very strange
p3 okay
for engine is not good but for humans
bishop e3 rookie one i don't know i i
like i was very happy with my move b3
but after e5 i mean every movie looks
normal
bishop g4 queen g3 and looks it how is
it
it looks
[Music]
but it does seem to be like the the best
movie yeah i mean okay i understand
you need to play some moves but i think
he played just moves because he need to
play music not best moves i mean
and here okay take take rook
i mean it's very strange i mean okay now
i was not very very happy because uh
two bishops every time big problem
uh but
it looks again not easy to play and here
absolutely for e4 i don't know the if
three five but no i know if there is
take yeah sorry if there is take is
knight a4
knight a4 because i i don't see his move
f5 of course i missed this f5
i think if not uh
this was a variation that alejandro was
looking at with the engine of course
with the engine as approval and he said
that there's no way they're going to go
into this line there's no way richard is
going to pay for i also miss i mean the
research okay
we know he'll like to calculate
everything that is this is very strange
you know i mean this king in center and
i don't lose any material and he just to
play queen d2 and here of course is i i
don't understand take take 95 i think
his first winning
this
again is very tricky is because his
bishop's three move his only move i mean
he looks upset losing with bishop c3 and
now yeah i think he's no mate no mate
because it's just
yes
i think it's good attack that is not
attacking
okay i just calculate king f7 and after
this thing is no attack
that means very strange and also uh why
i play this move after
take
take
uh
i think it's the best move here knight
f3 i mean this looks not knight f3 but i
understand if i will play knight f3 i
can lose easily in this position because
uh of course if i played some um
i don't know as i understand that if
there is very tricky move very
interesting move but i understand i can
also lose it because the three results
yeah and now it's absolutely
looks good okay b6 is absolutely
and how are you where are you one time
at this point who was uh 26 minutes for
a year and 33 minutes for him
understandable that i was i was really
lucky because i take after you see
rookie one i i see here bishop v5 move i
missed this before if you only might see
triple
if i play rookie
okay i lose i mean i don't i missed
bishop v5 first and here is
what's this a bit was still good movie
take taking just kink
maybe it's
better for black yeah maybe some good
chance for play with black i miss
absolutely yeah bishop e5 of course
you should
yeah h3 bishop d7 is the
two rooks still notice i mean
i can lose my control after all these
moves because it was very good position
now okay i need to defense this
king is very strange of course very
strange
moves and after h3 bishop
knight http and now you're starting to
get some control right i calculate this
one knight c5 and i think it's okay me
mommy's draw is
okay i can try to do something here
but
we should be h3 be sure which three is
i think
i need
i need to
think about very serious to continue to
play chess my career or not because
every move guy it was a surprise for me
i mean every this is how it's possible
to play just like this quindy once again
it looks two nights
but after okay four maybe not just sixth
maybe 96 now zero f6 the minimum yeah
it's 95
i just maybe you're gonna see some
points yeah no no as if i ever lose one
pawn is losing position
i mean yeah okay knight g2 and rook f3
okay here is the
of course
i was very happy for draw because no
move here i mean
i just need to play knight b2 for black
is also same no move it might be two
knight devices i mean it's very easy of
course it is a winning position i mean
maybe it's 95 take if 695 is winning
i see you very uh puzzled by his style
of only calculating that's what you said
you said something very interesting if
he likes to play like this only to
calculate why why did you say that
i mean
i mean
we all know the richard is
i mean
is very good in
calculate to move lines but i also like
to calculate but uh
i mean
line like this f4
means looks i mean if you calculate
everything again it looks very
bad position and i think is very close
to win but
now i'm very happy to see it was not
winning position but but i think is his
key moment in the game it's just his
winning movie i think is take take 95
i mean here is take ninety-five
practically humans for humans is king in
centuries i mean
i don't know for maybe foreign is a
good chance to save but for humans is
made i think after this crazy game do
you feel like uh you're back in shape
you regain let's say uh
the right play i mean it was a big
problem yesterday uh i think i played
normal game and i think all my old times
i have some normal position but after
the game i check same yeah i i check my
game and i see from the opening is
losing position for me but i was very
happy the board i think is okay it looks
very good everything is
i mean my pawns is good but after the
game i check it was all game i have bad
possession but it's like today today i
think the all game is a winning position
but it was not winning yesterday i think
i have all game was a good position it
was losing position every day i improve
in this tournament okay i i will say oh
i will play but okay
it looks like it will be not
like last year but
we have more
seven games shaq always entertaining
keep the energy up and we'll see you in
the next few rounds thank you thank you
thanks guys back to you guys
that was a great interview
we owe shaq a great apology because we
were just laughing we were giggling
because he he was just like
expressing every uh
amount of confusion that we expressed
like how could i not be winning i'm
winning i'm winning i'm not winning
exactly it was brilliant it was great i
mean he is a fantastic player he saw a
ton of things and and richard as well
they both saw very very unobvious things
during the game but yeah
for for somebody who plays this game
from from the white side yeah the
feeling of bewilderment
that you're not winning right i was i
was talking about it on air that he must
be sitting there thinking how am i
failing to calculate this very very
simple
simple problem why why haven't i found
the forest wind in three moves just yet
and also said the good news that after
the game he would come and discover that
there wasn't a win and also we were
apparently like
three seconds away from him actually
playing efgf 95 which is right which i
was uh
not so
engaging necessarily but your take on
that interview it was just hilarious
because we're not laughing at shaq let's
be very very clear it was like we were
laughing with
chess players all of that pain right you
have this position that logically is
winning
but it's not and it's very frustrating
and there's a certain sense of relief
when the engine tells you you know what
you weren't winning you you did your
best just just chill this is the best
you could do and you did it all right so
what what else can you do right and i
think that shaq is going to be a
slightly relief that he didn't just
straight up miss a win right i think he
would really be frustrated if he found
himself thinking this is a winning
position that logically has to be
winning and the win was available and he
just missed it but this gives him high
hopes in the tournament let's go to the
game of alareza and nepo because they
are in severe time pressure alerts are
down in a minute and thirty pounds
on a minute declines are basically a
draw for it with this move what he could
have played 95 back instead of 91 pretty
much forcing uh jan to repeat
but he is just not interested
yup that's up that's pretty interesting
he actually plays him 91 perhaps he
thinks his position is better
i'm not so sure yeah i've i wonder why
he thinks he is the one who should be
continuing yeah because the engine just
wants to take on h3 yeah knight of three
is now more than yeah more than taking
the pawn which i'm sure yasser loves
i'd have three
and knight takes e1 well the rook's
trapped right it's not so easy to defend
against this threat uh alireza with a
130 to think about it because i have
trouble believing that you don't play
rook h3 in this position the second best
move is to move the rook somewhere else
and play with the idea of knight f3 next
move notice that nepo has put his knight
on g5 i'm assuming it's to invade on f3
at some point not just to defend upon e4
so rook h3 kind of jumps at me
nepo with three minutes and 20 laressa
with one minute and 30 nepal two moves
to make colors adjust one uh so not
severe time pressure but still important
decisions in the next couple of moves
talking about severe time pressure
may i mentioned our good friend lanier
yeah
tends to be he tends to be in time
travel and he also has a body posture of
somebody
uh entire four moves to go he's going to
get his 30 second instruments but he's
underneath 10 seconds as i'm speaking
yeah but i think he has a safe position
but he just needs to make him three
yeah
and he's very very unhurried you like
this kind of you know very relaxed
posture as you make your move on two
seconds there like you he knows he's
gonna make it uh
i remember a certain jeffrey jean
who in a very leisurely way pressed the
clock with one second and flagged
against
but let's go back to bucharest and uh
christian with levon aronia
thank you yasser yes we are indeed with
lavon arunian lev first of all welcome
back to bucharest one of your favorite
places you always say that tell us a bit
about your experience with the opening
ceremony as well as the first couple of
games yesterday a draw but quite a
difficult one quite an explosive one
uh yeah i mean so far it's quite
interesting uh i
i mean we visited the parliament house
it was an impressive building very
interesting
uh
games wise i think
i'm uh slowly adjusting you know the jet
lag is
is an issue here
slight issue of course
but we always fight ex excuses you know
it's just players that's just players of
course yeah yeah we don't miss move uh
we forget moves
tell us a bit about this game uh because
i saw you quite disappointed you entered
the studio and you said you had a big
pressure on your opponent at least
that's what you felt tell us a bit about
that yeah well this opening is
extremely solid but black has to play
very precisely you know in all these
lines same with vienna
when you were taking on c4 without white
having to commit playing a move
uh normally holds because of tactical
reasons right otherwise uh of course
it's not very advisable to surrender the
center and
not gain a tempo out of it right
but i knew this line um
i analyzed it to beat this i think this
bishop before moves exactly it's very
precise
the point is that if you place queen e2
and i put the bishop on a3
so and then queen to e7 i think this is
uh yeah it's very close to equality i
think this is a good idea i'll bring the
bishop to g6 and fortify my king yes
and this was the move that everybody in
the studio was also praising because you
played it so fast and you signal that
you've analyzed this at home yeah yeah i
think
i've analyzed more uh coins coming in
the client than anything
for the last i think a year or something
once it gained popularity thanks to
fabiano that's uh that's a huge
information you're revealing thank you
okay so after knight to g5 you guys
entered this end game he was playing
quite aggressive with f4 trying to
normally trying to open up with f5 and
create something yeah i thought this
bishop d7 is was the move because uh i
remembered this line was
it's very interesting so knight f3 wait
so you still remember something at this
point uh one thing you need to know
about me
when i say i remember quite often i have
a better view oh okay
yeah i thought i remembered so i thought
that when i take here 95 q5
and if knight c6 then i have this bishop
of the sixth castle we should be seven
c5 it's it's the best is the best move
yeah so so probably i remembered it and
then black is out of any danger and
towards the end just to go to the
critical move because uh games are
winding down as we speak after king to
g3 uh we were discussing with gary in
the studio disrupted d1 but you nicely
made the point that you thought this
position was not weird i mean even when
white goes to rook d3 bishop d4 well
actually you don't have to go and this
was the the critical move e5 i5 but what
if it takes now the opponent h2 is is
not so sure is that king king f3
yes
oh
okay and we get this type of yeah i mean
uh this type of positions there is
always a lot of counter play for white
yeah with this knight but still not as
easy uh and no no in fact the reason why
i played it i wanted to play g6 which i
thought was extremely unpleasant in time
trouble
and then i just
after i played it i mean after i went
rook c5 because h4 is only natural i
only hear i noticed that 96 uh
is is a possibility and this is just a
crazy move because once you cover up on
g7 the simple route to e7
followed by rook to d7 doubling up and
there's no way to stop it yeah yeah it's
pretty crazy but do you think he saw
do you think he's honestly i'm sure
you know he would see that
so then i kind of started
you know trying to catch a fish in the
muddy water
but yeah i
i knew that i always have this bishop
before so i was not
too concerned but
obviously after h5 the position is
yeah i mean it's watering down lavon
thank you very much for uh joining us
keep the energy up and we'll see you in
the next few rounds perfect guys back to
you thank you christian thank you lavon
big developments taking place in both of
our remaining games in both
but most especially we've been focused
on the ali riza game uh we think
jan is in control yeah jan is better the
question is how much because uh as you
will uh see in this group
after 91 yan preferred the second best
move according to what alejandra was
telling us instead of rook h3 he did
play rook f3 f4
and uh alireza who was very short on
time it's actually difficult to make a
good move in this position i think he
played queen e3 which looks logical but
after knight f3 the rules yeah you
realize you realize rookie ii doesn't
actually save any material it loses more
material the queen takes h3 and weirdly
the rook on f1 is completely completely
indefensible exactly so he will have to
after night of three play something like
knight bc3 we suspect because the
opponent e4 needs to be attacked exactly
and uh jana think doesn't even have to
commit tonight take c1 i think the rook
is not really running anywhere so i
think you can maybe even wait for a move
with something if you find something
smart to do here maybe like you feel
that bishop a7 is a good inclusion for
instance but is it i'm not sure i don't
know why we're provoking c5 yeah it's
something i might want to do yeah
absolutely uh but
you have the option you have the option
of considering whether you have the
luxury the rook's not running anyway as
you say yeah and obviously you can take
on e1 white will take with the rook and
uh in that position you you have to
somehow solve the issue of the dual
threat of 95 and knight takes e4 we were
discussing rook takes f2 here which is
not illogical but i don't know if it's
the best move in the position i suspect
it isn't specifically because the rooks
come off after rookies yeah if you could
if you could have this position with
your pawn on f5 it's a totally different
ball game but you were just disappointed
that the move rookie two raquito forces
the rooks off i i think i still prefer
black here after a five in this position
but yeah queen and queen and knight is
very well known for for being dangerous
and tricky and yeah the c and d pawns
will also run
so yeah this is
it looks fine for black but there should
be more right you you you get the
feeling there must be more from the
starting position with the trapped
exchange
you don't want to go into a position
that's murky and before we actually ask
for for our expert to tell us what that
more is there's also the second game uh
in which linear is now i think
significantly better against fabi
um we have left it just about here we
saw him play age four
and uh
found nothing better than to accept all
of these trades and now move 40 is
reached and i think whatever linear
plays here here is better the move i
like the most is rook before but i don't
know if it's the strongest one it's just
the one that appeals to me the most
because i think it really it asks for it
it asks the most questions but you can
take only four you can also just go like
i don't know rook d7 king of two and say
my dominance is south the dark squares
is great the dark squares and the one
open file on the board and so on and
black has zero count to play right white
i think is better even there yeah but
the the
split between rook takes e4 and rook
before is what interests me the most
yeah i i find myself drawn to the move
rook before as well
i mean that is certainly the linchpin of
the position you can have even a triple
e pawn if you like oh put a pawn on e6
and we'll both be happy yeah the
question is can we maybe save the end
game of the bishop c4
uh-huh inviting uh
a clean rook ending but this yeah even
king of two here maybe is not stupid
apart from brook takes c4 which is also
a very decent movie
i want to play rook g8 here my idea here
is to play rook g8
scooping up a lot of pawns
yeah
really yeah
rook b2 and hope that i end up defending
some three against two
which i probably do hold right
question mark question
i'm not sure i i'll definitely take
white's uh
yeah yeah i'll just take blessing
yeah i'm just saying that maybe we hold
um but yeah this is the extent of how
desperate i am with fabi's position
exactly if you if you give up the pawn
on b5 for nothing i think you lose if
you play rook b8 here
at the very least at the very least i
can go rook takes e4 and win the full
tempo because e5 is not so useful yes uh
i also have c3 c4 which might quite
easily be winning yeah that's i think
the real problem and finally king f2 all
of which leads us to think that lanier
has a really huge advantage let's jump
back
uh
did they make at time control and
should play d4g5 instead of knight c3
which is also like a movie he will at
some point need to make because he needs
to start creating his own trump so he
wants to play c5 d6 and just create a
passer absolutely
a significant passer on the g-file but
have they made time no
yeah it doesn't move 45 or 41. i see it
on my screen now d5 so
with the uh time control being made both
players will get that extra 30 minutes
very very different
uh tournament we're calling then the
american cup alejandro where we didn't
get that extra 30 minutes
i missed this uh only one time control
system where we don't have this
artificial extra 30 minutes i understand
purity of chess there was a lot of
debate back when i uh played the back
then it was called world championship in
2004 in libya and we used 90 30 but
there was a huge debate about whether
this was going to kill chess and kill
end games and that we really needed the
second time control and yada yada as a
commentator i hate the second time
control i feel like we have all this
excitement and then we take it away for
the next 25 minutes as the players
settle down think about their positions
now let me tell you what the engines
think about this one uh d5 was not the
engine's favorite move they did prefer
the move knight bc3 but in any case they
thought white was busted there was a
really nice move here rook c6 it attacks
c4 and the idea is that you're going to
prepare the move f5 in this position
nice and that hangs on to this pawn on
e4 it's a very nice dual purpose move
you don't want to take e4 and give up c4
at all but after d5 uh bishop e5
bringing the bishop into the game seems
to be like a very strong move uh the
rook on e1 as you guys were mentioning
doesn't go anywhere so play bishop b5
first take on the next move white's
pawns are a little threatening but
they're stuck and you can start
threatening the king side remember that
h3 is still very weak you can always
have possibilities of sacrificing
nobody's defending f3 just yet so it
does feel that black has a decisive
advantage not as big as i expected it's
only two and a half and if we go to the
linear game that is 0.00
no linear is not even a little bit
better you know
in the same game because after rook b4
i have to root before rook d8 if you
want to continue down that line
and we can take a pawn and then rook d2
and just a lot of counter play king f1
i'm still confused ambition b3
ah
that's okay
yeah i missed bishop b3 i thought this
doesn't do anything i thought i'd get
the king to iwani too and then the
counter play just runs out but right
bishop b3 is the move i missed
okay the defense of the pawn on
b2 as we get uh ready for our break here
it's just i i'm still sorry it's like
i haven't completely reset my mind from
that most amazing game between shaq and
richie for those of you who are joining
us light shame on you you've missed an
extraordinary battle and i urge you to
play the game over not with an engine
just try to understand the game and then
play it over with an engine and see what
you've missed this is one of the rare
times where i actually don't endorse
this the suggestion because you will you
will not understand the single thing
like ourselves in real time like like
ourselves and like most people
including the players i would suggest
and shaq which is brilliant i mean
including like
this is one of the games where
normally it's exactly how yassers
yasa says it's very very useful kind of
training exercise to to go through it
and try to figure out what's going on
but
it's an extremely tactical game where
things just
hang every move and everything hinges on
very very precise calculation and uh
yeah
try if you want but be prepared for this
appointment because yeah that one that
one was
not your normal game not your normal
game at all we'll see on the other side
of this break
[Music]
can you hear it
it's the sound of hope
and health
and strength
it's the sound of compassion
of open doors
where people and machines are in tune
and miracles occur
[Music]
it's the sound of personalized
healthcare
and active communities
it sounds like life
and it's what you hear
when you really listen
[Music]
[Music]
when you visit st louis you'll probably
want to watch the cardinals or the blues
what about after the game
heading back to the hotel would be a
major error
instead boogie through the city and
discover the music that gave the blues
their name at the national blues museum
broadway oyster bar or even the
legendary blueberry him so whether you
love the cardinals the blues or the
blues come play with us
and you guys know i can't play this
right
st lou is always exploring
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
and there we are uh with the potentially
the last portion of today's broadcast
with only two games remaining but both
of them still are undecided even though
the harvest machine does suggest that
our
optimism for the year's position is
slightly overstated but i still very
much like his position i still sort of
refuse to accept what alejandra is
telling me about it being completely
equal but
is very much in the in the driver's seat
against ali reserve roger but i will say
that
i did briefly glance at the machine
evaluation and this is one of the more
unclear minus threes you will see in
your life it's a minus three which you
definitely
don't feel assured in winning yeah
minus three i didn't realize it was that
severe when we left it we just left it
at the point that white had played the
move d5
get him going bishop e5 and came c5 and
peter this looks like a severe threat
that the pawn might run up the board but
you were assuring me as we were coming
on air that no uh yeah
under control reasonably easily
contained apparently by taking on h3 and
then bringing the queen back to f5 so
you don't take on e1 not yet i think i
think it can be postponed for quite some
time and here maybe i will take you will
take some yeah at some point it does
happen yeah like i will take i will play
queen of five
and this setup basically prevents d7
very very efficiently because you can't
really leave the the e3 square with the
queen it all pretty much always allows
some sort of uh discover check so you
have to put a lot of preparation into
safeguarding your king for
uh for the time being let's say you go
king b1 here which is very reasonable
yeah and black goes h6 no this this one
stays on a four the other one goes to h3
ah
and then potentially d3 and if you
imagine that rook getting transferred
from f6 over to d3 i'm
happy yeah i think i think once you you
picture that in your mind's eye you
start realizing why this position isn't
really all that great for white and not
only that but i'm you know even if i do
somehow get my king
over to the a file it's not like i've
made any great success no not to mention
that queen e6 is disturbing but i really
like what you're saying just just
block it on g3 and kind of stare at your
opponent right i mean the knight on d1
is not happy this pawn on c5 is
even this is
when you said minus three i didn't think
it was that good but once you put the
rook on d3 it feels like minus four it
was like
yikes uh very very bad all of these
moves all of these moves like the idea
of actually keeping this rook on f4 and
activating the other one uh it's not
that obvious and i i was absolutely
sincere when i said that
you know minus threes come in all shapes
and sizes and sometimes
like there's no counterplay there is
nothing really to be threatened off or
worried about and and you just know that
it will take some time because the
position still needs to be your
opponent's position still needs to be
deconstructed you still need to prevail
over some some defense but
you know what the end result is you know
how this movie ends right whereas here
you can still imagine like blundering
something and i know the knight from g1
gets activated picks up the knight that
upon e4 or you miss some way to create a
threat of d67 and have to switch to
defending right and it gets very unclear
so yeah this game is still very much
alive but jan of course is a heavy heavy
favorite
and i really do like so much this rook
h6 rook
h3 idea very very powerful and
i'm with you a hundred percent by the
way on the fabi game you can't convince
me that white's not for choice here
and it's justifying yeah okay i agree
i'm upon down but this night on e3 so
powerful at any moment it seems like
white could
go and start rounding up pawns on the on
the
queen side especially if i can play king
you want to prevent the counter play
that we saw earlier with the rook coming
to d2 and the bishop coming to v3
but
wow
the the engines uh
uh really confuse us yeah we'll we'll
get to that but in the meantime this is
the standings with the two games still
running uh we have wesley on a point and
a half
uh he will not be caught up because the
the people still playing are hanging on
a second online yeah can catch him up
right exactly uh yeah so so can you so
can you i don't know i don't know what
i'm talking about yeah i am
very good morning saint louis good
morning same place yeah exactly current
standing wesley the only person to win
we have three draws two remaining games
in our round two coverage
and uh wesley sitting pretty he said
he's good this is the type of tournament
he likes to play he gets an early plus
one he gets some positions where's he
even pressing his opponent like he did
against mvl today but just pulls the
brakes says so i don't want to take too
much risk this is the way that he plays
many many events and it works to
perfection there's you can't really
criticize results he is the defending
champion of the grand chess tour and i'm
sure that he knows how to win it he's
actually won it twice the other time in
2016 a very experienced player when it
comes to this format i think he's one of
the most dangerous round robin players
because if he gets an early point i mean
he's just not going to give you any room
to work with now this one in particular
this game between lanier and favi
i'm not here to convince anybody i'm
just here to read what the engine says
right the engine says zero
and that's what i'm gonna go with i am
of course
a grandmaster and i do think that white
has a lot of potential in this position
do you have more active rook the knight
on e3 blockading the stupid pawns the
king coming to f2 in the center and it
seems that black doesn't have any real
counterplay however the more i analyzed
it with the engine the more it turns out
that not only can white create very few
threats but the moment you start
creating threats i get immediate
counterplay i get immediate access to a
lot of squares the moment this rook
disappears from the d-file i'll take it
over
if you start hitting this pawn on b7
sometimes i'll just play the move bishop
c4 force you to give up your blockading
knight and then i'm going to be able to
penetrate or force the penetration of
the rook down the d-file within the
either d3 d2 or d1 you can't cover all
of them especially can't cover d3 so the
rook's going to get in somehow and
that's just going to provide enough
compensation for
the queen side basically which will
eventually disappear and it seems like
it's all headed to a draw now white has
a ton of ways to uh try to continue in
this position the move king of six is
now on the board he could play rook d6
check he could play rook b7 he could
just bring the king to e1 he could
continue with the move g4 so lanier
certainly has a lot of ways to keep up
some pressure against fabiano the only
thing is that the engines doesn't think
any of these moves are different than
any others they will all lead to the
same result
thank you for that alejandro we do have
a surprise move development somewhat
surprising in the game of the year and i
like what you said queen h3 queen f5 he
took on e1 immediately
you know
there's only only this much you can be
surprised at the idea of winning an
exchange with czech right
it's not going to be a bad move it's not
going to be it's not going to be a bad
move that's a terrible move
oh okay
i liked your queen h3 queen f5 the rook
wasn't going anywhere yeah the engines
hate this move they think that white is
close to equality
well
there we go there we go i just read
lines guys
we'll shoot you
don't worry we've got the slings and
arrows and spears we've got all kinds of
weapons okay i got stockfish
but
yeah you got to think
too is
why this is terrible the thing is you're
not taking h3 and the queen doesn't
return to this diagonal as effectively
actually the engine wants to go queen h7
queen f5 but why didn't you take the
pawn and do the same thing
it's a big deal right it's an important
pawn
well okay it's not that important but it
is a pawn and at some point in rook h6
rook h3 you might think it's a similar
scenario bond h3 will have its uses down
the low now it
it's still black for choice right but
you're gonna have to be a little bit
more creative on how to uh get an
advantage here the move rook have to
just flat out uh
helps
pops white because rookie two takes
takes and you could argue that white
black is still doing
well in this position you have this king
that's a little iffy queen f5 is coming
e3 queen e4 is also an idea e3 queen
takes a4 as an idea perhaps this is also
attractive to black but after d3
sorry d6 e3 b3 it says we know white's
hanging on black is still better but
it's not the crushing minus three minus
four advantages that we were looking at
with the other variations so
is that is black still better yes
definitely black is still for choice is
it the crushing you know we're giving
this game
not so much wow
yeah and the what what it boils down to
me is too is that
it it seemed like you could very easily
postpone it for one more move and and
pick up the pollen h3 uh while bringing
the bringing the queen to good squares
and exactly
uh
and yeah there has to be a reason for uh
for hurrying with this with this
sculpture and i get the feeling that
maybe jan
one way to explain it and i don't think
it's a good explanation i don't think it
works but one way to explain it i
immediately started thinking that maybe
he wants to go 91 rookie one rook of
three
queen takes e4 rook takes f2
i just don't think it works the point
here is that i've provoked queen takes
c4 meaning that after you take on f2 i
assume you take on f2 here i do
after rook takes f2 you no longer can
play rookie two because queen takes e4
wins the queen due to the pin along the
second wins the house yeah wins
everything meaning that you have to play
king somewhere uh and then uh you know
quote black has attack but
black probably doesn't have much of it
like king b3 for instance and then any
check along the third will be met by
rookie 3 and rook takes b2 king a3
any checklist yeah and because the
bishop is and the bishop is hanging in
every single position uh
so but if perhaps
f1 or something or queen somewhere f1
probably or h2
i am going to just be a little bit of a
spoiler sport rook f2 is already played
but if you play rook f3 he played rook
f2 immediately immediately if you played
rook f3 first just to uh just illustrate
yeah queen takes e4 is correct or it
takes f2 is correct but because you are
hanging both the bishop on e5 and the
reconnaissance king b1
yeah and actually i don't have to be
fast yes and actually the computer
thinks white's already better
ouch
again the d-pawn is ready it's ready to
advance you're going to get your
exchange back and it doesn't think that
black's lost but certainly not a lot of
fun he's negan f2 immediately which we
thought was the idea the only
explanation i have of why he didn't take
on h3 as i was analyzing is that you are
setting up yourself on a pin i was
wondering if it is for sure that you're
going to take only one because i could
play the move king b1 because queen d7
if all else fails i can go play queen
december yeah but then now i'm on my
rook right queen takes d5 i mean i'm
actually more interested in the d5 pawn
than i am in exchange yeah that f1 rook
is really sad but it is that's changed
that's true but it is an exchange and
the engines don't think that you should
go for the d5 pawn wow they actually
think that the best way to do this is to
defend your queen play the move rook h6
defend that guy so you can take only one
next move and perhaps this is something
that either young underestimated or
didn't thought it was a little too
artificial
perhaps the reason why he didn't go for
queen takes h3
and what do we have
after this very
quick uh knight takes e1 rook takes f2 i
assume takes f2
yeah knight of two already played yeah
he will take with the
rook i mean you could you could take
with the queen by the way wait you could
play rook f3
ah
so ah this is quite clever
i don't know if it's good but it's quite
clever we need for queen f2 and then
queen takes c5 check no queenie for rook
f2 no no we know we don't want that
position i think okay yeah yeah queen
queen photograph too that's exactly what
we wanted
that is that that's the thing that's the
one we wanted yeah we wanted because we
forced you to take on f2 first right
this is clever this is clever and the
engines are not in love with it but
that's because they're engines right and
they defend which i don't think it's
easy to do because they just want to go
queen takes e4
continue the analysis rook takes f2 yes
and the king d1
yeah which is i can see that
we don't have we don't have that very
many that many attackers and
with the bishop on the dark square you
do want to be occupying the light
squares here so i don't know rook or
queen e2 maybe this is terrifying it is
terrifying
look i just saw a game between richie
where there was a king in the open files
in the middle of the board with queens
and rooks and bishops
and knights and
it was a draw yeah
so i i'm not terrified anymore of
anything this is kind of sick yeah
rookie too and the engine just says
white is perfectly holding
wow
wow so rook f3 isn't all
we've got
which is the reason he's thinking right
otherwise you take one after with the
rook automatically i don't think he's
yeah the stutter step the stutter step
and uh i've analyzed this with the
engine so just to save us some time
queen e4 is the only move
yeah but no knight g4
there's no way you give up the queen and
survive
yeah yeah a big
i was just thinking sorry i i ju just
boldly pointing out five years at the
end of the game yeah that uh the desire
you know get this guy
rolling there is this queen f2 what
you're about to mention peter
and
lights out this yeah it's also
interesting to go uh knight takes e4
knight takes yeah vertex e3 rook takes
e3 yeah but it also runs into some
difficulties i think that if you got the
move d6 in yes exactly then black white
is actually fine but it doesn't come on
time black has to move f5
yeah their screen takes a fourth thread
so you have to play maybe knight c3
knight c3 is the only move
but here i take advantage of the
positioning of your pieces i take on c3
take on c3
queen f2 and that picks up c5 ah
that's nasty
clever just before i get in the d6
before you get in dc just on time right
yes and this is still a fight but i
think that should be weird this actually
isn't isn't though
in that position and we uh very much
continue playing
but yeah you get the feeling you
probably lose long term but it's yeah
the pawn gets to d6 because we have an
ip5 after well i'm just wondering if i
can try it yeah what yazar is saying is
probably quite good yeah yeah try to
defend block yeah the knight the knight
never actually gets to e6 the queen is
way too strong and yeah
just the concept of playing the stutter
step rook f2 takes rook f3 first that's
crazy that's really nice
we had a great round well and again just
to continue and the game still is in
full swing yes queen takes e4 rook takes
f2 king d1 do you want us is king
strictly the only strictly the only move
amazing because everything else is minus
seven and then queen takes h3 not the
best move not the best one yeah i'm not
going to spoil that much but it's not
the best move
oh
well geez my bishop is hanging
i can't have that many alt oh
plenty of choices yeah i don't know oh
my gosh
yeah it's it's it's very capable but it
goes queen h5
my brain hurts
no
that's terrible what really not my brain
yeah i
d6 and what i mean
all right all right i'll i'll play with
you guys yeah like okay these things
looks logical i'm not looking at the
engine right but it does
this rook f1 work and then queen takes
e5
no no but king e1 was my problem instead
of not d6 no because kingi one i think
gets some material off the board while
not losing any of the important pawns
yeah he's got knight takes night takes
knight takes e4 yeah so very humanly
understandable that he didn't believe
this is holding and now if jan plays
precisely white is in trouble right
isn't trouble the game is far from over
of course knight takes e4 on the board
now the i think the sequence is more or
less forced right okay the queen has to
go up right take c3 is forced it's not
the only move f5 however i feel it's so
logical you push your passport and you
give your king a loft you kick out at
night it's hard not to play the move f5
it's actually because in this particular
moment you force it to c3 so you play f5
then figure it out uh giving up a4 is no
good you have to play it here then you
kind of stumble onto this yeah you go
get to this position you realize check
doesn't matter if you got king d3 i
still have f4 and pick up the
c5 pawn later because rookie 8 king f7
uh
it's putting your rook on c8 he's a
little too happy right i think this pawn
will actually promote on the f file so
we have all of this going on i think f5
is winning the engine also thinks queen
f4 is winning but
um f4 yeah
i think it destabilizes the pieces it's
also a very attractive movement it is it
is actually right yeah because it
creates a very strong thread of queen h2
check apart from obviously the rook
hanging like rookie one queen h2
probably picks up a lot of materials so
you have to play either king d3 or
rookie two i'll drop my rook back i just
don't want to walk in the kingdom
and then we can
continue creating i guess maybe even
just queen of three queen takes h3 and
just go from there but that is
but that f5 move my goodness that f5
move is
uh and we're we're slowly returning to
time pressure right
these last games these last moves were
so complicated that both players are
approaching time control again 10
minutes for yan
and 13 minutes for laressa in an end
game that's still going to take a while
full of tricks knights are always tricky
the queen is very powerful these past
pawns yes it's not an easy end game to
play for either side even if it's
technically winning for one of them
yeah yeah it's also interesting to see
that jan
is not
asserting
his usual
time pressure
pressing his opponent by playing his
moves very forcefully and quickly but
rather he's he doesn't want to spoil he
doesn't want to spoil which definitely i
mean yeah you understand it completely
this like of of our two entirely crazy
games of the day this one is far less
perfect than the uh mijara opportunity
game but it's still a very very
interesting game against an extremely
strong opponent so he obviously
understands that
uh you know he very very
probably actually i would say that he's
doing quite well right now and he
doesn't want to make a
rush decision and uh and throw it all
away yeah it's it's terrible how you
know you can play almost a near perfect
flawless game and with one as you say
rash decision uh advantage just
disappears and terrible things happening
uh fabi uh versus linear any
developments going on in that one
there's a draw for on the table here
basically which i think you probably
take because if you allow king g4 it
suddenly maybe becomes a bit of a three
result game suddenly which you like it
would be a travesty of white
where actually to be in any danger of
losing like if you play rook g8 here or
rook d7 i go let's say rookie seven i go
bish p8
and if you don't give a check from e3
again i will play king g4 next move and
it it starts getting somewhat awkward if
i get that
i
i agree um because because it can
actually it can actually hide on h3 it's
like if we continue the hang on i wonder
the bishop there king loses the rook to
c8s okay ignore everything
okay so let me not
let me not help people under a bishop
let me be
no then i'm being too helpful where can
i move my rook where it's not terrible
okay there you go yeah so like g4 g3 and
i can actually play king h3 here and
hide out on h3 and then start
challenging the knight on g5 with bishop
c6 and trying to play either e3 check or
rook f6 check
and yeah these are the you know the kind
of a threatening threatening pictures in
your mind which you probably don't want
to be seeing so there's an even funnier
move after the move rook d7
rook c6 or something yeah rook this
happened rookie 8 is also equal rookie
8. yeah i was looking at rook c6 but
rook six that probably doesn't that's so
much calculation you have to calculate
the pawn end game
you have to calculate the rook and game
you have to calculate the rook moves
randomly
there's so much to calculate after
rookie eight rookie
but it's apparently okay we should be it
is also fine yeah no the the much more
end game there is the one that is
easiest to calculate because black
basically has such a majority on the
queen side and you get to defend e5 yeah
yeah easily yeah i don't know you know
one ending you know you're doing well
yeah and young in the meantime has
already played a five-minute just let us
help our parties i think black might be
winning here i have a feeling black is
maybe winning this game right
d6 king e6 i mean i think yeah i mean i
was thinking of doing it with the knight
c7 chuck oh yeah that's so that's a one
tempo e better for white but still
losing probably still losing yeah right
same same position pretty much yeah take
take and then king gets to e6 and
yeah the fact that black got b5 and day
four earlier in the game uh just
completely destroys any chances white
house of creating a passer on the
principle yeah normally you're happy to
have a queen side majority in such
positions but your majority is actually
not
um
a candidate you can't make a candidate
passer so you expect that in the current
position yeah i think we'll think for
quite some time and then go 93 check to
be honest i think he will realize that
he probably isn't better anymore and he
is down to four minutes again and he has
this yeah that would be a bit of a
mistake from fabio i don't think you
think it wasn't better ever
it wasn't better ever ever ever oh yes
in this game okay wow
what do we know about
and he's gone well he's 93 so we know
something you know 93 check and we
expect this to
draw especially with five minutes on the
clock right yeah i mean you you can
decline the the the rook trade but then
let's say if the bishop gets to c6 why
are you even better everything is
protected black his pawn up
it's very it will be very difficult to
explain to yourself why you're supposed
to be better if that happens i think we
stopped at the five minute yeah
like i got five minutes so like what and
there it goes
we expect a handshake soon-ish
check me two times baby
or something or something
we are expecting a three-time repetition
all right
we're waiting for the handshake so we
can focus on the young guy
let's be honest with our audience what's
going on here truly that is what we are
waiting for and i just have to say it i
mean
fabi looked like he's played the
this feshnikov his whole life or
something yeah he played this very well
this was really extraordinary and it was
just a very solid game with king f6 that
will be a three-time repetition and we
can finally
focus on the young game yeah yeah and to
let our producers know that this was a
fascinating game but we would like to
focus on the yan game
okay and by the way bishop takes c3 on
the board as we catch up
there's a pause here
which is kind of interesting why is
there a pause because you could take
with the king you could also consider
going rookie check first because king of
796 check is not that stupid
and the idea of making black breaking h7
might be worth something but
just pushing the king further away from
the g pawn
i'm kind of
i'm kind of stunned that king takes c3
by the way getting out of the queen a4
check but we're at the end of the day we
do have a dangerous passer don't we so
there is queen before check i get i get
it i i didn't say it was a good move i'm
just saying that there was an actual
alternative and if you take on c5 you
can play this six yeah i think maybe
queen takes a4
prior to giving a check
you could yeah prior to the check right
prior to the checkout i'm sorry and he's
taken with the knight on c3 which we
more or less expected only because he
delayed the decision
right
that we actually started looking at king
takes but knight takes e3 very
reasonable and we're back to
yeah queen of two will be played this is
an automatic yeah yeah but the move we
were kind of looking at rookie two queen
takes e5 and liking
yon's chances one more look at king d3
okay f4
let's hit you with the chest seven
and now we'll drop back with the rook
so that if you take my pawn i'll take
your pawn at the least and queen of two
as we predicted
on the board yeah
i'm
guessing maybe i can even maybe invest
it no that actually looks risky yeah i
wanted to play g5 but i'm very worried
about d67 there precisely that was on my
agenda yeah i'm very worried about the
67. with good reason d6 d7
is fast
yeah i think i think in practical terms
you you have to go
with king you have to go for this
because
the other person the university
exactly exactly so uh
king d3
uh f4 i think f4 has to be played so we
give this check you lure the king to f7
which i assume is required after rookie
four is there something
i mean we can try to actually queen the
f1 very quickly here right we can go
like f3 maybe queen g3 check first i
don't know which one is strong let's go
queen g3 check first well
wait a minute wait a minute now
f3
you're not queening with check anymore
yeah the 67 is what is once again
worrying me exactly 6f27.
and the queen the
emerging queen on g8 will actually
control all the queen d3 checks as well
which is very relevant
otherwise what might be better what
might be better there exactly yeah so
was it from the american cup where we
had uh two queens yeah that was the
aronian game with uh black side it's an
incredible game lastly promoted to two
yeah
he's playing g3 yeah he has played and
the whole point is as peter was
mentioning
hugely relevant that the queen on d8
covers all the squares otherwise queen
one d3 would have been winning yeah iii
and simply queen takes e4 if all else
fails but none none of that works but
here the point is is that white king is
actually
enjoying a lot of stuff i'm taking white
here and queen e8 may really harass the
black
uh king and again we do have we're up to
date with the players
after this move king d3 we're looking
at f4
which we just have on the board he's
played a four yeah i think rookie rookie
four is very very smart here it actually
required
the engine just prefers going to h7
which peter was kind of suggesting not
in this position
that
you may just want to tuck your king away
as opposed to having it exposed but king
f7 was a very human move yeah it looks
extremely natural but after rookie four
i'm very stuck because yeah the counter
play comes extremely quickly after
rookie
think you have to be foreign precise
here only the move queen g3 retains
winning chances
and after once again king c2 i believe
it was the move f3 but let me double
check on that real quick maybe takes h3
here or something yeah just stop d7 f3
d6 and
f3 d6 the six and take on h3 take on
h3 yeah before or after giving a check
on the second rank
you could
push my king if you prefer to be three
and then yeah but not none of this is
remotely trivial no no
even this position is not remotely
trivial
i wouldn't be able to tell you that
white is for sure losing this hand game
no i
yeah i mean after move rookie seven
check it would be still crazy but we uh
have a special guest in bucharest we're
gonna jump over
to christian and fabiano
thank you yasser yes we are indeed here
with fabiano caruana fabi first of all
welcome back to bucharest welcome back
to the studio as well tell us a bit
about your first couple of days
experience here in bucharest yeah the
first two games were pretty interesting
i mean especially today i thought it was
a super
interesting game it was really tough
it's one of those i mean i chose an
opening which is
risky but also
quite ambitious
and
i think like we were playing reasonably
well i was quite happy with my position
from the opening
but uh at some point it got quite
dangerous and even at the end i was i
was rather worried about the end game
but i didn't see
anything for him let's quickly go
through the critical moments which ones
uh
how did you feel after the opening let's
say yeah i thought i equalized um
i'd say
i mean it's such a complicated line
and i think we were more or less both on
our own after a3
he i mean the main move was h4 but i
guess he wasn't ready for this
theoretical battle and he played a
decent move but was he surprised by your
caster instead of bishop g5 which seems
to be
the tendency nowadays well they're yeah
they're both very popular moves bishop
g5 i played
before i played it against alexander
grishouk
and he's faced it many times as well
this is one of his i mean he's one of
the biggest experts of the line i'm sure
he knows that h4 is the main move here
but he probably just wasn't ready
without having
probably rehearsed the lines recently
right and the a3s is a fine move anyway
um
yeah i think i played normally and he
also played normally i was okay knights
see it is unnecessary but it's quite
ambitious because i'm trying to keep
more pieces on the board while if i
make another move let's say
yeah i just wait for the trade on d5
and uh and we get a position where white
has a tiny tiny edge while here i was
hoping for
a more interesting position i feel like
you got quite ambitious was this your
strategy going into the game to try to
complicate matters well i was not shying
away from a fight in general um and i
guess he wasn't either in fact i
overestimated my position i thought i
was already taking the initiative here
um but bishop d3 and f3 is excellent i
mean he showed very good understanding
uh and here it's it's like a little bit
more pleasant for one i guess i still
thought i should be totally fine
but uh yeah after a few moves i didn't
entirely like my position
um
[Music]
okay i was kind of happy that
it's rather simplified i didn't think
like i should be
hugely worse but of course white is the
one who presses here
and uh then we both got into time
trouble
did he surprise you with his decision to
open things up with f4 like this
i was sort of thinking it's a natural
move i thought why i could play knight
d5 why could play f4 or white could wait
but waiting i see the computer
recommends like h3 here is
it's not so easy to do more of a slower
game and yeah make the best moves and
then play four at some point yeah of
course it's probably the right approach
to put pressure on black but
um but it's very natural for him to
play in a concrete manner
uh but here i think i already felt like
i was fine i didn't think i should be
worse because my queen on e5 is
extremely stable
and then i played i don't know maybe
if i was not the best move but i missed
rook for this is an excellent move i was
mainly looking at queen g5 king h7 and i
thought i have a good position f i'd
play it for myself do you get the four
in play but this is an excellent move um
okay fp4 i didn't really want to do
this was a slightly weird move
um
i guess there's some nice tactics like
knight five i probably gf also but rook
five is nice and if ef queen e3
and then king h1 yes
left yeah
very nice so okay of course this is uh
fantasy stuff i mean he'll he'll never
fall for this hry i mean he was playing
really well despite his time trouble
um i wasn't sure if i want to take or
not i thought the end game is a bit
dangerous but i also had no time and i
thought okay i should make a draw here
um who was playing uh for an advantage
in the end game did you feel like you
were pressing or he was probably of
course it's clear i mean uh it's clear
what can only be better if we trade
works i can't like ever break through
yeah despite being a pawn
like um okay some i mean i would i would
be happy to make the trade of brooks
like here
i mean it's
uh you know it's a fortress yeah
it's clear that this is just a draw uh
so white has that at any moment you want
i was actually thinking that root b7 was
interesting because i should play bishop
c4 because rook d rook g2 doesn't invade
his knight only holds everything
together
he takes
plays with b4
and okay i guess it's a draw but it's
still quite a sharp end game because he
actually wins all my pawns on the queen
side
i was thinking like here and i'm going
to play g5
take take let's say
c4
and then i get this rook g8 and i also
understand why he didn't want to go for
this stuff you know i think this is like
this position where peter was saying
that this becomes a three-year-old game
yeah yeah it's probably a draw but
it's very understandable he didn't want
to go for this but it's what i was also
worried about because
you know it's such a weird looking game
right but he can't ever move his rook
from the fourth because e3 comes uh so i
could probably just oscillate rook d8 or
g8 and it'll be a repetition
uh and he played a dangerous looking
move brook d6 rookie six
because it's almost winning like if uh
rook d7
um bishop v8
um rook d8 and the only movie is bishop
c6 i think actually i see like every
movie's draw i didn't realize this but
okay bishop c6 and 93 king of six and
there's the draw sorry to interrupt you
fabiano the other game is about to
finish thank you very much for joining
us keep the energy up and we'll see you
in the next few rounds thank you nice
back to you
thank you uh christian as we uh
pick up the action uh here looks like uh
jan
is steering uh the win home um
interesting at this moment f4 uh there
was no rook e8 check yeah he chose to do
it with the king steel on g8 i guess his
reasoning is very understandably he
wants the d78 queen to be a check so he
already that is felt that forcing the
king away from the eighth actually harms
his chances because uh in all of those
positions we're discussing if let's say
the f1 twins and the g-pawn queens he
wants d8 to be played with a check
and after queen g3 check i think the
position was still potentially
i don't know if holdable is the right
word but difficult to win but kingdom is
a mistake and now there is a very
beautiful line which i suspect may have
been missed
after uh f3 has been played i assume his
intention here is to play d6 right and
then black wins by playing quincy to
check for no no you play quincy to check
first to force the king onto a poor
square
uh
yeah so i think he wants to go king e3
here after g7
and
and this is where kind of a nasty
surprise awaits him because f1 check
with the knight
under promote under promotion wins on
the spot because then the queen checks
from g2 and picks up the pawn on g7 and
you ended up knighting the pawn yeah uh
that's nasty that is nasty but it's also
completely winning yeah you must have
forgotten that about the move f1 equals
knight i don't see any other explanation
why to go to d2 instead of a c
to look like a strange choice of a
square because you see two b3 is what
you want to do to hide away from all the
checks right
so this was the
this was the moment of truth where it
all goes wrong king d2 double question
mark
double question mark but the engine's
already thought that it is eventually
winning for the black side had he played
the superior house even if he played the
superior king c2 they go down the line
it's f3 d6 queen takes h3 takes a while
but double question mark to me always
implied that it changed the evaluation
requisition it doesn't change the
evaluation of position still winning for
black it just makes black's life a lot
easier i'd give it one question mark i
see so king d2
and we're expecting three after we've
already played yeah and after d6 i think
finding q2 checkers should not be much
of a problem for uh for yam because it's
a it's a very nice inclusion
right uh forcing white into some very
uncomfortable uh contortions to just to
prevent the the the pawn queening with
check
yes so it's lighting this checkmate
nightingale
there's just nothing to do no no a
minute and 20 for uh alireza
and less than that now
counting
as f3 on the board he's
he's realizing i think he's now
realizing that the thing is
yeah i think it's a knight
but there's no way there's no way back
you can't if you don't play d6 here the
f pawn is just way too quick you can't
really you can't really make a waiting
move of any sort in this position it's
not a position where you have the luxury
of
not playing the most forcing move every
single time
he must be looking at knight d1 though
and then knight e3 i can just take them
tonight right and then you take it even
actually three is winning even uh yeah
there might be something great yeah
because he's played this c6
and this is the moment for yon to find
queen g to check not the only winning
move but cringey two looks like the
movie like clean
they're the cleanest but
what's the other choice queen g5
apparently is also awkward enough for
white
queen g5 i i would never look at that
move i think queen g2 i find the win and
we go with it
one win per game that's all we need
that's all you need yeah
yeah we should probably stay with that
with that view because uh we've
described the position i think in enough
detail to just watch them watch them
play it out queen g2
he clearly is leaning into quincy to
check he's already almost played it i
think he's pretty sure he's winning but
he once again stakes a high enough
considering as gary said all of this is
kind of rehearsal
for for the candidates so he knows how
important this is he knows how much of a
confidence booster it would be to beat
alireza with the black pieces here
um
absolutely
very very quick and a very very good
calculator when he's playing well and
today i think in general yes there were
some there were some decisions which the
computer is quite sharply critical of
but
like the general plan for the game and
the the ideas he had seen are are very
good and i think it's you know
you you take you take a win like this
over earlier
any day of the week yeah and for me i
must say i was a little bit confused it
seemed like
uh alireza was playing this game as if
he had to win
at all costs it did seem a little like
he's gone 92 and now f2 ends the game on
the spot yeah you don't you don't go fp2
you go after yeah v2 also works yeah but
i think f2 f2 is yes cleaner because
queen g5 check exists
f2 i think on f2 d7 and then
yeah because you take on dna with chuck
yeah yeah the line we're looking at is
um f2 uh f2 d7 queen g5 check rook f4
you promote to a queen
no no i wanted like a queen's king c2
here or something
but that still doesn't work because the
knight will be hanging on e2 rook f4
and then f1 yeah f1 and uh d8 quintex v8
is a check sadly for what
i mean this is like shades of richie's
game you know like check check i mean
like what uh
f2 by the way yeah f2 which is
definitely the most precise
yeah
by the way that's
that's that's a stylish move it's a
stylish
get out of here
nice
uh why didn't he want the stinking
knight i like stinking knights he wants
to stinky rock yeah he wants to be more
more mature
just tell me what this thing is ii i
think is the point yeah rook takes e2
this is not just like no no it's it's
winning it's winning
we don't we don't have to like yeah
anyway yeah f takes a two was definitely
a winning move okay uh but f2 is cleaner
f2 finishes the game faster
with lost counter play
uh by the way i wanted to ask you about
that
three
seconds
and ah plenty of time
yeah with two seconds on the clock just
king age 77 25 check now wins wins on
the spot yeah this doesn't really
improve your your chances of survival
no
i just wanted to ask you uh peter that
we we quote uh the great masters all the
time it is nice
uh one of the things is i i've come to
realize that i've really quoted michael
tall a lot he had some wonderful
witticism yes absolutely yeah were you
raised on uh michael tall's games or
um
he's always he's always been one of my
one of my biggest biggest chess idols uh
throughout my career i've
admired him from afar i've never spoken
to him while we were what really we i i
just sort of started becoming a chess
player
when yeah when he said he passed away
the closest i got to him i was like
within maybe 20 meters away from him
playing the
uh alejan open alongside the alejan
memorial tournament in 92 which i think
boris gelfand won but i was playing in
the open i was nowhere near good enough
to you know be right you know anywhere
near the round robin and he he came to
visit one day he wasn't playing in the
tournament he was already i think ill
enough to i think to not be playing but
uh he came to visit one day and i saw
him and it was a kind of a thrilling
experience even to see him from from
afar but
never spoke to the man okay and we do
have king he's going king of seven king
of six which i think is unnecessary but
also he's completely winning doesn't
really change anything at all
yes yes king f8 seems a bit easier but
yeah i mean i can't criticize this
honestly i would have gone king h7 i
don't want to give any more checks and
that is missing
good enough it's gonna be enough king f6
and
ian
bounces on the trampoline ties for first
with wesley so that's right a brilliant
victory there for giannis garrison black
with black against the player that he's
going to be facing in a month and a half
in the candidates quite the rehearsal
that is quite at the rehearsal it's just
stamping his foot on him right i beat
you with black what are you going to do
about it the next time we meet this is a
great result for jan wow yeah
[Music]
wesley spoke yesterday about the
confidence builder it was for him that
he won a classical game he was
explaining that was having some troubles
and that he felt really good about his
victory this will be a
a very very good feeling for absolutely
yeah
yeah winning a game like this is going
to be a a very good feeling uh despite
the fact that he will come back home and
he will realize that there are some you
know quote unquote chances missed and
not everything in this game was entirely
precise but
it was full of ideas it was full of uh
you know vim and vigor and things right
starting with the v but were you
startled by
um
alireza's
decision to play for the win
not to take a repetition he was playing
he was pushing the envelope
he must have missed something at this
point this point where he goes knight d1
kind of traps his own pieces in the
background this was the part we were all
expecting him to go for the move knight
d5 and i think it's just a little bit of
inexperience sometimes we forget that
this 2800 is 18 years old and sometimes
he hasn't built up that muscle memory to
say hey this is mu 40 if he got rookie 6
i can just go back that's the same
position and then let me think on mu 40.
let me see what i do when i get my extra
30 minutes instead he rushed his
decision he played the move 91 and maybe
he missed something maybe he was afraid
of something in this position i'm not
really sure what because rook f2 knight
f6 is a very easy calculation um you
have to go to e6 basically no other move
of the rook is better than the e6 so you
have to go back and then you can repeat
the position and then decide it turns
out the knight d1 was a horrible move
for his position he must under must have
underestimated the danger of this knight
coming to f3 and simply trapping the
rook on e1 it's just so awkward the way
that the game went on right knight d1
rook here queen e3 move 40 by the way
not a very good move knight f3 and he
must have realized around here wait a
second i can't move my rook right
because the other one is hanging that's
it's just such a cold shower something
that would not have happened he had he
repeated once right so i i think just a
little bit of an experience here and
what was really a fascinating game it
was tactics everywhere there were ideas
the weak king sacrifice of pawns you at
some point we could have sacrificed an
exchange into pawns for black so many
things to calculate so many ideas to
evaluate and i think the players
navigated it relatively well
of course they're not engines and it was
a fun and entertaining game i think for
jan this is a great win but
i it was a game that could have gone
either way
exactly absolutely yeah and i think
uh yeah the standings will be on your
screen right now and as you can see with
this victory uh january she catches up
to to wesley so we have a
uh diane virat up top there uh and then
uh a huge die for third with uh
six people six people on 50 and there's
a couple of people in the miners uh uh
my pick for the eventual winner of the
tournament
ali reza and i think uh anastasia's big
for the winner of the tournament
uh we're not doing that hot in the
prediction right now nobody got napo
nobody got wesley right right uh and
lavonne
may have felt like he missed a chance as
well today it should so i sure felt like
he should have done more with the
position he got that ending that he got
yeah i think he let dak off a little too
soon and i think it really was
his opponent's time pressure especially
especially that tricked him into it
because here gary was analyzing this
position with christian pointing out and
we pointed out too the rook takes the
161 rugby two gives black really serious
winning chances not just because of the
clock situation and the fact that dak
had to defend an unpleasant endgame but
you know the more you analyze it the
more unpleasant it gets even an end game
that i i started to play around with
this with my phone a little bit my phone
engine even this end game and bringing
the king to f to d5 was not so easy to
hold you never really had the
possibility of going d5 and just drawing
a three versus three with a one here
because your structure's already ruined
i can already take it in many situations
so this would have given black very real
winning chances and i think with dax
time pressure by this point this is
already moved 37 you still have a few
moves to make
how do you put your pawns together what
are you going to do with this king
coming into the board do you actually
play g5 at some point what do you do
here wouldn't have been easy for the
romanian player to figure out and i
think that levon because of his
opponent's time pressure played this
move rook c5 a little bit too quickly
and dak was able to
hold together his position and obtain a
valuable draw yeah that h4 move uh
the inclusion of h4 was very very
valuable
yeah
and
once again we we end the day with only
one decisive game but once again i don't
think you can you can complain about the
quality
of display uh really full of content
yeah and uh i i still despite the fact
that jan won this brilliant game against
i am still saying that the moment of
rapport game was
was my game of the day today
and we do have the winners interview
from bucharest
thank you peter yes we are here with a
very happy victor of uh the round that
is neponiashi after an incredible
victory against the surging alireza
first of all tell us your thoughts about
this game
well it
feels good to finally win some game in
classical chess yeah because last one i
guess was uh
in september we just in september yeah
so it's of course pleasing and
yeah the end game uh
you know i can say i i became you know a
big expert in this queen against knight
and games here all sorts of ccn games
and also
i dedicated quite some time you know
playing and then some quite some time
studying
so you win sometimes you lose yeah okay
here it is
yeah thanks take us through the game uh
he started off with this bishop's
opening did he surprise you with this at
all or no not really so bishop's opening
is probably the only sensible way to
avoid petrov
unless you know not playing e4 at all uh
so well uh i believe it's more or less
known but he came up with an interesting
plan
normally uh i believe normally white
just castles here
but okay knight f1 is is a nice idea
yeah just to
uh
gain some uh some time yeah so you're
using perfect okay if one square is
still valid right yeah this was just
very curious to me
and here well i couldn't uh you know uh
remember any lines so that's why i just
decided to play out of common sense so
bishop f4 and queen b8 sometimes is
is more or less a normal plan but uh
yeah here after h3 well i wasn't sure so
i could also go for i don't know
something like g5 and then um try to
maneuver with my knights but
i also put like uh okay rookie won't
want you know one harm probably rookie
is not such a good move in these
positions as far as i know but here uh
you know i couldn't resist uh to play so
some sometimes i can push e3 at least
from a practical yeah and here uh
yeah but sometimes you probably you need
rook on f8 to push a five yeah but uh in
in some future but this future you know
and he started playing some weird moves
and now well what he did was uh
i mean quite interesting so you know at
first glance it looks like white is
going to lose by force
but uh more time i spent
you know harder it was to understand
what what's my
what's my plan so here i think this is
quite principle
and this is also principle
and okay it takes
takes okay here of course 94 was
very interesting so knight f4 uh bishop
b7 because uh i believe bishop before
then probably bishop g5 is winning like
maybe something maybe something else
but this was the move that gary actually
when he came to the studio proposed as
well yeah but jackie this position is
quite curious i mean i couldn't i mean
this is surely some very nice
compensation but
uh you know i couldn't see anything
forced and uh so if you take it covers
yeah if i take uh i probably lose so
that's why if i play bishop before and
take on b2
but here's something like queen f1 so
this would well this was not self-views
yes sir probably you know if you play
with some nice precision
even computer like i would say yeah you
find something like bishop f4 but
i mean it never never seemed obvious to
me so that's why i came up with this
bishop d5 so more as controllable knight
d5 so here well i do not really know
what to do so queen h4 queen g5 so i go
ig five like the right yeah c4
but uh
yeah here you know of course i could go
for knight four which would be like uh
ten times more logical but you know i
wasn't sure about how good is this
position for me
queen e2
and yeah it should be obviously good but
you know it looks like i don't know
fortress let's say yes so that's why i
don't have a way to break
at least nothing hey i couldn't i
couldn't find so i thought like okay
it's very smart to keep the deeply nice
because initially i just wondered that
here i can you know i wanted to play e3
and f takes e3 knight f4 and therefore
that's very smart ah also h4 here is
good for complete status but here i am
generally
i wasn't happy about this move so white
obviously escapes but you know some kind
of bridging cells are here
so
well i just couldn't understand what's
going on sir okay the computer was
saying something like we need two yeah
queen of two is the move i didn't like
because e3 i just completely missed king
the only one yeah yeah that's probably
was the thing i missed and i mean that's
quite obvious but uh not not for me i
don't know not for me yeah it's not for
me it's for ali did you speak about the
game just very very briefly you got it
and then he played this queen to b3 well
i feel like you're kind of slowly
getting back into the game
i had no idea so here
i mean
clearly the pawn is a pawn and all the
end games are somewhat decent and also
he has these 97 ideas so i wasn't sure
about you know this bishop frequent h5
so where do i find this compensation for
an exchange
so probably this part
wasn't that bright by me but
here i believe that suddenly
the position is not so clear so
queen g4 okay rookie six and rook f6 uh
very sound maneuver probably here it
doesn't work uh you know that great but
uh i was literally shot on time already
and uh you know i couldn't
i couldn't see if you know if free move
is so smart yeah so i didn't really like
my position right so v6 i mainly was
concerned about knight c3
uh bringing the knight to d5 it's very
sound so probably i should put something
like e3 and just open things and
see what happens
but yeah clearly white is
in in driver's seat here
but king d1 i think
he started
making some
[Music]
not the optimal moves here so here after
rook f6 i finally got some some idea
rookie one so here you know uh it was
never you know lied to blunder
something like 97 but here well comp is
so happy and you even hear this king of
faith being afraid okay
that's just too much for me yeah
[Music]
yeah who could uh but by the way i
calculated something like this yeah but
okay i just saw 97 in the photo okay
that's too much for me engine stuff yeah
and here well i mean given the time
factor
you know i think we didn't play that
badly but i think now black is slightly
pressing
so it's
it should be analyzed but i felt like
i'm doing some sensible things
once you got your knight all the way to
f3 it already felt like you're gaining
full control yeah here he should play 95
so this we're going to repeat no i was
going to repeat once and then probably
okay i would pass the time control so
probably i would do something like
rookie
6. and uh maybe here rogue h6 i don't
know
but maybe that's not so smart but but of
course knight g5 was the move but after
91
i mean okay i was
obviously shocked
a bit too passive
yeah and here uh well rook take rook
takes h3 was maybe even better but i
thought like all right i'm winning an
exchange at last cost something
get some uh you were down one pawn the
whole game now at least yeah yeah what's
the advantage it was nice to get some
you know
logically yeah yeah so d5
c5 so here i'm not sure of
bishop uh e5 okay c5
probably that that was the position i
was aiming for but i couldn't just
evaluate it so i mean obviously i should
be doing very nicely but uh you know
some positions uh can arise which are
really hard to evaluate so
let's say if i just take an h3 here okay
something like king b1
and then if he plays calmly like knight
to c3 and d6 probably he always will
have some counter play so i decided to
clear you spent like 10 minutes or so
around at this point and what was the
concrete variation that you calculated
i didn't calculate anything i was just
using the in between the lines i have
seen uh you know
before so okay this rook takes f2 i
wasn't sure about this end game
so queen f4 but uh okay e3 is not so
good because queen e3 and b3 and um
white escapes
so queen f4 is something i wanted to
play
but then okay
oops
but then i uh at last came up with some
brilliancy there we go
uh
so i really wanted to make this line
work i mean uh
here i wanted to play rook f3 queen e4
rook f2 but here of course he can play
king d1 so he's not obliged to take on
that
so that's why i uh i was very happy when
i found this you know intermediate move
in internet so
yeah 94 was a little bit of panic but in
my opinion okay queen e4 rook f2 king d1
is probably the only one only but this
looks so ugly for white i don't really
believe this works but
yeah if it works and probably he has to
find like rookie too or okay if it works
if it works doesn't work so what can i
do but i was like very optimistic about
uh this position but yeah okay that's
that's some brilliance and he definitely
felt quite uh yeah pressure that's very
nice this is a very nice practical
chance i would say so
it takes takes a five i actually thought
it should be closer to a draw but you
know move per move it's not so easy to
make things work yesterday of course i
think the move
between c5 and here rook d2 so i wasn't
sure about this position so perhaps i
should if i want to fight for something
they play like this like this
yeah and this position
somehow it seemed to me that okay white
will in some
miracles way bring knight to i don't
know f7 or b7 or e6 but now it seems
like okay at least now i see the
revolution so probably knight is not
going anywhere yeah
yeah but uh this
king d3 f4
i
i have you know a lot of different um
checks like queen g3 to
uh to set up some some traps on the uh
all the way yeah so king c2 was maybe
more precise if kingdom is probably
losing
f3 let's say d6
uh maybe a check maybe queen takes h3 so
i thought like this position will will
rise and probably will still have some
good goodwin chances but like i wasn't
really sure about
the revolution so maybe white
is in time to make to build a fortress
maybe not but
at that point it's not you know my
business actually
john a huge victory for you with the
black pieces against probably the
hottest prospect out there right now
what does this victory mean to you
it's nice to play you know a game with a
good result but i don't think it means
anything special just
i'm
you know not so happy about
uh equality once again but uh yeah it
was a big mess so at least it was fun
thank you very much for joining us keep
the energy up and we'll see you in the
next few rounds thank you guys back to
you
thank you uh christian congratulations
john yeah congratulations to y'all and
also i want to say very kind of an
interesting interview in which he keeps
on saying i didn't understand anything
and uh you know the game is full of
holes it keeps on showing us lines which
we found with the help of the engine and
giving the entire precise lines which
which are just right yeah showing great
judgment yeah
well all the same all the time
i missed
i know nothing about this game i see
this pieces for the first time in my
life yeah exactly is this the trophies
this is this first place
as we see our current standings two
players tied for first wesley and jan
everybody else has made draws except for
the two players at the bottoms of the
standings
and as we uh
prepare ourselves for tomorrow to take a
look at our schedule yeah we've got
three more rounds to go until the rest
day and then four more rounds to uh to
to end the tournament with potential
playoffs on
saturday if they are required
and a quick look at our predictions as i
think nobody had uh has our two leaders
i'm i'm happy with fifty percent i'm
happy it's gonna be yeah i'm undelegated
that'd be awesome everybody's happy
peter is a rough day for us yeah we need
to catch up with me me and us i don't
necessarily we need to start picking up
points there but
and let's jump to
romania for our final thoughts christian
and anastasia
well uh what a day it was uh guys uh one
of those days in which uh i have the
engine alejandra i'm sure had the engine
as well and we were not understanding
absolutely anything that was happening
in either that ritual report game
against mamedyaro but also this complete
mess of a game between uh firuja and
yaniponnyashi but still such amazing
games filled with excitement and i'm
sure this trend is going to continue as
the tournament progresses anastasia how
about yourself yeah i enjoyed it so much
sometimes the dreams come true we
actually wanted to have two big fights
and we had them today right i mean it
was so much fun also i was so happy to
hear gary kasparov thoughts on those
games and also the players explain a lot
of things it was interesting to see
shakira mamijarov disappointment over
the result and then when he actually
realized that all the way it was not so
clear the whole position even though the
king was running around the board of
richard so i think it was a lot of fun
today right absolutely a lot of fun and
i'm sure the fun is going to continue
guys back to you in the studio in st
louis well thank you very much see you
both that was just so uh
such an enjoyable day alejandro my
goodness i mean the predictions of which
were going to be the games of the day
were right on point but for me these
battles between mamedyarov and rapport
are going to be always headlining two
games that i've seen from them two
spectacular battles one one by mamadarf
here at the singh field cup and now this
draw in bucharest just had me
electrified i'm loving this matchup i'm
loving the games that we're seeing from
romania it's gearing up to be a great
event thank you alejandro peters was
great calling the action with you it is
today and we're looking forward to
tomorrow as well it is it is despite
only two games being decisive out of ten
this is the best fantastic first two
days of the event and i think it's only
going to get better so stay tuned same
time same place tomorrow see you
tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited
you